[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver pour vivre le temps fort de la
semaine au sénat les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
avec une nouvelle formule pour cette
séance c'est désormais tous les
mercredis à 15 heures une heure des
changes direct entre les sénateurs et le
gouvernement
les analyses les réactions fait avec
alice bardot dans l'hémicycle et
alexandre poussard dans la salle des
conférences
on se retrouve tout de suite les maires
agresser les maires insulté le sénat a
lancé une grande consultation 3800 mer
ont répondu 92% d'entre eux ont été
victimes d'incivilités d'injures ou même
d'agressions physiques on débat dans un
instant des préconisations du sénat et
du gouvernement
enfin que pense le sénat du budget 2020
ce budget du pouvoir d'achat les styles
filer le déficit et comment les
collectivités vont bien pouvoir faire
face à la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation c'est l'objet de notre duel
à 14h30
et n'hésitez pas à commenter cette
émission avec le hashtag qu à g et on va
tout de suite rejoindre alice bardot
dans l'hémicycle du sénat alice dans une
heure maintenant vont commencer les
questions d'actu alors comment ça va se
passer
eh bien tu aimes aujourd'hui les
sénateurs expérimente la nouvelle
formule des questions au gouvernement
désormais ce sera tous les mercredis de
15 heures à 16 heures
mais aujourd'hui petit parc eu la
particularité puisque un hommage sera
rendu à jacques chirac par le président
du sénat gérard larcher
puis par le premier ministre edouard
philippe alors un hommage particulier
pour les sénateurs de droite jacques
chirac ayant fondé le rpr l'actuel
devenu l'actuel party les républicains
mais également pour gérard larcher qui a
été nommé deux fois ministre par
l'ancien président de la république donc
jacques chirac
on se retrouve donc tout à l'heure tam
avant les discours en hommage
à jacques chirac décédé jeudi dernier à
l'âge de 86 ans merci beaucoup aller ce
pour toutes ces explications et on passe
à présent au premier thème de cette
émission je vous le disais en titre les
maires agressé c'est l'élu le plus
proche de ses administrés le plus
populaire de la république pourtant les
maires font face à de plus en plus
d'incivilités d'injures et d'agression
après la mort du maire de signes l'été
dernier la commission des lois du sénat
a lancé une grande consultation leur
état des lieux et préconisations sont
résumées par béatrice faisant ils sont
3812 avoir répondu à la consultation
lancée par la commission des lois du
sénat le 13 août dernier sur les 36000
maires de france sollicité 10,9 pour
cent de participation
cette amère sur dix est le premier
constat est affligeant
92% des élus qui ont répondu au
questionnaire ont déjà été victimes
d'incivilités d'injures de menaces ou
d'agressions physiques
or moins de la moitié vont jusqu'à
porter plainte des plaintes qui
n'aboutissent à la condamnation pénale
que dans un cas sur cinq objectifs de
cette consultation mesurer l'insécurité
des maires pour apporter des
propositions présentées par la
commission des lois
les maires parce qu'ils détiennent une
parcelle de l'autorité publique sont
exposées sont nombreux à se sentir seul
a bordeaux n'est et sans moyens pour
lutter contre les violences dont leurs
réponses au questionnaire atteste qu
elles sont très nombreuses
aujourd'hui il faut leur donner un coup
d'arrêt un plan d'action donc qui
s'articule autour de douze mesures
visant à renforcer l'autorité des maires
conforter leurs moyens d'action et mieux
les protéger dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions il faut qu'il y ait davantage
d'amande qu'ils soient pas des amendes
pénales c2d prononcé par tribunal mais
les amendes administratives
c'est à dire prononcé par le maire la
commission va d'ailleurs amender le
projet de loi engagement et proximité
afin d'y intégrer les dites mesures déjà
transmises au gouvernement afin qu'elle
soit appliquée au plus vite
alors face à cette violence accrue
contre les maires cette montée des
injures et des incivilités les réponses
apportées par le gouvernement dans le
projet de loi sur le statut de l'élu
sont elles à la hauteur et qu'elles sont
aussi les préconisations du sénat on en
débat avec nos invités françois noël
buffet bonjour vous êtes sénateur l ère
du rhône vice président de la commission
des lois et je précise que vous avez été
maire pendant 20 ans maire d'oullins
également sur ce plateau arnaud de
belenet bonjour aux sénateurs la
république en marge de la seine et marne
également vice président de la
commission des lois
j'ai gamer pendant près de quinze heures
vous avez aussi des mairies on a les
invités par faible puisque également sur
ce plateau joséphine delpeyrat vous êtes
animatrice nationale des réseaux locaux
élu local et enfin aurélien et d'actes
et sur ce plateau
bonjour vous êtes rédacteur en chef
adjoint au courrier des maires d'abord
et bien on l'a on a entendu un des
extraits tout à l'heure et de cette
conférence de presse qui s'est tenue au
sénat cette conférence de presse
elle portait sur un certain nombre de
témoignages qui ont été reçus par le
sénat je voudrais en citer quelques-uns
ça donne une idée du constat exemples de
ces témoignages de mères j'ai reçu neuf
coups de couteau et j'ai été annoncé
mort au journal de 20 heures voilà ce
qu'ils ont pu lire les sénateurs
également tentative de meurtre en 2004
avec une voiture comme arme pour me tuer
deux interventions chirurgicales plus de
six mois d'arrêt et puis il y en a eu de
nombreux en des témoignages
voici un troisième que nous avons
sélectionné incendie de ma maison la
nuit du 1er janvier 2013 alors que je me
trouvais en pologne dans le cadre d'un
jumelage ma maison a été entièrement
détruite par un incendie
françois noël buffet ce sont des
témoignages qui sont glaçantes sur tous
les cas le reflet d'une réalité liées à
la consultation qui a été fait et
organisé par le sénat auprès de auprès
des maires et des adjoints consultation
quand même qu'il ya un certain succès
puisque presque 11% de ses élus ont
répandu et apparaît au grand jour en
réalité une vie quotidienne des mères
nous sommes nous avons été peut-être
pour certains d'entre nous d'autres le
sont aujourd'hui
le réceptacle de toutes les agressivités
de toutes les difficultés de la vie et
le maire devient une cible comme les
policiers le sont comme les pompiers le
sont devenus et ses marques notamment
depuis 2014 un changement profond même
si avant les choses existaient aussi et
depuis 2014 on a une forme à
l'augmentation de cette tension
14 il semblerait que ça puisse
correspondre c'est une interprétation
qui est personnel aux difficultés de
plus en plus importantes rencontrées par
nos concitoyens
et puis il ya sans doute sur le fond des
choses un vrai sujet d'éducation de
respect à la fois des institutions et
puis on a quand même jetés en pâture les
élus à la vindicte populaire
faut dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont
c'est le fait de certains et c'est
devenu presque une forme de deux sports
le terme n'est pas beau mais c'est celui
là que j'utilise
et à force de jeter des gens en pâture
quels qu'ils soient ont fini par le pays
à un moment et on est là on en est là
aussi donc vous avez été maire est ce
que ces témoignages il reflète aussi une
partie de votre expérience de maire est
ce que vous avez eu à faire face à
autant de violence dans l'exercice de
ses fonctions
oui et non en tant que maire jamais mais
ce que j'ai constaté c'est que le samedi
matin quand on tient des permanences en
rendez vous à la mairie quand on est
maire on est l'ultime recours
et tous les maux de la société se
retrouve dans notre bureau et on n'est
pas tous prêts à être le confident le
psychiatre l'accompagnateur social
d'assistance sociale c'est un métier
d'accompagner socialement les gens on
n'est pas tous prêts à ça et c'est une
partie du problème c'est pas tout et
puis il ya l'autre volet qui est que le
système pyramidal qui est nôtre dans
l'humanité depuis des millénaires ne
fonctionne plus système pyramidal de
l'autorité ne fonctionne plus qu'on soit
chef d'entreprise conçoit mer qu'on soit
président de la république qu'on soit un
cadre qu'on soit policier on voit bien
que l'autorité est contestée est de plus
en plus est avec des relents populistes
et démagogiques
comment collègues buffet le disait ou
l'évoqué le sous-entendait à l'instant
on voit bien qu à une contestation et ça
demande une consultation de réintégrer
de permettre la réappropriation en
permanence et on touche une partie de la
population quand on est maire en
proximité mais on la touche plus quand
on est parlementaire ou quand on est
chef d'entreprise et ça oblige à une
communication plus réticulaire donc oui
il ya une réalité
je crois que le projet de loi on va en
parler qui hélas amène un certain nombre
de réponses sans régler l'ensemble des
problèmes
évidemment parce que c'est au delà de la
situation des mères etc au delà de
l'intervention du législateur sur ces
sujets on va parler un des
préconisations mais d'abord on reste un
petit peu sur le constat joséphine
delpeyrat alors parmi les chiffres qui
ont été sortis par la commission des
lois
on découvre que 92 % des mères qui ont
participé à cette consultation été
victimes d'incivilités
et d'injures de menaces d'agressions
physiques bon c'est beaucoup en même
temps ce sont les personnes qui ont
participé à la consultation n'a jamais
que 3812 témoignage sur 35 mille
communes ont tout à fait moi il se
trouve que dans le cadre de nos réseaux
locaux on est quand même actif dans plus
de 50 départements français est partout
où je me range entend ce genre de show
j'entends des menaces de mort
j'entendais maison taguée notamment
pendant le grand débat national
il y à de nombreuses et lieux qui ont dû
faire face aux attaques aux menaces et
je pense que ce qu'on n'a pas encore
évoqué aujourd'hui on parle de 2014
depuis 2014 aussi on sait que l'usagé
des réseaux sociaux a considérablement
augmenté dans la communication de nos
élus et on se rend compte aussi il faut
en parler que le harcèlement en ligne si
une violence phénoménal pour nos élus
qui sont constamment confrontés à ce que
j'appelle les trolls des réseaux sociaux
et que ça également safin violence
psychologique terrible je pense
notamment à l'égard des femmes dans la
consultation il est apparu qu'il avait
eu un certain nombre d'injures sexistes
et qui ont beaucoup fleuri sur les
réseaux sociaux pour des mères tout à
fait alors là dessus nous en a fait une
autre étude également avec nous tout
nous tout est élu local ou en a
recueilli de très nombreux témoignages
de femmes sur les violences sexistes et
sexuelles
on est à peu près malheureusement sur
les mêmes chiffres que votre étude sur
les incivilités et on se rend compte
c'est effectivement que quand on est une
femme et qu'on est maire on est d'autant
plus confrontés à certaines menaces qui
sont encore plus liée à la visite privée
à ce qui est la personne et on est moins
protégée par les chartes de la
république on est attaqué en tant que
femme
aurélien elias est ce que pour vous eh
bien ces violences et incivilités dans
les moeurs se sont réellement accrue au
cours des années certains disent mais il
ya 20 ans déjà en faisait face à ce
problème alors tout à l'heure je me suis
fait parler de la date de 2014
qu'est ce que vous avez observé je pense
qu'il ya forcément un effet un peu
déformant de l'étude de la commission
des lois même si elle a tout son mérite
c'est de mettre des cas concret de faire
remonter des cas concrets puisque
forcément par le ceux qui ont été
victimes de violences et de violences
graves et il faut en parler
mais effectivement ce qu'on voit croître
depuis le début du mandat
une manière j'ai envie de dire
exponentielle c'est tout ce magma de ce
qu'on peut appeler incivilités alors
incivilités dans la rue ça va être deux
en apostrophe le maire parce qu'on n'est
pas content de ne pas avoir eu un rendez
vous assez vite à on va le chercher
jusque dans son bureau parce qu'on n'a
pas eu le permis de construire mais
aussi et surtout j'ai envie de dire
effectivement tout ce qui se passe sur
le web sur les réseaux sociaux
et alors là
en plus on a un effet démultiplicateur
c'est à dire que une menace une insulte
n'est jamais agréable à recevoir mais
quand en plus elle est dix minutes
démultipliée par ces réseaux sociaux
qu'elle navigue sur les réseaux quel est
ce enfin aussi on parle aussi de
diffamation forcément ça c'est quelque
chose qui interpelle et alors là qui
touche tous les élus grandes villes
petite ville le maire a longtemps et
elle et lui préférer à des français il
l'est toujours mais pour autant il ya
une espèce de mauvaises libération de la
parole qui fait que citoyen consommateur
se lâche un petit peu bien trop en tout
cas eh bien c'est un sujet un kig occupe
aujourd'hui le devant de la scène depuis
notamment cet été bien la mort du maire
de sign on et qu'on n'en parle plus
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs écouter ce
témoignage du maire de montbrison dans
la loire ce week-end il a été agressé
ont l'écoutant je passe au jardin
d'allard et là il y avait des troubles à
l'ordre public des gens qui hurlent et
qui s'insultent et donc quand je suis
arrivé par hasard je leur ai demandé de
se calmer tout simplement d'arrêter du
relais de se comporter convenablement et
éventuellement de rentrer chez eux ces
inepties n'était pas en état parce
qu'ils avaient l'air d'avoir un peu bu à
suhr dans la jeune femme s'est
précipitée vers moi nez à nez me pousse
du doigt m'insulte copieusement je ne
peux pas dire ce qu'elle m'a dit à
l'antenne mais y en avait tout un
florilège est un système très menaçante
et bien évidemment que savait que
j'étais maire je m'étais présenté son
mari qui était à côté un peu aussi ivre
lui précise que c'est le maire qu'il
faut qu'elle arrête et à ce moment là a
dit mais j'en ai rien à que ce
soit le maire et c'est à ce moment là
qu'elle m'a littéralement cracher dessus
sur la poitrine sur les lunettes
françois noël buffet la jeune femme
aujourd'hui les temps jugé en
comparution immédiate
ça montre que c'est un jour elles ont
été prises au sérieux
mais ce n'est pas représentatif
finalement de la réponse de la justice
toujours est bien avec cette
consultation découvre que seuls 37% des
élus ayant répondu ont saisi la justice
à la suite d'une attaque physique ou
verbale ça ne va pas souvent jusque là
plus cru parce qu'il faut distinguer ce
qui relève de la mauvaise humeur
propos verbale qui peut être tenus sur
qu'elles ont passées puis on se dit ça
se calmera de l'agression elle même
physique pas seulement physiques
insultant de vous l'avez dit est de plus
en plus agressive et une forme de
désinhibition d'un simple de personnes
qui considèrent que toutes la même
valeur et qu'on est libre de tout et la
réponse pénale elle doit aboutir alors
elle n'aboutit qu'à une seule condition
c'est d'abord que le maire ou les lui
dépose plainte
engage la procédure et qu'ensuite le
procureur poursuivre il ya toujours une
question de preuves
oui évidemment et là on se pose toujours
la question de la preuve si vous êtes
dans un lieu public qui a des témoins
c'est beaucoup plus simple que si c'est
dans le secret ou le la confidentialité
de votre bureau ou d'un lieu où les
choses se passent donc il faut inviter
les élus de deux sont à déposer cette
plainte
on ne peut pas laisser sans réponse est
une forme de pour toutes les infractions
qui est telle qu'elles peuvent exister
de tôle de tolérance zéro que nous
devons avoir la justice ensuite tranche
prend sa décision c'est son travail mais
on ne peut pas accepter que les choses
se continue sans réaction c'est vrai
pour les élus c'est vrai pour les
policiers c'est vrai pour les magistrats
c'est vrai pour tous ceux qui dans ce
pays représente une autorité mais
représentait une autorité c'est pas être
forcément un objet de défiance
c'est aussi d'être une personne de
confiance et cette confiance là elle ne
peut exister et contribuer au lien
social la vie en commun qu à la
condition qu'elle soit respectée
arnaud de belenet la consultation le
moment à montre que seulement 21 % des
plaintes déposées ont abouti à la
condamnation pénale des fautifs
certains sénateurs quand on les
interroge ils disent même le problème
c'est que finalement et bien le maire
est tout de même une autorité une un
représentant de l'état et puis on nous
oblige quand même un à prouver qu'il ya
eu la faute ils disent bon ben c'est pas
très normal ce que vous alliez jusque là
vous n'en françois noël buffet juriste
mais devant un juge pénal
effectivement il faut prouver la
matérialité des faits et c'était pas
suffit pas d'être mère quand même pour
un non parce que certains irait jusque
là bas j'espère que devant un juge la
parole du maire compte un petit peu plus
que celle
d'un multirécidiviste pour reprendre un
cas un peu extrême mais mais
effectivement quand on était en tous les
cas quand on peut le souhaiter
quand on est passionné quand on s'engage
quand on est maire on s'expose
quand on aime ce qu'on fait quand on
aime les gens on va au bout du bout de
son engagement et on se met dans des
situations de risque parfois aussi je
les fais en tant que maire comme
beaucoup d'autres les petits truands de
stupéfiants qui squattent la place le
parking central de la ville un tout
maire est allé les voir à un moment
donné à nouer le contact et essayer de
régler les problèmes on le fait on sait
que c'est pas raisonnable on s'expose
on prend des risques et ça c'est un
message qu'il faut faire passer bien sûr
qu'il faut dire au maire porter plainte
engagé des procédures ne laissait rien
passer préserver l'autorité que vous
incarnez et et n'ayez pas peur de le
faire et assumée de le faire n'ayez pas
honte dépassé oui vous êtes mère oui
vous êtes généreux oui vous êtes grand
oui vous préserver l'ambiance locale
oui vous pourrez vous essayer d'apaiser
les relations partout mais porter
plainte ne laissait pas passer un
certain nombre d'actes mais al'inverse
on sait bien qu'on s'expose de temps en
temps ça ne justifie rien mais ça il
faut qu'on le dise et qu'on leur dise
que nos concitoyens aient conscience
qu'ils ont de la chance d'avoir des
mères qui vont au bout de leur
engagement en prenant des risques
personnels et juste il faut d'autant
mieux les protéger
il est maire ont toujours une bonne
image c'est ce que montre et bien un
sondage un café à public sénat avec
opinionway
les deux tiers des sondés par exemple
juge que le bilan de leur maire sortant
est bon voire excellent aurélien elias
donc on voit le maire reste un élu de
proximité très apprécié de ses
administrés alors est-ce que c'est
contradictoire ce que l'on a là une bien
sûr ces agressions et en même temps et
bien cet attachement profond qui reste
pour pour le maire n'ont passé
c'est l'explication elle réside dans les
deux cas dans le fait que le maire et
les élus de proximité par excellence il
est l'élu de proximité par excellence
donc il est aimé parce qu'il est
accessible
je crois que c'est le président du sénat
qui dit régulièrement qui les a portés
danglade et le problème c'est que il est
aussi apporter de bave puisque quand
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
ce citoyen consommateur c'est ce citoyen
consommateur de police
public qui en demande toujours plus à
des mères qui n'ont pas forcément
toujours les moyens et donc parfois on a
des des demandes qui vont au delà des
capacités financières mais aussi de la
capacité des mères à répondre en temps
et en heure à des citoyens qui
voudraient avoir des réponses tout de
suite un rond c'est que sur plein de
compétences qu'on les communes
les choses ne peuvent pas se décider en
un clin d'oeil et il ya cet assaut ce
sentiment que les choses ne vont pas
assez vite
celle aussi chez le ch et le citoyen
consommateur de politiques publiques
et pourtant le maire reste l'élu le plus
populaire mais attention ce qui encore
une fois il a toujours été l'élu le plus
le plus populaire auprès des français
mais on voit quand même de que depuis
quelques années de la même manière que
l'ensemble de la classe politique a
moins la cote auprès des français
on voit la cote du maire petit à petit
diminués oui il a une cote qui diminue
joséphine d'altéra alors que c'est donc
important que ce mr occupent toujours
cette place auprès des français le maire
françoise gatel la co rapporteur du
projet de loi elle dit c'est le filet de
cohésion sociale pour la république du
quotidien c'est important aussi dans le
contexte social actuel le contexte des
gilets jaunes
le maire il est important c'est aussi ce
qu'a montré le grand débat oui c'est un
vecteur de proximité
extrêmement important le ou la mère
d'ailleurs et la chef de file de sa
commune il est l'interlocuteur
privilégié la personne en qui on en a le
plus confiance vers qui on se tourne
dans tous les cas quand on a un problème
sur sa commune maintenant il est
nécessaire par contre de repréciser son
rôle à la fois auprès des élus parce que
malheureusement on a encore des élus
locaux qui méconnaissent un petit peu
leur statut leur protection
fonctionnelle mais on a aussi des
citoyens devenus clients consommateurs
moi j'ai quand même une élue qui m'a
raconté qu'une de ces commerçantes
étaient venus lui poser une crotte de
chien dans son bureau en exigeant
qu'elle ramasse elle même parce que ça
n'allait pas assez vite
donc effectivement en
on tombe dans du caprice et le ou la mer
c'est pas le papa ou la maman de la
commune départ hier qu on est d'accord
mais en tout cas on peut pas autoriser
non plus c'est qui a pris c'est cette
impatience permanente il faut repréciser
dans les deux sens en maintenant un
dialogue bien entendu alors on vous
parlait du statut de l'élu on va
justement s'intéresser et bien aux
propositions qui sont faites dans le
projet de loi sur le statut de l'élu
ces projets de loi engagement et
proximité qui a été débattue en
commission
ce matin déjà bien une fois n'est pas
coutume c'est un texte sur lequel il ya
plutôt un grand accord c'est la lune de
miel entre le gouvernement et le sénat
écoutez à ce propos est bien le ministre
sébastien lecornu aura pas de surprise
pour les sénateurs puisque on s'est
largement inspiré des travaux du sénat
qui sont des travaux consensuelle avec
en plus derrière beaucoup de des changes
avec les associations d'élus est donc là
effectivement pouvoir rentrer dans
l'examen des amendements parce que
l'objectif c'est bien sûr d'avoir une
discussion parlementaire fluide qui
permet de voir ce texte voté avant le 31
décembre de cette année pour pouvoir
créer des effets des 1er janvier en tout
cas les 600 milieu le coup nous
attendent là dessus et pour poursuivre
sur ce sujet on va tout de suite
rejoindre alexandre poussard salle des
conférences alexandre vous être avec le
sénateur socialiste et le tir au chant
oui eric kerrouche est ce que vous
pensez que ce projet de loi porté par
sébastien lecornu sur le statut d'élu
l'engagement et la proximité va répondre
aux attentes des aux attentes des maires
il va répondre à certaines attentes
il va pas répondre à toutes les attentes
le texte il s'appelait engagement et
proximité il arrive après une période
tout à fait particulière on se rend
compte que l'engagement des élus locaux
l'engagement des mères est très
important on pensait la période gilet
jaune ou le président de la république a
dû s'appuyer sur ses relais qu'il
constitue et on attendait à terre un
texte qui vient transformer le statut
c'est pas le cas
c'est un texte qui donne et qui traite
quelques points du statut c'est pas la
même chose
aucun texte insuffisant selon vous sur
cette question c'est un texte en fait
qui est en demi teinte c'est à dire que
à vrai dire dans ce texte il ya
certaines mesures qui sont utiles qui
vont venir améliorer tel ou tel aspect
de la gouvernance locale ou sur le
statut
en revanche quand on parle des statuts
on pense à l'accès à l'exercice du
mandat à la fin du mandat
l'ensemble n'est pas traitée on n'a que
quelques points de progression je peux
pas dire qu'il soit pas inutile mais que
quelques points 1 en tout cas ce projet
doivent être enrichie de mesures sur la
sécurité des mers des mesures du
gouvernement également du sénat issu de
ce rapport et de cette grande
consultation des maires est ce que vous
pensez que ces mesures sécuritaires vont
donner envie au maire de se représenter
et d'avoir un mandat alors deux choses
le texte engagement et proximité il
visait aussi à ce que les élus
découragés se représente est ce que ce
texte à lui seul suffit non c'est un
premier pas s'agissant du sujet que vous
évoquez là effectivement on a bien vu
dans la consultation menée par le sénat
qui était une consultation utile que les
incivilités progresse que les mères se
sentent plus menacés et que donc comme
tout dépositaire de l'autorité
ils ont des ils ont des difficultés et
il est normal que l'on puisse répondre à
ses attentes
mais c'est bien d'avoir plus de pouvoir
de police encore faut-il également plus
de moyens et vous pensez que ce projet
de loi ne prévoit pas ces moyens pour
pour renforcer ces espoirs de police ça
veut dire que les moyens j'entends
matériel j'entends humains dépendent
aussi des fonds des possibilité donnée
aux collectivités territoriales et ça on
voit bien que ça sera traitée
ultérieurement dans le cadre du de la
loi de finances ou on verra bien ce qui
reste de la taxe d'habitation des
compensations et c'est ce que je veux
juste vous dire c'est que il faut
effectivement que le maire puisse avoir
plus de latitude en matière de police
c'est vraiment très important parce que
ça permet de traiter des situations
difficiles on l'a encore évoqué ce matin
il faudra sans doute aller plus loin
dans les moyens donnés au maire et aux
élus locaux
très bien merci beaucoup et l'arrière
rouge pour votre réaction merci beaucoup
alexandre françois noël buffet donc on
l'a entendu le maire va être plus
soutenue pour utiliser ses pouvoirs de
police est une bonne chose est-ce que ça
suffit d une chose c'est que les élus
locaux en ce début de mandat
présidentiel ont quand même pas été bien
traités sait bien qu'aujourd'hui on s'en
occupe et qu'on s'en préoccupe
le sénat a fait un travail de fond
le sénat fait un travail de fond depuis
longtemps et c'est heureux que le
gouvernement s'en inspire et notamment
que le débat qui souhaite un débat qui
soit ouvert fin qui soit non passionné
passionnant mais non passionnée en
revanche est ce que le texte va tout
résoudre
la réponse est non est ce que les maires
auront tous les outils nécessaires pour
se re motiver pour être candidat aux
élections
la réponse est sans doute pas
complètement en revanche est ce qu'il
est nécessaire de mieux les protéger sur
le plan pénal d'aggraver éventuellement
par des sanctions administratives assez
forte ce qui les agressent et ce qu'il
est nécessaire de donner plus de moyens
aux collectivités locales pour voir
mener des politiques qui soient plus
adaptée au territoire sans aucun doute
donc quand elle était c'est un tout
naturellement on aura une avancé avec ce
texte et l total nom est elle suffisante
non faut-il le faire oui parce que c'est
une étape mais nous avons besoin de cela
donc une première étape pour françois
noël buffet ça ne suffit pas tout de
même plus de pouvoirs de police des
réponses pénales plus ferme
c'est un c'est un début mais c'est un
texte qui est un volet de plusieurs et
qui s'inscrit dans une démarche qui a
commencé en 2017 avec deux postulats fin
de la baisse des dotations parce qu'il
fallait redonner de la visibilité aux
maires pour qu'ils aient la capacité
d'agir et pouvoir se projeter dans le
temps on absolument essentiel est
essentielle et fin de l'instabilité
institutionnelle est tous ras-le-bol de
passer nos soirées en commission qu'on
appelle des clect à retravailler les
périmètres les redistributions de
compétence entre nos communes nos
interco et quand ce n'était pas avec des
sujets de fusion d'interco donc tout ça
s'est arrêté avec les premières mesures
du quinquennat je rejoins quelque chose
je suis fier il faut le rappeler parce
que c'était et le maire que j'étais
s'est engagé notamment à cause de ça aux
sénatoriales que tout cela s'arrête et
s'arrête vite et qu'on respecte le
travail des élus qu'on leur redonne
capacités et moyens d'agir la relation
entre l'exécutif national et les élus
locaux à travers ce texte
à travers le prochain qui sera apporté
par jacqueline gourault et à mon avis à
travers un travail de fond qui est
absolument nécessaire sur les sujets de
financement et de répartition des
compétences à tous les échelons et qui
demandera beaucoup plus de temps que la
simple année qui vient sont enclenchées
ce travail est enclenché il avance et a
énormément de points positifs dans ce
projet de loi
c'était pas l'objet de l'émission pas
seulement sur les sujets de sécurité
mais puisque vous avez singulariser sur
les sujets de sécurité je crois qu'il
est urgent de faire en sorte que le
maire ne soit plus positionnée comme un
shérif qui prend des risques et qu'on
accompagne les moyens dont ils disposent
des moyens de faire respecter ces
arrêtés il ya des réponses dans le
projet de loi qu'on facilite la
mutualisation des polices la
disponibilité services de secours qu'il
soit comme le disait kerrouche mieux
intégrés dans la chaîne 2 de la police
judiciaire et a plein de choses à faire
certaines réponses dans le projet de loi
et d'autres aussi c'est vrai sur le
sujet de sécurité c'est vrai sur tous
les sujets qui sont dans le projet de
loi et que cette fois j'ai donc demain
sera l'occasion effectivement d'en
reparler
aurélia alias un shérif qui prend des
risques est ce que c'est ça le maire
aujourd'hui parce que c'est vrai si on
lui donne le plus de pouvoir de police
il faut aussi les lui donner sans qu'ils
se mettent davantage en danger c'est un
petit peu la difficulté de ce texte
oui et c'est vrai que pour le coup je
pense que personne ne va dire enfin
j'ose espérer que se règlent ce texte va
tout régler ce ce qui est avancé est ce
qui fait assez consensus suffisamment
d'ailleurs pour que les associations
d'élus le soutiennent ce qui a été assez
rare en début de quinquennat sur sur
d'autres textes ou sur d'autres
initiatives du gouvernement
c'est l'idée de pouvoir exemple de
pouvoir prononcer des amendes
l'idée qui est plus de liens
au sein d'un conseil de sécurité qui
soit unique avec les polices municipales
mais aussi un police nationale ou
gendarmerie
c'est le fait que des instructions
soient données au parquet pour que les
les condamnations qui seront prononcées
envers des personnes qui auraient à
porter atteinte physiquement ou autres à
des à des élus soient soient fortes et
en ce sens l'exécutif a envoyé des
cycles lors des derniers congrès dé lui
donc c'est un accompagnement que
qui est qui va être forcément positif
mais ne soyons pas naïfs ça ne va pas
régler toutes les situations impromptues
ou des citoyens qui estime avoir tout
presque tous les droits
s'en prenne physiquement un élu qui ne
va pas dans son sens joséphine delpeyrat
soit là d'autant plus ça fait un petit
peu écho à ce que disait dans le sujet
philippe bas les reçoit nombre de maires
qui estime qu'ils portent trop de choses
seuls aussi sur leurs épaules dans l'un
des témoignages sur la consultation
l'un d'entre eux dit j'ai le sentiment
d'être seuls laissé en première ligne
sans moyens pour faire respecter le
droit et la sécurité
sentiment de solitude même avec tout ce
qu'on apporte comme arsenal
il va être difficile à contrer tout à
fait nous aussi nos réseaux fonctionnent
aussi bien en milieu rural justement
c'est que je pense que c'est une manière
de contrer ce sentiment de solitude
les élus attendent ont besoin d'être
entendus et ses rangs des effets
positifs effectivement du grand débat
national
une partie des propositions se
retrouvent dans cette loi et je pense
aussi que c'est ce soulagement la qui
fait qu' il y a une relation apaisée
entre les élus et ministère suite à ces
propositions
quand je rencontre des citoyens et
citoyennes qui hésitent à s'engager il y
est me disent j'ai peur de rentrer dans
l'arène la politique c'est la guerre ça
m'inquiète je vais être exposé ma
famille mes enfants donc on voit qu'il
ya quand même une réelle inquiétude par
rapport à ça et sur ces points-là de
sécurité je pense qu'on va avoir un
mieux par contre il me paraît absolument
nécessaire de continuer d'accompagner
les élus autrement et de faire des
propositions rapides sur le statut de
l'élu local pour vraiment préciser les
missions et les droits auxquels ont
accès les élus locaux
il nous reste 30 secondes françois noël
buffet arnaud de belenet juste deux mots
pour conclure peut-être aussi bien sur
le fait que et bien on parle aussi d'une
société qui a de moins en moins de
respect pour les élus dans leur ensemble
n'y a pas que les mères et donc c'est
sûr que c'est pas un projet de loi qui
va permettre de résoudre tout cela la
politique c'est un bel engagement
je connais pas d'élus quelles que soient
ses convictions politiques
qu'ils ne s'engagent pas sincèrement
qu'ils aient pas envie de servir
donc il faut que nos concitoyens et que
chacun prenne bien conscience que si on
abîme cet engagement on abîmera notre
système démocratique et on s'affaiblira
et ce sera dangereux donc il faut
redonner à la politique ses lettres de
noblesse il faut respecter l'engagement
politique pour conclure la fonction de
maire et de conseiller municipal sont
les plus belles qu'il soit elles sont
enrichissante humainement elles sont
merveilleuses
elle demande de l'effort de la ténacité
de l'engagement c'est une servitude
aussi mail mais sont des fonctions qui
mérite d'être occupés et ceux qui les
occupent mérite d'être encore mieux
accompagnés par les dispositions
nationales c'est ce à quoi nous avons et
j'en suis très heureux qu'on ait de quoi
indigner candidats ce plateau merci
beaucoup à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat merci arnaud de belenet françois
noël buffet et aurélien elias et
joséphine delpeyrat merci à tous et on
pense à présent au deuxième thème de
cette émission le budget 2020 budget du
pouvoir d'achat après la crise des gilet
jaune les vannes sont elles vraiment
ouverte et l'installent filer le déficit
on en parle dans un instant avec nos
invités mais d'abord les grandes lignes
de ce budget qui ne satisfait pas tout
le monde
michael spitzberg c'en est fini de
l'image du président des riches qui
avait marqué le premier budget du
président emmanuel macron le projet de
loi de finances pour 2020 présentée la
semaine dernière reflète la réponse du
gouvernement à la crise sociale incarnée
par le mouvement des gilet jaune pour
soigner leur pouvoir d'achat les ménages
pourront compter sur une baisse d'impôt
de 9 milliards d'euros
le sentiment d'abandon et de disparition
des services publics dans les
territoires est aussi pris en compte
l'objectif de diminution de postes de
fonctionnaires est encore revu à la
baisse pour se fixer à 10500 côté
recettes l'état misent sur la baisse des
taux d'intérêt pour économiser 5
milliards d'euros un projet de loi de
finances qui allie utiles et agréables
selon françois patriat redonner du
pouvoir d'achat ce qui est bien une
demande aujourd'hui avec le gouvernement
a répondu par presque 20 milliards de
pouvoir d'achat qui redistribue aux
français ce budget aussi à une
une évidence que personne ne relève ses
stabilisation de la dette
98% dans la première fois stabilise pour
le président du haut conseil des
finances publiques
c'est plutôt un budget de rupture qui se
dessine le haut conseil relève en
conséquence que le gouvernement présente
un article liminaire du projet de loi de
finances qui s'écartent fortement de la
trajectoire de la loi de programmation
en vigueur at-elle choix pose un
problème de cohérence entre le pelleve
2020 et la loi de programmation des
finances publiques et affaiblit la
portée de l'exercice de programmation
pluriannuelle en matière de finances
publiques
à droite on considère que ce budget est
un renoncement redressement des finances
publiques il ya deux des baisses
d'impôts qui sont financés par de la
dette et qu'ils sont donc ils ne sont
pas financés et ça c'est évidemment pas
acceptable qu'on abdique sur l'idée qu'
on souhaite reconquérir notre
souveraineté financière le pouvoir
d'achat des français
c'est pas uniquement des transferts
sociaux et c'est pas uniquement des
baisses d'impôts le projet de loi de
finances et ses 80 articles seront
discutées au sénat fin novembre
l'exécutif présente donc ce budget 2020
comme le budget du pouvoir d'achat mais
à quel prix on en parle avec nos deux
invités tous deux sénateurs de la
commission des finances vincent eblé
bonjour vous êtes le président
socialiste de la commission des finances
est également à mes côtés vincent
delahaye bonjour jour sénateur uc de
l'essonne vincent eblé
c'est un texte qui prévoit des baisses
d'impôts ça se comprend dans le contexte
du mouvement des gilet jaune
vous ne pouvez que vous en réjouir
peut-être pas la question c'est surtout
de savoir sur quoi ces baisses d'impôts
giresse engagée elle s'engager
malheureusement une fois encore sur la
dette
donc nous sommes surtout dans une
préoccupation déquilibre ce n'est pas
nouveau voilà 40 ans que la france
j'irais produit du déficit public avec
plus de dépenses que de recettes
moi je pense qu'il faut d'abord j'irai
tenir ses comptes avant de penser
distribués j'irai quelques cadeaux
fiscaux ici ou là et ça pose également
la question de savoir à qui bénéficient
ces cadeaux fiscaux
nous venons de faire un travail le
comité france stratégie sous l'égide du
ministre mais également les sénateurs le
rapporteur général du budget et votre
serviteur
sur la question de la réforme de la
fiscalité du patrimoine et nous
annoncerons la semaine prochaine un
certain nombre d'éléments de conclusion
qui démontre que tout le monde n'est pas
bénéficiaire de ces cadeaux fiscaux on
va en parler c'est un budget du moindre
effort qui manque de vision à long terme
mais tu fais du bricolage estime et
réviseurs de vincent de l'est est ce que
vous êtes d'accord est ce que vous êtes
aussi sévère écoutez moi je suis un
orthodoxe sur le plan budgétaire donc je
considère qu'on devrait retourner vers
l'équilibré budgétaire ça nous avait été
promis par françois hollande au début de
son quinquennat ça nous a été promis par
emmanuel macron début de son quinquennat
et je pense qu'à chaque fois on repousse
les efforts plus loin donc aujourd'hui
on baisse les impôts ça ne peut faire
que plaisir aux français
en fait ils vont recevoir de l'argent et
en même temps ils m'ont payé moins donc
tout ça c'est c'est bien gentil mais les
dépenses d'aujourd'hui seront les impôts
de demain
aman donné il faudra bien payer donc et
les baisses d'impôts aujourd'hui bien
sûr qu'il fallait sans doute agir par
rapport au gilet jaune mais en même
temps on prendra l'immense exaspération
fiscal des france on sait très bien que
cet argent là il va où il va où
finalement il va il va dans une épargne
supplémentaire parce que les pagnes
grappes
donc on met de côté est ce que c'est bon
pour l'économie on peut se poser la
question et ensuite il va aussi surtout
sur les importations ce qui fait que ça
va dégrader notre déficit commercial
vis-à-vis de l'étranger donc je pense
que c'est pas forcément une bonne
politique de fond politiquement elle est
sans doute intéressante
aujourd'hui c'est pour ça qu'on peut
comprendre que le gouvernement et elle
souhaitait présenter ce budget
suffisamment finalement quelques cadeaux
tout le monde y retrouve un peu son dos
et ses petits dans ce budget donc il ya
beaucoup de missions qui augmente
on fait plaisir à la défense aurait
plaisir à l'intérieur il n'ya pas il n'y
a pas de gros soucis mais le déficit lui
continue d'augmenter en tout cas
pourcentage du pib mais moi j'aime pas
parler pourcentage du pib parce que
quand vous parlez aux français de 2 2%
il considère que c'est rien du tout il
sait ce que c'est normal quand vous leur
dites que c'est 93 milliards ça commence
déjà un petit peu pour certains aller
toucher et c'était 1 5% qui était
initialement prévu de concept car de la
trajectoire qui est passé car de la
trajectoire surtout on a un déficit qui
est très important qu'est ce temps les
plus importants de l'union européenne
alors qu'on veut donner des leçons au
niveau européen donc moi je considère
que les efforts budgétaires il faudrait
les poursuivre et j'ai l'impression
plutôt qu'on est en train de les stopper
il en a pas eu beaucoup ou pas tant que
ça sur les dix dernières années je
dirais globalement pour mettre tout le
monde dans le même sac mais je considère
qu'on devrait en faire beaucoup plus et
que les efforts il faut les faire en
début de mandat parce que c'est des
efforts forcément impopulaire quand vous
demander des effort sur la dépense est
forcément impopulaires donc il faut pas
penser qu'on puisse les faire en fin de
mandat juste avant une élection
d'ailleurs et bien le quinquennat il a
commencé par une mesure qui a été assez
impopulaire pour beaucoup de français
cette mesure c'est la suppression de l'
isf transformer en hi-fi à impôt sur la
fortune immobilière
hier alors que les ministres un bruno le
maire gérald darmanin olivier dussopt
qui était auditionné par la commission
des finances sur ce budget de la salle
chauffée sur cette question les
sénateurs ont refusé de faire partie du
comité d'évaluation prévue par le
gouvernement
écoutez cet échange c'était avec vous
monsieur les blés et bruno le maire je
regrette que pour des raisons juridiques
que je trouve obscures le sénat ne
puisse pas être associée directement au
comité d'évaluation qu'elle fait un
travail tout à fait remarquable en
totale transparence sur nos choix en
terme de fiscalité du capital que je
crois que pour des raisons juridiques
une fois encore qui m'échappe totalement
le sénat ne pouvait pas être dans ce
comité d'évaluation c'est le juridique
ces politiques
nous l'avons formellement
président remettrait de le déplorer me
représenter à raison de un parlementaire
pour la chambre août
un parlementaire pour la chambre basse
ne permet pas d'assurer la diversité de
notre représentation politique et nous
n'avons pas vocation en tant que
parlementaire alors que nous participons
la décision d'intégrer des comités
d'experts
excusez-moi de vous interrompre nous ne
sommes pas des experts ou critiquer la
position du gouvernement je me permette
de regretter que le scénar n'est pas
acceptée participer comme ils savaient
je suis en panne ou transmet vraiment
que nous vous adressons par
questionnaire mais je vais y venir
monsieur le président je pense que
depuis avril à ça n'est pas la peine de
hausser le ton j'estime que nous avons
dans rival fermeté ce qui constitue ma
conviction
vincent eblé voilà donc pourrait bien ce
petit moment de clash hier en commission
alors si on revient davantage sur le
fond bien finalement ce rapport de
francs stratégie sur la réforme de l'aef
qui dit c'est que c'est assez difficile
à évaluer c'est que l'on manque
réellement de recul ou est-ce qu'on ne
fera jamais réellement l'impact d'une
telle mesure pour veux je pense que
cette façon de dire nous n'avons pas
encore de réponse
c'est tout simplement la révélation ce
comité qui se passait sous l'autorité du
premier ministre
j'irai aimerait bien pouvoir dire autre
chose mais comme il n'a pas les éléments
il y a
nous verrons plus tard la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a parlé de
ruissellement il n'y en a aucun il n'y a
pas dans l'économie à prendre important
qui a été accordée aux 5 % des français
les plus riches
cette économie fiscale elle ne sert pas
l'économie française ni en
investissement ni en consommation elle
ne soutient pas la croissance peut être
soutien tels la croissance extérieure
mais l'on sait par les chiffres dont
nous disposons et nous donnerons des
éléments dès la semaine prochaine en
réponse en quelque sorte au travail
d'évaluation réalisé par ce comité
nous démontrerons que cet argent ne sert
pas l'économie française et donc c'est
un cadeau qui a été fait sans retour aux
français les plus riches et qui ne
bénéficie pas à l'ensemble de notre
économie nationale
il reste quelques minutes je voudrais
maintenant de là quand on parle aussi
tout de même un petit peu de fiscalité
locales parmi les baisses ne pas donner
mon idée sur le sujet c'est pas pour que
l'impôt sur la fortune soit concentré
sur l'immobilier
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de produits
financiers placements financiers qui
aurait dû continuer à être imposée mais
qu'on aurait dû permettre à ceux aux
contribuables ali ahani sf renouvelée de
l'investir dans des pme ou des tpe et de
déduire son plafond parce que on a
besoin finalement d'investissement en
capital dans nos entreprises notamment
les petites entreprises et on aurait pu
se servir de cet outil pour le faire
alors on va également parlé un petit peu
de fiscalité locale parce que c'est un
autre sujet sur les coincer ça coince
déjà depuis un certain nombre d'années
hier gérard larcher notamment eh bien il
a menacé de ne même pas commencé à
examiner le budget en séance et bien si
vous n'avez pas les simulations l'impact
que va avoir et bien la suppression de
la taxe d'habitation pour les finances
des communes et des départements
vincent eblé bon est-ce que c'est
faisable déjà c'est quand même la
moindre des choses si vous voulez nous
sommes dans un système démocratique qui
distingue le pouvoir exécutif qui a la
responsabilité de faire et le pouvoir
législatif qui définit le cadre légal ça
fonctionne bien mais à la condition
évidemment qu'il y ait un minimum de
respect entre les deux et que des
éléments d'information dont dispose de
pouvoirs exécutifs soient mis à
disposition des parlementaires pour
qu'ils fassent de façon éclairée leur
travail de définition du cadre légal
c'est juste qu'on monde c'est la même
colère que celles de tout à l'heure avec
le ministre le maire
nous avons besoin qu'ils porteraient
travailler de façon efficace de données
dont nous ne disposons pas et qui nous
viennent des administrations placé sous
l'autorité dès ministres donc qu'il y
ait un minimum de loyauté dans le
fonctionnement de nos institutions de
telle façon qu en tant que parlementaire
nous puissions travailler non pas à la
règle non pas à tâtons mais de façon
éclairée c'est tout ce que nous
demandons est la colère du président
larcher est une saine colère hier
olivier des sables d'ailleurs lors de
son audition il a promis ces simulations
il a continué à
dire que bien ça serait compensée à
l'euro près on a fait réagir dominique
bussereau le patron des départements
voyez tout de suite sa réaction il faut
qu'une collectivité locale puisse lever
l'impôt
elles en portent la responsabilité
politique électorale devant les citoyens
et donc le fait de le compenser même si
in fine est après des négociations qui
n'ont pas vraiment commencé
on arrivait à un accord c'est quand même
pas la même liberté que lorsqu'un maire
fixe à taxe d'habitation un président
département son foncier bâti
il ya une autonomie financière qui doit
exister et je trouve dommage qu'on les
remette en cause
donc il faut en effet qu'on ait des
simulations très précises et on peut pas
dire à des élus locaux et passez votre
chemin ya rien à voir
bercy a fait des calculs bercy veille
sur vous c'est pas qu'on manque de
confiance mais on veut des preuves et
des choses réelles et tangibles
les présidents du sénat le dis avec
force il a raison de le dire
vincent delahaye on parle beaucoup des
finances des communes mais les
départements aussi ils sont très
inquiets on la retient leur part de taxe
foncière la remplace par la tva tout ça
c'est tout de même un drôle de micmac
c'est un drôle de micmac qui est parti
de la volonté de supprimer la taxe
d'habitation dont on peut en penser ce
qu'on veut moi je n'étais pas forcément
favorable à la suppression de taxe
d'habitation à partir de là c'est ce que
c'est un mauvais impôt mais oui mais la
taxe foncière aussi ta mauvaise impôts
puisque en fait on a des vieilles
valeurs locatives qui ne bouge pas
depuis des années quoi qui bouge qui
sont revalorisées chaque année mais qui
en fait mériterait une revue d'ensemble
que personne n'ose faire parce que pour
des raisons politiques ça perturberait
pas mal de personnes gagnant qui dirait
rien mais il ya les perdants qui eux se
manifesterait donc aujourd'hui par
rapport à ce qui est promis c'est à dire
une compensation à l'euro près le
transfert de la taxe foncière vers les
communes magie suis plutôt favorable que
les communes elles la taxe foncière dont
la part est pas bien mais par contre la
compensation elle doit tenir compte des
l'évolution des bases de ce qui ce qui
était à l'avant l'évolution des bases si
on fige les choses
le gouvernement propose finalement de
figer pour 2010 sur 2010 ne reste en
fait on n'a plus le dynamisme du tout
c'est à dire que même l'inflation la
part on a rien donc les communes se
retrouve à devoir payer à cause d'une
décision prise par le gouvernement par
l'état donc c'est ça qui on a déjà subi
ça par le passé mais on n'a plus envie
de le subir
aujourd'hui les communes envie
effectivement d'y voir clair et de se
dire voilà on nous supprime la taxe
d'habitation et en même temps on ne
compense mais cette compensation elle
continue quand même à évoluer au moins
en fonction du coût de la vie
parce que comme ça on ne fait pas appel
au contribuable local et l'état assume
ses décisions ce qui me paraît logique
en vain démocratie faut que chacun
assume ses décisions
vincent eblé quel est le risque si les
communes perçoivent moins de recettes
finalement qu'elle augmente d'autres
impôts certains disent à bien un très
bien on va augmenter la taxe foncière ou
qu'elle renonce à certains services à la
population pareil pour les pour les
départements pas répond tout le monde
finalement mais la réponse est dans
l'autre question ce sont des deux bien
évidemment réduction des services rendus
à la population et transfert de
financement sur d'autres ressources
il n'y a pas que les recettes fiscales
d'ailleurs il ya aussi le prix des
services publics et tout un tas de
services publics municipaux par exemple
qui sont arrivés aux familles la
demi-pension la piscine plage donc le
risque c'est que de toute façon les
communes ne pourront pas elles n'en ont
pas le droit
dépenser plus que l'argent dont elles
disposent donc il faudra bien trouver
cet argent quelque part alors un mot de
conclusion
et bien sûr le budget dans son ensemble
avant qu'il que l'on commençait bien sa
grand tante budgété à vincent delahaye
écoutez d'abord je dis ce que je pensais
de ce budget on va essayer comme chaque
année de l'améliorer au sénat on y
travaille on y travaille avec le
rapporteur général et on va essayer de
faire en sorte d'aller un petit peu plus
loin en tout cas pour nous sur les
propositions fiscales pour avoir une
fiscalité plus simple plus efficace et
plus compréhensibles par tous les
acteurs
un budget de renoncement en renoncement
redresser les comptes publics puisque
finalement on laisse filer en quelque
sorte le déficit du mois il est stagnant
alors même qu'on s'était fixé à soi même
des objectifs plus ambitieux il n'y a
que quelques mois et années en arrière
eh bien merci beaucoup va sembler merci
beaucoup vincent delage demeure
participer à cette discussion merci
messieurs
autre temps fort dans l'actualité du
sénat ce matin l'audition de jean-pierre
farandou le successeur désigné pour
succéder à guillaume pepy à la tête de
la sncf a passé son grand oral ce matin
au sénat
on en parle tout de suite avec alexandre
poussard mais d'abord un petit extrait
est bien de cette audition la
détermination politique de l'état et du
parlement lors de cette réforme qui va
donner naissance à la nouvelle sncf
marque le premier jour d'une entreprise
consciente de la transformation opérée
et des engagements à tenir
je voudrais saluer le rôle et
l'impulsion donnée par l'état et le
parlement qui ont pris acte de la
nécessité de moderniser le système
ferroviaire français
le parlement a fait sa part dès 2014
en créant sncf réseau et tout récemment
en 2018
à travers le nouveau parc ferroviaire la
reprise de dettes qui vous sera proposé
dans le cadre du projet de loi de
finances 2009 1 sera la prochaine étape
importante
matérialisant cet engagement des
pouvoirs publics alors qu'il ya du
mouvement qui commence à arriver dans la
salle des conférences du sénat avant les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
pendant une dizaine de minutes
maintenant on va tout de suite rejoindre
alexandre pousse à vous êtes avec hervé
morin le président de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire bien sûr et
bien qu est ce qu il pense de peu de
monsieur farandou pour prendre la
succession de guillaume pepy louis hervé
maurey ce que vous avez été convaincu
par la prestation de jean pierre
farandou futur pdg de la sncf
ce au veto du parlement ils voudraient
nous verrons tout à l'heure au terme du
dépouillement si les mandats commission
et était convaincu
ce qui est vrai c'est que jean pierre
farandou connaît bien la sncf il a
effectué toute sa carrière au sein de
cette maison
en même temps il ya eu des fonctions
dans une entreprise qui est déjà ouverte
à la concurrence keolis
il permet de savoir ce que c'est que de
rechercher des marchés d'en gagner et
d'en perdre et nous a donné l'impression
d'être quelqu'un
effectivement tout à fait capable de
relever les défis qui sont ceux de la
sncf avec notamment et principalement
l'ouverture à la concurrence qui doit
intervenir dès le 1er janvier 2020 avec
la mise en place du nouveau statut avec
la mise en concurrence des différentes
lignes donc c'est un moment important de
l'histoire de la sncf et on pense à
priori qu'il est capable de relever ce
défi mais justement ce défi vin peut
bouleverser l'avenir de la sncf
est ce que ça va être un président du
dialogue social qui va améliorer le
dialogue avec les syndicats
il a beaucoup insisté sur ce point je
crois qu'effectivement il est réellement
attaché à la question du dialogue social
c'est un élément important de la
réussite de la transformation de la sncf
c'est une entreprise où les syndicats
sont encore très présents ou un certain
nombre de membres du personnel n'ont pas
accepté le changement de statut de la
sncf
le tout dans un contexte social qui est
compliqué puisque il y à la réforme des
retraites qui se posent globalement mais
qui a la sncf inquiète particulièrement
touchée déjà un mouvement de grève qui
était annoncé pour le 5 décembre
donc le contexte social il a évidemment
bien en tête et je pense qu'il l'est
certainement armée pour essayer de
différents fasse dans les meilleures
conditions
alors effectivement il a fait ses
classes à la sncf depuis 30 ans se
profile cheminots cet homme du sérail
c'était important
je crois que c'était important au moment
où nous en sommes de l'histoire de la
sncf
l'un profil de quelqu'un qui n'aurait
pas eu cette connaissance de la maison
aurait été à mon avis difficile à
accepter notamment par le corps social
de la sncf et en même temps comme je le
disais le fait d'avoir eu d'autres
fonctions même si c'est dans une filiale
de la sncf en l'occurrence keolis dans
une entreprise qui a eu à affronter des
concurrents à répondre à des marchés
publics à se moderniser à réduire ses
coûts
c'est une expérience je pense
complémentaires et utile est ce que vous
êtes satisfait du mandat de son
prédécesseur guillaume pepy à la tête de
la sncf guillaume pepy a accompli un
mandat assez exceptionnel déjà pour sa
longévité il aura bien sûr marqué
l'histoire de la sncf
aujourd'hui c'est une nouvelle page qui
va s'écrire je pense que c'est important
effectivement qu'elle soit
écrite avec une nouvelle personne
c'était l'objet de l'audition ce matin
très bien merci beaucoup et hervé maurey
c'était notamment
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
nouvelle réaction à tout à l'heure j'ai
le plaisir d'accueillir sur ce plateau
samuel le goff bonjour vous êtes
journaliste à contacter spécialiste des
questions parlementaires on est à
quelques minutes des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
premier changement samuel ça n'a l'air
de rien mais ça compte les questions
d'actualité bien c'est désormais tous
les mercredis à 15h pourquoi ce
changement et qu'est-ce que ça va
changer c'est l'assemblée nationale qui
a elle-même changer son propre rythme en
concentrant toutes les séances de
questions sur le mardi de 15h à 17h et
donc à libérer le créneau du mercredi
après-midi donc le sénat en a profité et
donc installe son ces questions et c'est
important pour le sénat d'avoir ce
rendez vous régulier ce que jusqu'à
maintenant c'était une alternance entre
le mardi le jeudi c'est compliqué
d'établir à rendez-vous ce n'importe
quel rang des spectateurs ya un
rendez-vous maintenant ça m à 15 heures
tous les mercredis à la et donc pour les
journalistes qui veulent venir
c'est plus facile on sait que le
mercredi après midi c'est le sénat est
donc progressivement les choses vont
changer la couverture sera sans doute
meilleur et ça permet un jeu de ping
pong avec l'assemblée puisque le le
sénat passe après et donc si des choses
sont levés à l'assemblée s'il ya des
soucis qui arrive
le sénat a 24 heures pour se préparer
c'est aussi une première séance de
questions d'actualité de la session
ordinaire qui va être marquée par
l'hommage qui va être rendu à jacques
chirac
en ouverture de séance samuel c'est
l'ultime hommage qui est donc faire
jacques chirac après l'assemblée
nationale hier aujourd'hui le sénat
c'est important pour la représentation
nationale de rendre hommage
collectivement ainsi à l'ancien
président la république
oui tout à fait puisque c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui a marqué l'histoire de
france l'histoire politique même s'il
n'a pas été sénateur c'est peut-être un
des rares mandeure qu'il n'est pas
humain
c'est quand même quelqu'un qu'on doit
qu'on doit célébrer qu'on doit enfin on
doit commémorer et il aurait été étrange
que le sénat ne fasse rien
oui effectivement il devrait y avoir
donc un hommage de gérard larcher est
suivi par une prise de parole du premier
ministre d'un philippe caumières à
l'assemblée
je vais vous faire réagir à ce que ce
qu'ont dit certains dans les couloirs de
jacques chirac il disait c'est un
politique dure avec des allures parfois
devoyault mais il a toujours été très
respectueux des institutions et en
harmonie avec le sénat jacques chirac
est un homme multi facettes
c'est à dire qu'on peut le voir sous
plein d'angles et on ne verra pas la
même personne et c'est justement ça qui
fait sa richesse et la sa stature mais
effectivement c'est quelqu'un qui a
toujours respecté les institutions qui a
toujours respecté le les corps
intermédiaires également mais c'était
aussi une autre époque de la vie
politique où il y avait des pratiques
étaient différentes et c'est vrai que
son départ ce marque à peu la faim
symbolique d'un ancien monde une façon
de faire de la politique qu'on pourrait
lui faire aujourd'hui
oui une page qui se tourne une façon de
faire de la politique qui meurt donc
avec lui on va passer aujourd'hui s'il
ya l'actualité de cette question le
thème dominant ça va être lincendie de
lusine de lubrizol à rouen c'est un
événement qui a eu d'ailleurs le même
jour que la mort de jacques chirac
certains vendeurs estimé que ça et même
éclipsé le drame d'euros mais là il
retrouve vraiment bien le devant de la
scène ce terrible drame avec ses
répercussions
c'est un peu le fonctionnement des
médias qui veut que quand il ya une
émotion avec le départ d'une
personnalité ça prend le pas sur le
reste de l'actualité
mais ça n'a pas complètement pris le pas
non plus puisque la sphère de lusine de
lubrizol est quand même quelque chose de
grande ampleur tuerie qu'il ya beaucoup
de questions qui se posent et la
population commence un peu à s'irriter
de ne pas être informé donc là dessus il
ya effectivement quelque chose à faire
quelque chose à creuser et c'est bon
maintenant qu'une fois que l'hommage
rendu à jacques chirac qu'on revienne
sur cette actualité qui est quand même
importante une actualité d'ailleurs sur
laquelle le parlement va se pencher on
appris qu'il allait y avoir une mission
d'information à l'assemblée nationale et
puis ici on me voit qu'il devrait y
avoir une commission denquête en tout
cas c'est ce qu'espère beaucoup de
parlementaires
c'est normal que le parlement se
saisisse et c'est bien justement que ce
soit pas le même format l'assemblée au
sénat sur la mission d'information
permet d'aller vite de rendre de rendre
des conclusions à serra n'a pas les
mêmes pouvoirs un qu'une commission
justement si elle est plus facile à
mettre en place il ya moins peut-être
deux
de décorum moins de solennité mais le
but des sénateurs des députés était
d'arriver vite à des conclusions
alors que les sénateurs sont plus dans
le temps long et donc ils vont peut-être
davantage creusé et arriver à des
préconisations différentes qui sont plus
de l'ordre de la manière de travailler
la manière de contrôler ces sites la
manière de gérer les catastrophes de ce
type alors que pour les députés c'est
plus avoir les informations rassurer la
population comprendre ce qui s'est passé
votre avis semelle sur la façon dont le
gouvernement a géré et bien cette
situation de crise certains jugent qu'il
ya des véritable couac de communication
est ce que c'est votre cas est ce qu'on
pouvait faire mieux
certainement la catastrophe a eu lieu il
ya cinq jours on peut pas on n'a pas le
recul encore pour mesurer analyser s'il
ya eu des erreurs ou pas d'où elles
seraient venus parfois qu'on pourra voir
des informations il faut mener des
analyses qui se font pas en 24-48 heures
donc il faut aussi comprendre comment ça
fonctionne comprendre qu'on ne peut pas
avoir toutes les informations tout de
suite même si effectivement la
population le demande et quelque part
est en droit d'avoir ses informations
quand on voit les conséquences visibles
de cette catastrophe avec des pollutions
de l'eau des hydrocarbures qui tombe sur
les cultures la préfecture qui dit qu'il
ne faut pas consommer les légumes
il ya une inquiétude légitime bien merci
beaucoup samuel d'avoir répondu à mes
questions et notamment sur ce thème qui
va largement occupé cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
on poursuit d'ailleurs et bien sûr ce
sujet avec vous alexandre pousse à vous
êtes avec le sénateur socialiste de
seine maritime didier marié il va
interpeller le gouvernement d'ailleurs à
ce sujet et oui didier marie vous aller
interpeller le gouvernement sur cet
accident industriel et cet incendie de
lusine lubrizol alors il ya une mission
d'information à l'assemblée il y aura
normalement une commission denquête au
sénat c'est important que le parlement
se saisisse du dossier
oui c'est particulièrement important
parce que c'est l'accident industriel le
plus important depuis azf en 2001
j'étais d'ailleurs à l'époque dans la
commission denquête et de cette
commission denquête il est ressorti
toute une série de préconisations qui
ensuite ont été
mise en oeuvre et donc que le parlement
se saisisse fasse des propositions
ensuite pour améliorer la sécurité
industrielle c'est absolument
indispensable et donc je suis très
heureux que nous puissions au sénat à la
demande d'ailleurs des sénateurs
socialistes mais aussi d'autres groupes
mettre en oeuvre cette commission d
enquête parlementaire
il faut encore la confirmer ça sera
complémentaire de la mission qui est
engagée à l'assemblée nationale ce cette
commission enquête c'est le signe qu'il
ya eu des failles dans la gestion de
l'état sur ce dossier
oui écouter la gestion de la crise a été
tout à fait déplorable
les sirènes ont retenti de nombreuses
heures après le déclaration d'un
incendie il y a eu des consignes pour
confiner les écoles à géométrie variable
certaines ont été fermés d'autres n'ont
pas été les maires n'ont pas été
associés bref les maires ont eu le
sentiment pendant la gestion de cette
crise d'être complètement laissés seuls
certains membres du gouvernement et
notamment la porte parole du
gouvernement si bête ndiaye estime qu'il
y à une instrumentalisation politique de
la part de l'opposition sur ce dossier
qu'en pensez vous que lui répondez-vous
coûté moi j'étais hier soir la
manifestation dans laquelle il y avait
entre quatre et cinq mille rouennaise et
roannais et habitants de l'ensemble de
l'agglomération
c'était des gens qui ne font pas de
politique au quotidien mais par contre
qu'ils respirent les odeurs nauséabondes
depuis maintenant six jours et qui
veulent une seule chose la vérité la
vérité et donc nous nous puissions nous
souhaitons maintenant et c'est ce que je
dirai tout à l'heure au premier ministre
c'est la transparence et des
informations précises nous portons
l'état a fait preuve de transparence la
liste des 5000 produits chimiques qui
ont brûlé lors de cet incendie a été
publiée hier par le gouvernement
c'est un aller par tardivement et
d'autre part je vous invite à vous
pencher sur cette liste et en tirer un
certain nombre d'enseignements
on ne connaît ni la quantité ni la
nocivité
ni l'impact sur la santé une fois que
ces molécules ont été soumis à des
fortes chaleurs et moi ce que je
préconise c'est la nomination d'un
groupe d'experts indépendants à la fois
pour analyser mais aussi pour
interpréter l'ensemble de ces données
dont vous ne faites pas confiance aux
scientifiques qui travaillent et donne
des informations aussi je fais confiance
à tout le monde mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui pour calmer la colère
pour
prévenir de nouvelles angoisses il faut
impérativement que toute la transparence
soit faite et je pense que
l'indépendance des experts est
absolument nécessaire alors prendre du
principe de précaution les agriculteurs
touchés dans cette région attention
attention quand on dit que la non non
juste une question sur ces agriculteurs
qui devront jeter leurs produits qu'ils
ne pourront pas les commercialiser
finalement ce principe de précaution il
est bien utilisé selon vous par le
gouvernement et il est nécessaire
puisque nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui les
résultats de toutes les études donc ne
prenons aucun risque
par contre ce qu'il faut c'est que les
agriculteurs soient indemnisés est
autrement que par un fonds de
mutualisation qu'ils ont eux-mêmes
abondé très bien que l'état assume ses
responsabilités très bien merci beaucoup
dû démarrer pour votre réaction
et on va tout de suite se diriger dans
l'hémicycle où gérard larcher va faire
un hommage à jacques chirac l'ancien
président de la république est décédé la
semaine dernière un hommage du sénat du
président du sénat qui sera suivie de
l'hommage du premier ministre la séance
est ouverte
le compte-rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribué nous
n'avons pas reçu l'observation il y en a
t'il en séance
je l'envoie point il est donc adoptée
sous les réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues jacques chirac nous a
quittés jeudi dans sa 87e année la
nouvelle de sa disparition nous a
plongés et à plonger l'ensemble du pays
dans une grande émotion la séance le
matin avait été suspendu dès l'annoncé
de cette triste nouvelle
rassemblant l'hémicycle dans un moment
de recueillement
philippe dallier qui présidait notre
séance l'après-midi a tenu à rendre un
premier hommage du sénat à cet homme
d'état au parcours exceptionnel qui a
profondément marqué la france les
français version nombreux du sénateur et
ancien sénateur ce lundi à la cérémonie
d'adieu en l'église saint sulpice au nom
du sénat tout entier en présence de vous
monsieur le premier ministre
2 nombre le nombre de membres du
gouvernement se souhaite cet après-midi
rendre un nouvel hommage solennel à
jacques chirac qui tout au long de plus
de 50 années de vie politique a occupé
d'éminentes fonctions
il avait de la france une connaissance
intime celle d'un homme qui a gravi tous
les échelons des mandats d'un élu de
terrain avant de présider au destin de
la nation
née de parents corrézien jacques chirac
fit ses études primaires et secondaires
d'abord à sainte féréole encore s puis à
versailles et à paris
après son bac raison de faire carrière
dans la marine marchande
ils s'engagent à quelques mois comme
pilotin sur un cargo charbonnier mais
son père ne le laissa pas persévérer
dans cette voie il reprit ensuite ses
études sciences po puis l'université de
harvard
enfin l'école nationale d'administration
au cours de son service militaire il se
porta volontaire pour partir vers
l'algérie en guerre
cette période d'aspirants le
sous-lieutenant ne marquera profondément
et il ira jusqu'à dire qu'elle sut
peut-être la plus passionnante de son
existence
si jacques chirac débuta sa carrière à
la cour des comptes près vite il
s'engagea dans la vie politique dès 1962
à 30 ans il devient chargé de mission au
secrétariat général du gouvernement
puis au cabinet du premier ministre
georges pompidou sommateurs en politique
envers qui il témoigna d'une fidélité
indéfectible
parallèlement avec l'énergie et la
ténacité qui le caractérisait il se
lance à la conquête de la corrèze et se
confrontent avec succès au suffrage
universel et suis assis élu conseiller
municipal de sainte féréole en 1965 puis
député de la circonscription d'ussel en
1967 et conseiller général du canton de
meymac en 1968
oui il fait ainsi et lui tissu ensuite
avec la carrière qu'on connaît candidat
aux élections présidentielles de 1981 et
1988 il fut président de la république
en 95 puis réélu
en 2002 oui nous avons tous en mémoire
ces moments particuliers mais vous
permettrait d'apporter de touche plus
personnelle
jacques chirac ministre de l'agriculture
un jacques chirac qui a profondément
marqué le monde agricole dans une
relation exceptionnelle à un moment où
la politique agricole commune se mettait
en place un souvenir aussi personnelle
sans jacques chirac n'aurait jamais été
maire de rambouillet en 1983 un
troisième souvenir dans cet hémicycle
un soir de déclaration de politique
générale suivie de débats où jacques
chirac arrive en smoking ici dans cet
hémicycle
en effet le groupe d'opposition avaient
réclamé sa présence n'estimant pas qu'il
pouvait s'exprimer seulement pardon
monsieur le ministre en charge des
relations avec le parlement
avec le ministre en charge des relations
avec le parlement d'alors andré rossinot
ce sont des sony fort humain et qui
démontre aussi ses qualités
j'ai eu l'honneur de fois d'être avec
d'autres quelques encore ici ministres
des deux gouvernements de jacques chirac
que de souvenirs dans ces conseils des
ministres que le souvenir aussi de
dimanche après midi où il nous convoquer
entre guillemets pour parler cohésion
sociale emploi travail
ces moments sont des souvenirs vivaces
jacques chirac à incarner les valeurs de
notre république la liberté en refusant
toute compromission avec les extrêmes en
assumant le passé de notre pays
ce lumière et ses ombres
son discours du vel d'hiv en est le
symbole le plus éclatant l'égalité en
tentant de résorber la fracture sociale
lui qui avait créé le samu social
lorsqu'il était maire de paris
parce que merde paris il eut aussi cette
formidable reconnaissance des parisiens
faisant son deuxième mandat le grand
chelem dans 20 arrondissements de paris
retour d'un paris qui l'a profondément
aimé transformer comme de la corrèze à
laquelle il était tellement attaché
oui fraternité dans sa proximité avec
les français
dans sa sensibilité à la souffrance de
ceux qui sont empêchés par le handicap
ou la maladie
j'ai le souvenir du texte de 2005 et de
sa présentation en conseil des ministres
il a tâché le plus grand prix être
parvenu à faire adopter trois lois en
faveur de l'intégration des personnes
handicapées
le plan cancer constitué de même que la
sécurité routière un autre grand
chantier de son second mandat
présidentiel
il permet les améliorations dans la
lutte contre cette terrible maladie
sur la scène internationale le président
chirac su conforter la place de la
france et développer son rayonnement
dans le monde
il faut avoir vécu un conseil des
ministres franco-allemand avec jacques
chirac pour mesurer cette dimension de
la relation avec pourtant des
chanceliers différent mais pour l'avoir
partagé pendant trois années
c'était un moment de rayonnement au
travers de cet homme oui il su conforter
la place de la france ils surent aussi
assurer l'adaptation des moyens de notre
défense au progrès technique et à leurs
exigences
il décida et ça n'était pas simple la
professionnalisation
de nos armées et cherche à promouvoir le
multilatéralisme dans les relations
internationales
pourtant la voix de la france il
n'hésita pas à s'opposer aux américains
le non à la guerre en irak restera dans
l'histoire
chacun a évoqué depuis quelques jours
son cri d'alarmé à johannesbourg c'est
vrai président chirac s'attacha à la
préservation de l'environnement domaine
dans lequel il fut à bien des égards un
précurseur des textes majeurs furent
adoptés en 1975 1976 alors qu'il était
premier ministre
la charte de l'environnement fut
intégrée au bloc de constitutionnalité
en 2004 pendant son second mandat
présidentiel jacques chirac aussi était
un homme de culture passionné par
l'histoire des civilisations africaines
et asiatiques domaine dans lequel il
faisait preuve d'une incroyable
érudition il laisse un grand musée
c'était un homme chaleureux attentif aux
au simple aussi prenez le temps
d'écouter d'avoir un mot pour chacun
puis 100 web qu'il compatissait aux
souffrances d'autrui mais pudique et
discret il n'évolue jamais les siennes
alors que la vie ne l'avait pas épargné
sa profonde humanité sa proximité avec
ses concitoyens
ce contact charnel avec les français ont
suscité une sympathie qui dépasse toutes
les sensibilités
comme en a témoigné dimanche les
interminables files d'attentes pour se
recueillir devant son cercueil lors de
l'hommage populaire aux invalides
permettez-moi aussi d'ajouter combien
jacques chirac a aimé la france d outre
mer il l'a aimé passionnément avec
attention
il avait parfaitement compris que la
france n'était vraiment la france
qu'avec ses outre-mer
son épouse bernadette chirac qui attend
vrai je peux en attester pour nos
hôpitaux nos qui fut le président de la
fédération hospitalière de france
sa fille claude chirac à son petit-fils
martin toute sa famille et ses proches
ainsi qu'à tous ceux qui ont partagé ses
engagements je souhaite au nom du sénat
redire en ce moment de recueillement
la part que nous prenons à leur chagrin
peu d'entre vous l'ont connu ici premier
ministre certains l'ont partagé des
spams sur le ministre quand sa grande
silhouette arrivé ici il y avait un
moment particulier d'une relation d'un
grand homme d'état attaché au
bicamérisme et il avait témoigné je vous
propose de nous recueillir un instant
puis je vous donnerai la parole monsieur
le premier ministre
sur le premier ministre
monsieur le président du sénat mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs beaucoup de
choses ont été dites et très bien dit
sur jacques chirac par le président de
la république le jeudi de l'annoncé de
son décès par vous même monsieur le
président à l'instant par de très
nombreux françaises et français célèbres
ou inconnues beaucoup de choses ont été
dites et très bien dit sur jacques
chirac sur ce sublime guerriers de la
politique sur son incroyable carrière
sans doute unique en son genre sur ses
victoires à la hussarde sur ces défaites
retentissantes sur ces erreurs qui n'en
commet pas surtout durant une si longue
carrière
beaucoup de choses ont été dites et très
bien dit sur ses intuitions politiques
profondes sur ses décisions majeures que
le président chirac a prises parfois
soutenues et parfois seul et dont nous
mesurons aujourd'hui la sagesse et la
perspicacité
beaucoup de choses ont été dites et très
bien dit sur sa personnalité attachante
et complexe sur ses habitudes sur ses
goûts sur ces combats secret et ses
blessures intimes
beaucoup de ces récits proviennent de
compagnons de compagnon monsieur le
président dont vous faites partie ainsi
que d'autres sur ces bandes des
compagnons qui sont parfois devenus des
amis
pas tous bien sûr loin s'en faut mais
beaucoup sont devenus des amis
la politique est parfois brutale et
peut-être n'est-elle pas toujours à la
hauteur de ce qu'elle devrait être
et elle peut être quand on le veut
l'expression d'un certain panache et le
creuset d'amitié profonde qui dépasse et
c'est heureux les limites des familles
politiques
quand il s'agit de défendre une idée un
territoire
l'intérêt de la nation ou des valeurs
communes et le sénat monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs est une excellente incarnation
de cette opiniâtreté courtoise ou de
cette courtoisie au pédiatre je ne sais
pas comment il faut le dire de la
république que jacques chirac interne et
lui aussi
c'est beau mais c'est loin
je ne précise pas qui est l'auteur de
cette formule si j'ai retenu cette
phrase ce n'est pas seulement pour
rendre hommage au sens de la formule du
président de la république du président
chirac
mais pour insister sur trois choses la
première c'est que avant d'avoir été un
grand président un grand premier
ministre jacques chirac a été un grand
élu local conseiller municipal de saint
ferréol durant 12 ans conseiller général
de la corrèze président de ce même
département durant neuf ans maire de
paris durant 18 ans un grand élu local
qui a été à la fois un grand élu de la
france rurale et le maire d'une des plus
puissantes métropoles d'europe deux
réalités françaises que jacques chirac
synthétiser et qui n'était pour lui
jamais exclusives l'une de l'autre
la deuxième chose sur laquelle je vais
insister c'est sur ce que dit cette
phrase de la fonction d'élu local
nous sommes nombreux ici avoir sillonné
une ville un canton un département dans
tous les sens probablement aucun a
sillonné autant la france que jacques
chirac
nous savons que un territoire ce n'est
pas un dossier que pour le connaître il
faut l'arpenter physiquement mètre carré
par mètre carré
et quand parfois on arrive à destination
après quelques kilomètres d'une route
cabossée dans un lieu comme il en existe
des milliers en france et qui en font
bien souvent le charme
je sais que nous sommes beaucoup dans
cette assemblée quelles que soient nos
opinions politiques à nous exclamer
intérieur manque quelque chose comme
c'est beau mais c'est loin
j'ajoute que c'est parfois justement
parce que c'est loin que c'est beau mais
c'est un autre débat
cette phrase rappelle enfin que pour
jacques chirac aucun territoire de la
république n'était trop éloignée c'est
évidemment vrai pour les territoires
métropolitains mais c'est encore plus
vrai pour les territoires d'outre-mer
avec lesquels comme vous l'avez dit
monsieur le président il entretenait des
liens extrêmement forts et de proximité
malgré la distance
le moment où les responsables politiques
de l'hexagone aussi des outre mer ainsi
que des chefs d'état du monde entier
ceux recueillis à l'église saint sulpice
nos compatriotes et les élus d outre-mer
rendait hommage à jacques chirac des
centaines de personnes se sont ainsi
réunies place de la république à
mamoudzou à mayotte au jardin de l'état
à saint denis de la réunion des minutes
de silence ont été observées en guyane
en martinique en guadeloupe à wallis et
futuna les habitants nouvelle calédonie
ont pu exprimer leurs émotions dans
plusieurs livres d'or les unes que lui
ont consacré les quotidiens des
territoires d'outre-mer sont
particulièrement éloquente les mêmes
termes reviennent lamoureux lamy le
grand défenseur
il ya le lien personnel que le président
a su tisser avec ces territoires leurs
populations leurs élus il y aussi les
décisions les inflexions majeures qu'il
a prises pour construire l'avenir de ce
territoire
je pense à la création entre 86 et 88 de
la défiscalisation qui a permis
d'orienter des fonds privés dans le
tissu économique des outre-mer autre
inflexion majeure
l'aboutissement du long combat pour
l'égalité des droits sociaux avec
l'alignement en 1996 dans les
territoires ultramarins du salaire
minimum et des prestations sociales sur
leur niveau métropolitain
ce sont aussi des décisions parfois plus
douloureuse
nous nous souvenons bien sûr des
événements de nouvelle calédonie et du
drame d'ouvéa en 1988
nous nous souvenons que 10 ans après
c'est sous la mandature du président
chirac et par le travail du premier
ministre lionel jospin que nous signons
l'accord de nouméa et un grand nombre de
calédoniens se souviennent que c'est
sous l'autorité de jacques chirac que la
république a adopté la révision
constitutionnelle qui gèle le corps
électoral pour les élections
provinciales j'observe
à cet égard qu'en nouvelle calédonie
responsable indépendantiste et
non-indépendantiste ont salué avec une
même émotion la mémoire du président
défunt
nous gardons également en mémoire la
décision difficile car éminemment
stratégique de relance et les essais
nucléaires en polynésie française
une décision qui a provoqué des
contestations parfois violentes mais qui
a garanti notre indépendance
quelques années après le président
chirac et le gouvernement de polynésie
française ont proposé au parlement un
nouveau statut pour le territoire lui
garantissant une plus grande autonomie
et marquant là encore une étape
importante
enfin le président jacques chirac c'est
aussi et vous le savez ici au sénat la
conduite d'une politique courageuse de
reconnaissance de la mémoire de l
esclavage dans le droit fil du rapport
d'edouard glissant
une reconnaissance qui a permis
d'instaurer en 2006 une date officielle
le 10 mai de commémoration une politique
qui consiste au fond à regarder le passé
droit dans les yeux à nommer les choses
pour mieux les surmonter monsieur le
président jacques chirac avait sans
doute toutes les qualités pour faire un
excellent sénateurs il ne l'a jamais été
ceci ne l'a pas empêché de bien
connaître le sénat en tant que ministre
en charge des relations avec le
parlement puis en tant que premier
ministre dans une courte intervention
pour accueillir les membres du bureau du
sénat à l'elysée en 1995 jacques chirac
rappelle qu'il a toujours entretenu des
relations courtoises avec le sénat c'est
un sénateur qu'il nomme premier ministre
en 2002 jean-pierre raffarin un premier
ministre avec lequel il engage l'acte ii
de la décentralisation un acte 2 qui
s'est traduit par la loi
constitutionnelle du 28 mars 2003 et des
avancées considérables que vous
connaissez mieux que quiconque
un enracinement profond une attention
particulière au territoire de la
république
un amour de nos terroirs qui ont fait
jacques chirac l'incarnation de la
france et des français de nous tous en
somme avec ce que laisse avec ce que
cela peut impliquer de défaut de
générosité et parfois de génie
pour paraphraser malraux son patriotisme
ignorer le chauvinisme cet équilibre
subtil exigence est celui d'une france
souveraine autonome farouchement
indépendante d'une france fière de son
identité mais capable de s'ouvrir et de
parler à tous avec raison avec mesure
avec sagesse c'est la france du
multilatéralisme celle du projet
européen et de l'amitié franco allemande
celle de la conscience écologique et du
combat pour réduire les égaler les
inégalités entre le nord et le sud une
conception de la france mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs très gaullienne
en somme qui se situe aux antipodes de
discours que l'on peut entendre parfois
dans une de ses dernières interventions
en mars 2010 est le président chirac
nous exhortait à refuser l'extrémisme
sous toutes ses formes
douze ans après nous savons que ces
propos n'ont rien perdu de leur acuité
et nous placent chacun devant nos
propres responsabilités
mes derniers mots monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
seront pour les proches et la famille du
président chirac pour son épouse qui a
pour sa fille claude
pour son petit fils
on se souvient de cette réflexion de
madame chirac au lendemain de la défaite
de son mari aux élections
présidentielles de 1988 elle avait dit
les français n'aiment pas mon mari est
bien s'il ya une chose que l'on peut
retenir de ces derniers jours monsieur
le président c'est que des français mais
passionnément jacques chirac sans doute
plus qu'il ne l'imaginait eux-mêmes et
peut-être plus que lui ne l'imaginé il
l'aimait comme on aime parfois ceux qui
vous ressemble le plus avec des
intermittences d impatience mais aussi
avec une profonde tendresse et une
fidélité peu commune qui résiste à tous
aux vicissitudes de la vie politique aux
erreurs aux opinions du moment et
surtout autant je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
proposé me recueillir encore quelques
instants
je vous remercie
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement la séance
est retransmise sur public sénat notre
site internet nous serons attentifs aux
deux temps et au respect des uns des
autres
la parole est maintenant madame la
présidente catherine morin desailly pour
le groupe de l'union centriste
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
jeudi dernier un terrible incendie qui
heureusement n'a fait aucune victime a
ravagé une partie de l'usiné lubrizol de
roue en générant un immense nuage noir
qui s'est abattue sur une partie de la
seine maritime et au delà merci vraiment
aux forces de l'ordre aux salariés de
l'usiné et à nos pompiers car le pire a
été évité mais j'ai les habitants une
légitime angoisse et colère demeurent
les enquêtes judiciaires administratives
doivent rapidement déterminer les
responsabilités mais là c'est la santé
qui prime
des réponses précises et des
explications claires sont attendus lors
de votre venue monsieur le premier
ministre vous vous êtes engagé à la
transparence
elle est garantie par l'article 7 de la
charte de l'environnement
hier le préfet dévoilé des chiffres
alarmants 5253 tonnes de produits
chimiques brûlé 160 fut toujours
entreposés en état délicat il faut que
les prochaines analyses nous renseigne
sur les molécules dégagé qui ont été
inhalé les retombées de suie et leurs
conséquences nos familles sont inquiètes
vous avez reconnu la nécessité d'un
suivi médical de long terme il faut
aussi un suivi épidémiologique strictes
qui doit s'appliquer à ceux qui sont
intervenus sur le sinistre ainsi qu'à
toute la population touchée d'une
manière ou d'une autre
si comme vous le dites l'état de
catastrophe technologique n'est pas
envisagée quel est alors votre solution
pour indemniser les victimes
je remercie dj guillaume qui a reconnu
la gravité de la situation et promis des
aides à nos agriculteurs éleveurs et
maraîchers des 206 commune de normandie
et des hauts de france impacté par la
suspension des récoltes et des collectes
de lait enfin lorsqu'un événement de
cette gravité ampleur se produit il faut
que l'ensemble des maires soient bien
informés ils nous ont dit regretter de
n'avoir pas toujours pu jouer leur rôle
auprès de la population pour vous
répondre la parole est à monsieur le
premier ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
présidente
lundi soir nous étions tous les deux et
avec d'autres parlementaires sénateurs
et députés sur le site et pour mesurer
l'ampleur de l'incendié
je voudrais aller dans le sens de ce que
vous avez indiquée madame la présidente
pour dire que cet incendie très
spectaculaire et graves a été maîtrisé
en 12 heures sans victimes et 100
blessés grâce à l'exceptionnelle qualité
de l'intervention des pompiers je
répondrais sur tous les points que vous
avez évoquées madame la présidente
mais je voudrais que ici au sénat et je
sais que vous le mesurer parfaitement
on songe bien à la qualité
exceptionnelle de ses interventions qui
en douze heures a permis d'éviter
l'effet domino la l'expansion du feu qui
d'une zone de stockage aurait pu aller
jusqu'à des zones de production avec des
conséquences qui auraient été bien plus
grave
cela a été empêché grâce à une
remarquable mobilisation des services de
l'état
grâce à une remarquable coordination
entre les salariés du site et les forces
de l'ordre et les forces de secours
et encore une fois toutes les questions
vous avez posées sont légitimes mais
gardons à l'esprit
l'exceptionnelle qualité de ce travail
de cette première réponse je comprends
madame la présidente parfaitement
l'émotion
l'inquiétude qui peut aller jusqu'à la
colère des rouennais et au delà
d'ailleurs de tous les habitants de la
métropole et de tous les habitants des
communes qui ont vu passer le nuage ou
qui s'interrogent sur les conséquences
de ce nuage sur leur santé je redis le
plus clairement et le plus fermement
l'engagement absolu du gouvernement de
l'état à la transparence totale complète
toutes les informations toutes les
données scientifiques qui seront rendues
disponibles par les analyses mise en
oeuvre seront communiqués au public tout
le principe de précaution a été appliqué
avec vigilance
dès le premier jour les recommandations
claires ont été formulées et je vous
entends volontiers madame la présidente
quand vous dites que dans la diffusion
de l'information le préfet l'a reconnu
je veux lui dire mon soutien
car son action était délicate mais le
reconnu le préfet reconnu lui-même dans
une rencontre avec les maires de la
métropole rennaise que la qualité de
l'information aux premières heures de
l'évènement à destination d'un certain
nombre de mères n'avaient peut-être pas
été à la hauteur des aspirations
légitimes formulées par les magistrats
les premiers magistrats de leur commune
et donc de ce point de vue là les
retours d'expérience que nous aurons à
conduire pour apprendre de cet événement
mettra en évidence sans doute
l'amélioration qu'il faut porter sur ce
point mais les consignes de vigilance
ont été immédiatement donnée nous avons
fait procéder au nettoyage de toutes les
écoles avant leur réouverture lundi une
campagne de surveillance approfondie de
l'ensemble des impacts environnementaux
dans l'eau dans l'air dans les sols avec
des prélèvements a débuté dès vendredi
dès vendredi les résultats sont et
seront rendus publics au fur et à mesure
de leur arrivée en fonction des produits
qui sont testés en fonction de la
difficulté technique de ses analyses ses
analyses peuvent prendre plus de temps
mais elles seront toutes rendues
publiques
j insiste j'ai demandé au préfet de
normandie de rendre compte au public
chaque jour en fin d'après-midi de
l'avancée des travaux
à l'occasion d'une conférence de presse
il sera appuyé par une cellule nationale
d'appui scientifique car beaucoup de
questions techniques environnementales
ou médicales sont posées et il faut
apporter à ces questions techniques
environnementales ou médicales des
réponses précises c'est la raison pour
laquelle le directeur général de
l'ineris un expert de santé publique
france le chef du service de pneus
pneus mollo j du chu de rouen seront
associés à ces prises de parole afin de
pouvoir répondre le plus précisément
possible aux questions qui ne manqueront
pas d'être posée hier
hier soir hier en fin d'après-midi le
préfet a rendu publique la liste
complète des produits présents dans
l'entrepôt qui a brûlé avec les
caractéristiques de ces produits et les
risques associés
je veux sur ce point être clair mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs depuis la fin
de l'année 2017 et pour des raisons de
sécurité qui n'échappera à personne
la liste complète des substances
autorisées sur les sites seveso n'était
plus rendues publiques mais dans tous
les cas dans tous les cas cette liste ne
dit rien des produits et des quantités
qui sont réellement présents sur le site
à un moment donné la liste que nous
avons rendu public hier et précise elle
donne les produits qui étaient
effectivement présents dans l'entrepôt
qui a brûlé dans l'entrepôt qui a brûlé
avec leur quantité
l'état a pu recevoir la liste précise
mardi matin nous l'avons publié dans la
journée sur la base de cette liste
l'ineris landes cesse seront saisis
aujourd'hui pour faire des
recommandations sur des produits
supplémentaires à rechercher dans l'air
ou dans les suit mesdames et messieurs
les années nous ne savons pas tout
aujourd'hui parce que les analyses sont
en cours
et parce qu'il va falloir les poursuivre
et pendant longtemps nous ne savons pas
tout aujourd'hui ce que nous savons
d'ores et déjà sur la qualité de l'air
c'est que tous les prélèvements dans
l'air dont nous disposons à cette heure
et qui sont publics font apparaître un
état habituel de la qualité de l'air sur
le plan sanitaire à l'extérieur du site
les analyses complémentaires ont été
engagés pour vérifier si des fibres
d'amiante sont présentes dans l'air
parce que la toiture des bâtiments qui
ont brûlé en contenait les premiers
résultats pour les mesures faites dans
un rayon de 300 mètres autour du site
ont été rendus publics hier il montre qu
aucune fibre n'a été détectée dans les
prélèvements de surface et qu'il n'y a
pas d'anomalie sur les prélèvements dans
l'air
d'autres résultats sur des zones plus
éloignées vont suivre dans les prochains
jours et évidemment ils seront rendus
publics
je n'ignore pas les odeurs incommodantes
qui perturbe qui perdurait encore hier
j'ai parfaitement conscience qu'elle
gêne j'ai parfaitement conscience
qu'elles inquiètent la population mais
les résultats connus des mesures d'air
permettent aux autorités sanitaires ce
n'est pas moi qui le dit ce sont les
autorités sanitaires d'affirmer que ces
odeurs ne présente pas de risque pour la
santé les services de l'état travaillent
d'ailleurs avec l'entreprise pour
résorber les sources d'odeur
comme l'indiqué le préfet mardi les
opérations nettoyage du sud du site sont
en cours et une protection sera
installée sur la zone contenant des flux
endommagée pour capter les flux d'air je
voudrais terminer et je voudrais vous
prier monsieur le président de cette
réponse trop longue mais compte tenu de
l'émotion je crois qu'il croit qu'il est
important que au travers je viens c'est
une à l'ensemble de la population soit
informée je vous remercie de pouvoir
préciser les choses de la façon la plus
claire possible
vous avez évoqué madame la présidente la
possibilité de faire reconnaître l'état
de catastrophe technologique et un
certain nombre d'élus rouennais m'ont
saisi de cette possibilité offerte par
une loi de 2003 la loi bachelot de 2003
qui a créé cette possibilité a mis en
place par cette loi un régime
d'indemnisation des victimes de
catastrophes technologie ce régime
je le dis au sénat vise à faciliter le
traitement des accidents qui ont eu un
très fort impact sur les biens
immobiliers et mobiliers en s'appuyant
sur le précédent d'azf à toulouse en
2001 pour lequel des milliers de
logements avaient été impactées voire
rendus inutilisables
dans le cas présent le dispositif tel
qu'il a été conçu les critères qui ont
été posées par la loi même ne semble pas
en première analyse adapté à ce que nous
vivons pas complètement adaptée
il n'y a pas eu de dommages importants
sur les logements dans l'environnement
du site et le dispositif ne concerne
d'ailleurs pas l'indemnisation des
producteurs agricoles
dans tous les cas et je veux le dire car
il y à un acteur que nous n'avons pas
encore mentionné
dans tous les cas je veillerai à ce que
les mesures prises pour l'indemnisation
immédiate des agriculteurs qui voient
leur production en vertu du principe de
précaution
non commercialisé les riverains
l'ensemble de ceux qui subissent un
préjudice ou un dommage je veillerai à
ce que rien ne vienne exonérer la
responsabilité de l'industriel car en
fait d'installations classées le régime
juridique qui a été posé par la loi est
complétée par la loi prévoit qu'il y à
bien un responsable l'entreprise
l'acteur industriel qui est responsable
des dommages causés au voisinage du fait
des activités à l'intérieur du site
industrie s'agissant de la demande et je
conclus par là s'agissant de la demande
de mettre en place un suivi médical de
long terme ou une étude épices et une
pardon et une étude épidémiologique en
la matière la réponse est évidemment que
comme pour la transparence le
gouvernement et l'état mettra tout en
oeuvre pour dire pour mesurer et pour
faire connaître l'ensemble des causes et
des conséquences de cet incendie de
cette catastrophe industrielle dont nous
souhaitons et dont nous allons veiller à
ce qu'elle ne devienne pas une
catastrophe sanitaire ou une catastrophe
environnementale
dams et messieurs les sénateurs je vous
prie de bien vouloir excuser le temps
que j'ai pris pour répondre à cette
question mais il me semble important
d'aller jusqu'au bout mais merci
monsieur le premier ministre
madame la présidente merci monsieur le
premier ministre de vos réponses vous
avez vous l'avez reconnu la crise est
grave les sanitaires écologiques
économiques
elle nous interpelle sur la sécurité des
sites seveso en général ça ne nous bien
préparés à gérer ces crises
industrielles même si nos paupières
hautes et absolument extraordinaire vous
l'avez dit toutes les leçons utiles et
ont elles été tirées des cdf c'est une
question nous allons prendre nos
responsabilités aussi au sénat créer une
commission denquête mes chers collègues
ou de contrôle commune qui nous
permettra un suivi très strict de cette
situation et des analyses qui nous
seront utiles pour progresser et faire
en sorte qu'un tel drame ne se
reproduise plus tu vous remercie merci
madame la présidente
la parole est à notre collègue didier
rambaud pour le groupe de la république
en marche vers la parole monsieur le
président madame la ministre de la
cohésion des territoires lors du congrès
des maires ruraux de france vous avez
présenté avec le premier ministre le
plan d'action du gouvernement dit agenda
rural et ses 173 mesure faisant suite au
travail d'une mission d'élu pour
reprendre votre expression vous
souhaitez faire du cousu main
vous avez raison il n'existe plus une
seule ruralité mais plusieurs formes de
réalité depuis l'hyper rural jusqu'au
péri urbain en passant par la montagne
comme ancien maire d'une commune rurale
chabon edimbourg centre le grand lemps
j'accueille donc ce plan avec beaucoup
d'espoir espoir car de nombreuses
mesures annoncées sont attendues depuis
longtemps la revitalisation des
centralités avec le soutien aux petits
commerces
le développement des lieux de
convivialité notamment l'opération mille
cafés dans les villages ou encore le
renforcement de l'accompagnement de la
jeunesse de ces territoires en lui
facilitant l'accès aux services dont ils
n'ont pas toujours connaissance les
cartes de réduction le permis à un euro
etc
et puis bien sûr d'autres propositions
sur la culture
l'accès au numérique ou à notre système
de santé mais madame la ministre vous
savez bien après le temps des annonces
doit venir le temps des actes concrets
afin de garantir la
une réalisation des mesures de ce plan
d'action pouvez-vous d'abord nous
préciser la méthode employée pour
définir la carte de géographie
prioritaire des ruralités ainsi que le
calendrier de cet agenda
quand ces territoires pourront-ils
concrètement ressentir ses effets et
répondre à des appels à projets je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole à
madame jacqueline go une liste de la
cohésion des territoires des relations
avec les collectivités territoriales
monsieur le sénateur rambo nous
partageons donc cette analyse sur le
fait qu'il n'existe pas une mais des
ruralités et qu'il faut effectivement
passé des annonces aux actes concrets
pour améliorer la vie quotidienne des
habitants de nos campagnes pour y
parvenir
vous l'avez rappelé nous avons donné
suite à un grand nombre de propositions
de la mission agenda rural dont je tiens
ici à saluer la qualité du travail
réalisé
la mission avait notamment recommandé
d'élaborer une géographie prioritaire
des territoires ruraux
le gouvernement a décidé d'y donner
suite
car nous pensons qu'il est nécessaire de
concentrer nos efforts dans les
territoires qui en ont le plus besoin
aujourd'hui vous le savez il existe des
zones de revitalisation rurale les
fameuses zrr qui sont importantes pour
les territoires elles couvrent près
d'une commune sur deux dans notre pays
et leurs effets nécessite d'être évalués
vous êtes d'ailleurs un certain nombre
sur ses bancs à le penser
je pense tout particulier à bernard
delcros frédérique espagnac et rémy
pointereau qui viennent de faire un
rapport sur ce sujet c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons pris de
décisions tout d'abord prolongé jusqu'à
fin 2020 le zonage federer pour les
quêtes 1074 commune qui devait sortir en
juin prochain
et puis bien sûr travailler sur une
nouvelle géographie prioritaire
nous avons une année
pour le faire je le dis dès à présent
cette nouvelle géographie prioritaire
sera naturellement défini en lien avec
les élus
bien sûr les membres de la mission mais
aussi des associations d'élus enfin les
associations d'élus et bien sûr des
parlementaires la méthode du
gouvernement et constante partir des
besoins des territoires et co construire
les solutions avec ceux qui les
représentent
merci sur hbo le la parole à d'autres
collègues stéphane artano pour le groupe
du rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre en 2013 le sénat sous
l'impulsion de nos collègues jacques
mézard et alain milon impulser une
commission d' enquête sur les dérives
sectaires dans le domaine de la santé a
sorti de quarante et une recommandation
pour répondre à cette problématique
la conséquence des dérives sectaires
dans le domaine de la santé c'est un
nombre important de décès prématurés
chaque année personne ne peut l'ignorer
ne nous y trompons pas ce phénomène
touche toute la société justifie
pleinement
l'existence de la mission
interministérielle de vigilance et de
lutte contre les dérives sectaires
miviludes
créé en 1996 son efficacité n'est plus à
démontrer récemment encore c'est elle
qui a révélé l affaire des essais
cliniques non autorisées sur 350 malades
de parkinson et alzheimer ce service
disposant d'un savoir faire que de
nombreux pays nous envient et considérés
comme uniques au monde parce qu'il est à
la fois observatoire est à la fois
régulateur
depuis un an cette mission placée sous
votre autorité monsieur le premier
ministre n'a plus de président suite au
départ de ce dernier et je le regrette
depuis plusieurs semaines quelques mois
des rumeurs circulent sur un
rattachement au ministère de l'intérieur
auprès de comité interministériel de la
prévention de la délinquance et de la
radicalisation ou du bureau chargé des
cultes
ce rattachement à d'ailleurs déjà été
évoqués ou suggérés par la cour des
comptes en 2017
il semblerait que ce rattachement au
titre de la police administrative de la
prévention a été récemment confirmée par
le ministère l'intérieur
est-ce à penser que la miviludes
perdrait 2 fait en conséquence ses
pouvoirs en matière de police
judiciaire la miviludes ont tant que
mission interministérielle est
indispensable dans notre société toucher
à tous les niveaux par les dérives
sectaires et les phénomène d'emprise
mentale
monsieur le premier ministre nous
aimerions je ne suis pas le seul sur ces
bombes connaître vos intentions sur
l'avenir de la miviludes sur son
possible rattachement au ministère de
l'intérieur dans quelles conditions
si cela est confirmé avec quels moyens
et pour quelles missions
je remercie pour vous répondre la parole
et secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
de l'intérieur monsieur laurent du neige
avaient la parole monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur en 2002 effectivement a été
créée la miviludes la mission
interministérielle de vigilance et de
lutte contre les dérives sectaires qui a
exerce des missions extrêmement
importante
d'abord c'est d'analyser le phénomène
des dérives sectaires qui vous le savez
émouvant évolutif et on l'a vu au cours
de ces vingt dernières années
ensuite il s'agit d'assurer la
coordination de la politique préventive
et répressive de la lutte contre les
dérives sectaires
et puis la miviludes un rôle extrêmement
important en matière de formation des
agents publics et puis d'une manière
générale de sensibilisation du public
sur ce que sont les dérives sectaires
aujourd'hui nous constatons je vous
permettent de faire trois observations
c'est que les missions telles qu'elles
sont exercées par la miviludes
aujourd'hui elle implique sans doute une
meilleure synergie un meilleur partage
de compétences avec d'autres organismes
qui ont vu le jour depuis 2002 et qui
exerce également sur le champ des
emprises notamment des dents emprise
mentale et autres et je pense notamment
secrétaire secrétariat général pardon au
comique du comité interministériel de la
prévention de la délinquance et de la
radicalisation
deuxièmement nous avons un rapport de la
cour des comptes et vous l'avez cité qui
en 2017 avait émis l'hypothèse d'un
rattachement de la miviludes au
ministère de l'intérieur
troisièmement et c'est une remarque de
bonne administration de bonne gestion il
est de bonne politique que les
politiques publiques soit menée dans les
ministères bien évidemment sous
l'impulsion et la coordination du
premier ministre et de son cabinet c'est
pour ces raisons effectivement qu'il a
été décidé de rattacher la miviludes
deux au ministère de l'intérieur où ses
compétences s'exercent seront en
parfaite synergie avec d'autres
compétences exercées en matière dans
prison ferme de radicalité mais ce que
je peux vous dire monsieur le sénateur
je le dis d'ailleurs à l'ensemble du
sénat c'est que les missions qui sont
celles de la miviludes les moyens qui
sont ceux de la miviludes ne seront
absolument pas remis en cause il ne
s'agit pas de revenir sur les 20 ans de
ce bilan extrêmement positif qui a été
celui de la miviludes et nous veillerons
à ce que la nouvelle organisation ne se
réduisent pas à la lutte contre une
seule forme d'emprise l'ensemble du
phénomène des dérives sectaires sera
bien appréhendé dans le cadre de ses
missions moyens mission maintenu la
détermination du gouvernement à lutter
contre ce phénomène et dérives sectaires
continuer est pleine et entière
merci la parole est à notre collègue
céline brulin pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologistes avaient
la parole moins chers collègues
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames messieurs les ministres vous
avez enfin accepté de publier la liste
des produits stockés chez lubrizol
mais j'imagine et j'espère que les
services de l'état ont disposé alors
pourquoi ne pas avoir fait évaluer dès
les premières heures de l'instant dit
les conséquences sur la santé humaine
celle des animaux sur l'air l'eau les
sols ou les cultures de la combustion de
ce cocktail de sus de substances face
aux effets sur la santé des populations
touchées
quel plan d'action sanitaire qu'elle
suivit épi dieu épidémiologique comptez
vous concrètement mettre en oeuvre
qu'est-il prévu pour les salariés
présents sur le site
lors de la dent lincendie pour les
sapeurs pompiers ou les forces de
l'ordre qui sont intervenues qui ont mis
leur vie en jeu et qui ont souvent
l'impression comme nos concitoyens
qu'ils courent de grands risques
les élus locaux seront finalement réunis
comme nous le demandons pouvez-vous nous
garantir qu'ils seront désormais
consultés et associés à chaque nouvelle
étape leur mise à l'écart l'isolement--
même le mépris qu'ils ont ressenties
sont inacceptables mais surtout contre
productif vous vous êtes privés
d'acteurs mages
heures dans la gestion de la crise
lusine lubrizol à bénéficier de ce que
vous appelez des simplification de la
législation
ce sont en réalité un détricotage du
droit de l'environnement et un recul des
exigences de sûreté en l'occurrence
l'augmentation des stocks sans étude de
dangers allez vous abandonnez vos
projets d'alléger encore les obligations
d'évaluation environnementale pour les
sites industriels sans attendre la
commis tant la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale dont nous nous réjouissons
nous voulons et la population veut des
réponses précises à ses questions
précises quand vous répondre la parole
est à la ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire vadam board
avait la parole je suis président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice céline brun brûla
excusez moi
tout d'abord comme le premier ministre
et d'autres collègues je me suis rendu
sur le site et donc je mesure pleinement
à la fois l'émotion et l'inquiétude des
populations qui ont été touchés par
cette catastrophe industrielle et donc
je voudrais vous redire l'engagement du
gouvernement à agir avec la plus grande
exigence et avec une transparence totale
c'est dans cet esprit que dès le début
de l'incendié
des mesures ont été réalisées à la fois
sur l'air sur les retombées du panache
de fumée donc sur les suisses qui se
sont déposées
donc ces mesures cette surveillance de
l'environnement
elle est faite depuis le départ les
analyses dont nous disposons aujourd'hui
on fait apparaître qu'il n'y avait pas
de de concentration anormale de produits
que ce soit dans l'air ou dans les suit
qui ont été analysées alors
effectivement le préfet a publié hier la
liste des produits qui avait qui se
trouvaient sur le site incendié sur la
partie incendiée du site qui représente
15% du site
cette liste elle a dû être établi à
notre demande par l'industriel parce que
comme vous le savez les autorisations
dont au demeurant plus public
pour les raisons exprimées par le
premier ministre portent sur la totalité
du site et ce qui était recherché
c'était la liste des produits sur la
partie incendiée du site qui a donc été
diffusée dès qu'elle nous a été remise
par l'industriel et sur cette base avec
agnès buzyn nous allons saisir landes
cesse et l'ineris pour savoir s'il faut
faire des analyses supplémentaires en
tout cas sur tous ces sujets moi je peux
vous assurer de la totale détermination
du gouvernement à assurer la plus grande
transparence à répondre à toutes les
questions des élus qui seront associés à
toutes les étapes du processus est bien
évidemment comme nous voulons cette
transparence totale tous les élément
pourrait être fourni à la commission
denquête syvlain j'avais huit secondes
merci monsieur le président je crois
qu'il faut que nous ayons collectivement
conscience que les réponses que vous
apportez et que je dirais que nous sont
répétés un peu en boucle ne répond pas à
la colère qui se développent parmi nos
concitoyens
il faut en tenir compte il ya une
inspiration immense à ce que l'état
protège
je crois que cette demande est légitime
et qu'il faut l'entendre et ils
répondent très concrètement je vous
remercie
merci la parole et à notre collègue
didier marie pour le groupe socialiste
et républicain
c'est le premier ministre mesdames
messieurs des ministres permettez-moi
d'associer à mon intervention nelly
tocqueville sénatrice de seine-maritime
et mes collègues des hauts de france il
ya six jours l'agglomération de rouen a
vécu la plus importante catastrophe
industrielle connue depuis le drame
d'azf en 2001 lincendie lusine du brise
hall a généré un gigantesque nuage de
fumée noire épaisse et nauséabonde dont
les particules ont tapissé jardin cour
d'école habitations et récolte
constituant une véritable marée noire
terrestre le pire a été évité grâce au
courage et 240 sapeurs-pompiers au
personnel de l usine dont je salue le
dévouement
mais monsieur le ministre la gestion de
cette crise n'a pas été satisfaisante
les maires ont été livrés à eux-mêmes
sirène d'alert actionnait tardivement
absence d'information dans certaines
communes pourtant très proches du
sinistre consignes de confinement
confuse cacophonie totale quant à
l'ouverture ou la fermeture des
établissements scolaires les
communications distillées au fil des
heures se voulaient rassurantes elles
ont produit l'effet inverse et la colère
a rempli le vide d'information
comment croire qu'il n'ya pas de danger
quand le préfet annonce qu'il n'y a pas
d'eau risque de toxicité aiguë
reconnaissant implicitement que les
fumées sont bien toxiques
comment accepter qu'il n'y ait aucun
risque lorsque l'état publie tardivement
la liste des produits partis en fumée et
que l'on en connaît ni la quantité ni la
résistance à la chaleur ni la
dangerosité
comment se sentir en sécurité quand ils
restent 165 fut endommagée qui peuvent
dégager du sulfure d'hydrogène hautement
toxiques
comment être rassurés lorsque les
agriculteurs de 206 communes ne sont
toujours pas autorisés à procéder aux
récoltes vendre leur lait et leurs
produits agricoles monsieur le premier
ministre pour apaiser la colère et les
angoisses
nous vous demandons d'accéder aux
demandes suivantes la transparence vous
y êtes engagés nous vous en remercions
la nomination d'un comité d'experts
indépendants chargé d'analyser
d'interpréter les résultats des études
sera la bienvenue
la mise en place d'un suivi médical à
court et long terme
la reconnaissance de l'état de
catastrophe technologique qui
permettrait d'ouvrir droit à
indemnisation
même si les biens n'ont pas été détruits
et la réparation rapide des dommages en
ordonnant préfet d'exercer ses
prérogatives de police administrative et
d'appliquer le principe de
pollueur-payeur
sans attendre l'issue des procédures
judiciaires qui prendront des années il
faut rétablir la confiance et la
sérénité en faisant preuve de sérieux et
de responsabilité et ses propositions
formulées avec une centaine d'élus
peuvent-ils contribuer
non monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur didier marie je vous ai indiqué
à l'occasion de la réponse que je
formule et un madame la présidente
membres de cyi les engagements pris par
le gouvernement de transparence totale
je vous ai dit que nous donnions les
éléments qui sont en notre possession au
fur et à mesure que nous les avons et
vous comprendrez bien je veux pas
prendre le sujet à la légère que je ne
peux pas produire les résultats des
analyses avant qu'elles aient été
réalisés lorsque vous tester un certain
nombre de prélèvements pour vérifier la
présence éventuelle de dioxine ça prend
du temps
ce n'est pas moi qui le dis je ne suis
pas chimiste c'est les gens qui font ces
analyses les spécialistes qui les font
bien parce qu'ils doivent donner une
information sérieuse et précises et je
pense que vous et moi nous accordons
parfaitement sur ce point dès que nous
les avons nous les communiquent au j'ai
parfaitement conscience qu'au fur et à
mesure que nous donnons des informations
de nouvelles questions se posent
et c'est bien naturel et nous ne nous
arrêterons pas à cela au contraire
toutes les informations qui seront
publiques qui seront connus seront
rendues publiques qu'elles susciteront
de nouvelles questions de nouvelles
interrogations parfois peut-être de
nouvelles angoisses et nous y répondrons
car j'ai parfaitement conscience
monsieur le sénateur que la parole est
parfois les expertises publiques sont
contestées et que certains dès lors que
je dirais ou que quiconque du monde
administratif ou politiques s'expriment
sur un sujet ne serait pas crédible
je le sais je le mesure et je le déplore
mais je ne vais pas pour cela commencer
à raconter n'importe quoi ou arrêter de
donner les informations donc nous allons
faire exactement ce que je me suis
engagé à faire donner au fur et à mesure
qu'elles sont disponibles
absolument toutes les informations dans
les questions et dans les demandes que
vous avez formulées monsieur le sénateur
j'ai déjà dit oui et je leur dis
volontiers à cette tribune
oui à la transparence totale bien
entendu bien entendu oui au suivi
épidémiologique est au bilan de santé
à court et à long terme bien entendu car
il faut être précis
oui à la discussion scientifique des
éléments qui seront données par les
analyses vous me permettrez de dire que
c'est d'abord à landresse à l'ineris aux
hôpitaux de donner les éléments et de
répondre à des questions mais par
définition ces informations et en public
elles seront discutées peut être
contesté par d'autres scientifiques ou
d'autres médecins cette discussion ne me
fait pas peur elle est nécessaire alors
a lieu et nous expliquerons vous
m'interrogez sur l'état de catastrophe
technologique je comprends et je vois
bien l'intérêt qu'il pourrait y avoir à
reconnaître officiellement qu'une
catastrophe a eu lieu à l'évidence une
catastrophe a eu lieu mais l'instrument
juridique tel qu'il a été conçu par le
parlement en 2003 ne répond
manifestement en rien ni aux
caractéristiques ni aux questions que
pose l'accident qui a eu lieu sur le
site de lubrizol est donc je ne veux pas
en la matière je pense que vous êtes
d'accord avec moi je ne veux pas me
payer de mots je veux dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont et mettre en place
les dispositifs tels qu'ils existent et
surtout monsieur le sénateur je veux
dire et redire que la responsabilité
les dommages relève de l'industriel
c'est sa responsabilité et et il
n'échappera pas à la mise en jeu de
cette responsabilité car encore une fois
si toute la législation que vous avez
passé que vous avez produite sur les
installations classées a un sens c'est
bien de dire qu'il y a un interlocuteur
l'acteur industriels qui responsable
alors nous allons appliquer toute la loi
en la matière avec beaucoup de rigueur
et avec la totale transparence qui est
dû à nos concitoyens
la parole est maintenant président
claude malhuret pour le groupe les
indépendants république des territoires
j'ai le président monsieur le premier
ministre mes chers collègues 20 ans de
développement à l'abri de toute
régulation ont permis au géant de
l'internet d'être les maîtres du jeu et
peut-être bientôt du monde
google détient 90% du marché des moteurs
de recherche facebook absorbe les deux
tiers des publicités sur internet amazon
concentrent la moitié des ventes en
ligne aux états unis
en commençant à fixer un cadre et des
règles à ses nouveaux empires la france
c'est attirer la fronde des firmes
concernées et l'hostilité du président
des états unis qui menace de rétorsions
sur les vins français vns hier amazon a
mis en oeuvre sa menace de reporter sur
les vendeurs de sa plateforme la taxe
gaffe a adopté le 11 juillet dernier
dix mille pme se retrouve pieds et
poings liés et certaines devront fermer
les rôles portes le 24 octobre prochain
google entamera un bras de fer contre la
nouvelle loi française sur les droits
voisins prévoyant une redistribution des
revenus du numérique au profit des
éditeurs de presse
l'objectif de google forcé les éditeurs
à céder tous leurs droits et faire
pression auprès des autres gouvernements
européens pour une transposition plus
favorable de la directive européenne le
premier ministre le sherman act
américain de 1890 et les règles
européennes contre les abus de position
dominante ne sont plus adaptées aux
pratiques des gammes femmes convie ce
qu'elle a donné de la vie privée
racheter les startups concurrentes
exclure ses rivaux de la publicité en
ligne
piliers la production des entreprises
d'ultras de presse
ce n'est plus du tout la même chose que
captait 90% du marché du dentifrice les
monopoles dégâts femmes sont sans doute
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus préoccupant
que ne l'était celui de la standard
deuil en 1911 et celui des ti enti en
1982 des deux côtés de l'atlantique de
nouvelles lois antitrust sont
nécessaires et de plus en plus évoquée
il est urgent que l'europe se saisisse
de ce dossier
quelle est la position du gouvernement
français à ce sujet pour vous répondre
là tu enlèves comme monsieur le premier
ministre le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président ma durée comme vous l'avez
évoqué amazon a annoncé sa décision
d'augmenter ses tarifs auprès des
vendeurs en france pour compenser la
taxe sur les services numériques qui a
été créée par la loi du 11 juillet
dernier
la semaine dernière google avait
présenté un nouvel outil de publication
pour les éditeurs et les agences de
presse et celui ci comme par hasard a
été configuré de telle sorte qu'ils
n'ouvrent pas droit à rémunération
contrairement aux principes qui ont été
posées par la loi du 25 juillet 2019 sur
les droits voisins
ces deux faits qui ne sont pas sans lien
pose une question juridique économique
et en vérité politique extrêmement
sérieuse pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
il n'est pas acceptable qu'un acteur
aussi puissant soit-il en l'occurrence
ces deux acteurs sont extrêmement
puissants qu'un acteur puisse changer
les règles d'utilisation de manière
unilatérale pour concernés pour
contourner une obligation légale
l'objectif politique qui a été poursuivi
par la création de la taxe sur les
services numériques comme celles sur les
droits voisins sont extrêmement clair
permettre un juste partage de la valeur
produite au bénéfice des plateformes par
les contenus et services quelle
référence et qui leur procure des
revenus qu'elle conserve aujourd'hui en
quasi totalité voire en totalité
li avec dams et messieurs les sénateurs
en france et en europe des entreprises
qui innovent et qui créent de la valeur
et il ya des gouvernements qui sont
démocratiquement élu les lois sont
votées par les représentations
nationales
les entreprises doivent mesurer
quand s'y opposant c'est au citoyen
libre de ces états qu'elles s'opposent
nous voulons croire nous voulons
vraiment croire que la démarche de
google relève de l'erreur d'appréciation
et non d'une volonté d'engager une
épreuve de force avec la france et
l'europe
c'est pourquoi le ministre de la culture
s'est exprimé le jour même pour que
google engage la négociation qui est
exigé par la loi avec les éditeurs les
agences de presse et la presse doit
évidemment relayé et s'unir pour
reconnaître et faire reconnaître ses
droits dans cette discussion mais la
question appelle évidemment une réponse
européenne fond nous sommes les premiers
à être confrontés à cette question parce
que nous avons été les premiers à
transposer la directive
mais la question concerne ou concernera
tous les pays d'europe
si nous voulons construire l'espace
souverain de droits et de libertés que
nous souhaitons bâtir ensemble à l'ère
du numérique alors l'union européenne au
moins autant que chacun des états qui la
composent doivent se saisir du sujet et
ça exige monsieur le président ma durée
je vous rejoins bien volontiers sur ce
point de modifier à la fois notre corpus
théorique
s'agissant de droit de la concurrence de
politique industrielle et des espaces
numériques et de modifier l'ambition ou
d'enrichir l'ambition de la commission
pour mettre en oeuvre ces nouveaux
concepts
il ya là un défi qui n'est pas une
petite chose car nous avons nous le
savons au sein de l'union européenne
des avis qui sont parfois différents
mais si nous voulons défendre nos droits
et notre conception alors nous devons
être offensif et exigeant c'est un des
éléments que nous avons fait valoir à
l'ensemble de ceux qui ont été proposées
pour composer la future commission et
c'est un des éléments qui a été au coeur
de la discussion entre le président de
la république et la future présidente de
la commission ça ne sera pas un combat
facile car nous avons en face de nous
des gens déterminés et puissant mais ce
qu'il s'agit de faire c'est quand même
de faire respecter notre souveraineté et
notre conception d'un monde numérique
ça n'est pas un petit combat c'est un
difficile combat il nous revient de le
livrer merci la parole est maintenant
président milon pour le groupe les
république à monsieur le président vous
avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur
comme ministre mais chaque collègue ma
question s'adressait au ministre des
comptes publics
je pense que c'est madame du boss qui va
répondre tu aura la lourde charge de
répondre la sécurité sociale madame la
ministre est malade et vous ne
prescrivent est pas le bon remède pire
vous aggravé le mal vous remettez en
cause plusieurs principes fondamentaux
qui constitue à nos yeux le coeur de
notre système de protection sociale
mettez fin à l'autonomie d'insécurité
sociale on ne respectant pas la loi veil
de 1994 et en la privant de près de 3
milliards d'euros
avec la mise en oeuvre des mesures
d'urgence économique et social en
réponse à la crise des jets et jaune par
ailleurs vous mettez fin à son
universalité en matière de politique
familiale alors que la branche famille
est excédentaire
vous ne saisissez pas cette opportunité
pour relancer la politique familiale et
redonner confiance aux familles bien au
contraire ou persévérer dans la casse
déjà mises en place depuis plusieurs
années de notre politique familiale en
prévoyant le quasi gel des aides aux
familles
enfin les décisions du gouvernement en
matière de retraite nous laisse pantois
quant à sa volonté de ramener
l'équilibré du système à court terme à
question madame la ministre est la
suivante le gouvernement en temps utile
uniquement agir sur le levier de la
baisse des pensions d'aujourd'hui et de
demain pour vous répondre en deux parts
en l'état
la secrétaire d'état madame christelle
du gosse merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs sénateurs monsieur
le président alain milon je vous prie
d'excuser en effet l'absence de monsieur
ministre exactions un des comptes
publics ne peut être présent cet après
midi mais vous le savez et vous l'avez
relevé le gouvernement a adopté fin en
2018 des mesures fortes pour répondre
aux attentes des citoyens en matière
notamment de pouvoir d'achat de justice
sociale ces éléments et la révision des
perspectives de croissance nous
conduisent aujourd'hui en effet à
retarder le retour à l'équilibré mais
notre ambition reste la même l'objectif
du gouvernement en matière de
redressement des comptes sociaux et de
désendettement de la sécu sociale reste
entier le projet de loi de finance de
financement de la spéciale pour 2020
s'inscrit dans la perspective de
poursuivre l'effort engagé depuis 2018
de maîtrise des dépenses sociales comme
l'ensemble des dépenses publiques tout
en veillant à préserver et soutenir nos
six concitoyens modeste et fragile et
nous avons entendu en effet la demande
d'un système social plus juste une
question d'une justice d'une prendre
prendre en compte l'évolution des
familles le projet de loi de finances
propose de mieux prendre en compte les
parcours de vie de soutenir la petite
enfance et l'accompagnement des familles
monoparentales qui sont les plus
vulnérables
mais aussi de prendre en compte de
nouveaux risques sociaux de simplifier
l'accès au droit et de poursuivre la
lutte contre les déserts médicaux
mais j'y reviendrai dans quelques
instants vous avez là les axes de ce
futur budget que vous aurez à débattre
dans les prochaines semaines et
notamment au sein de votre commission
monsieur le président et vous savez que
les ministres ils sont très attachés
je vous remercie monsieur le président
1000 euros
merci madame la ministre je voudrais que
nous ayons tous en tête
cette déclaration de simone veil la
sécurité sociale c'est d'abord un
immense progrès social et le plus
puissant facteur de cohésion sociale qui
existe en france que nous avons le
devoir de préserver pour les générations
futures
je souhaite que cela soit toujours vrai
je ne suis pas sûr que cela soit le cas
ne serait ce que par la paire 6 à sion
sournoise du financement de la sécurité
sociale qui en est me semble-t-il la
preuve
ainsi d'ailleurs que le non respect de
la loi simone veil de 1994
la parole est à notre collègue christine
bonfanti-dossat pour le groupe l'est
républicain je devais la parole monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre chers
collègues
aujourd'hui les policiers sont dans la
rue suicide agression perte de sens de
leur mission
depuis vingt ans les gardiennes de la
paix n'avait pas crier aussi fort leur
rage rage à cause des violences qu'ils
subissent et qui restent impunis rage à
cause des heures supplémentaires qu'ils
donnent rage face à l'indifférence
générale lorsque l'on faut fonctionner
salies rage enfin quand ils se sentent
lâchés par les autorités monsieur le
ministre
ils ne sont pas les seuls les pompiers
les personnels des hôpitaux les
enseignants crient eux aussi leur
désespoir agressions violences verbales
et physiques menace peugeot s'ils sont
seuls pour affronter ces tensions
quotidiennes
enfin n'oublions pas les verts dont nous
avons tous vu cet été qu'il n'était plus
uniquement à porter d'engueulades comme
le dit notre président larcher mais
qu'ils sont désormais à portée de coûts
depuis des mois ces hommes et ces femmes
font face avec courage et détermination
faute d'un soutien sans faille pour oser
aux événements que le gouvernement ne
sait pas maîtriser mais la résistance
humaine a ses limites
faute de réponse faute d'une colite
politique sans concession vis-à-vis de
la violence nous assistons à une perte
d'autorité sans précédent le sentiment
d'abandon par la puissance publique
dobbin or monsieur le ministre
un état qui ne protège pas ses
serviteurs est un navire sans boussole
donc en perdition monsieur le ministre
quelles sont les mesures immédiates que
vous allez prendre pour protéger des
forces de l'ordre dans l'exercice de
leurs fonctions quand déciderez-vous à
sanctionner ceux qui appellent à la
violence et à la mort envers tous ses
serviteurs qui incarne pourtant
l'autorité de la république
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur christophe castaner ministre
l'intérieur monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs et dames madame la sénatrice
ou à raison la police souffre souffre
d'un abandon budgétaires je pense depuis
de trop longues années souffre d'un
désengagement massif du budget de l'état
et notamment a souffert fortement d'une
baisse de 13 mille cinq cents emplois
on peut pas aujourd'hui évoquer les
heures supplémentaires en en négligeant
la cause la cause c'est effectivement
une baisse massive des emplois au sein
de la police et de la gendarmerie
c'est effectivement une sur mobilisation
après les attentats de 2015 et c'est
aujourd'hui la nécessité de remettre
tout cela à niveau madame la sénatrice
aux termes du budget que je présenterai
donc quelques jours devant votre
assemblée le budget de la police
nationale aura augmenté en trois
exercices de plus de 1 milliard d'euros
dans le budget que je vous présenterai
dans quelques jours le budget de la
police augmentera de 5 3%
voilà madame la sénatrice des réponses
concrètes des réponses concrètes à la
fois sur les embauches avec un plan de
recrutement de dix mille emplois et 1398
policiers supplémentaires seront
recrutés dans le cadre du plf 2020 que
je vous présenterai et de la même façon
nous avons fait le choix avec les
organisations syndicales que nous
rencontrer avec lors que nous
rencontrons avec laurent nunès très
régulièrement d'améliorer les conditions
matérielles notamment des gardiens de la
paix est dégradée et ce sera en début
d'année prochaine dans le cadre d'une
réorganisation profonde aussi de notre
prise près de 130 euros mensuels
d'augmentation nette qu'ils connaîtront
voilà quelques réponses mais nous devons
aller au-delà nous devons équiper mieux
mieux investir aussi dans l'immobilier
300 millions d'euros seront consacrés
l'année prochaine dans le budget pour
rénover ou ferr ou construire des
comices mais c'est beaucoup plus mais ce
sénateur que ce que nous avons connu ces
quinze dernières années en moyenne
et donc très clairement il y à des
efforts significatifs qui sont faits
cela ne suffit pas et je crois comme
vous l'avez dit que nos forces de
sécurité ont besoin de respect et le
respect c'est celui que toute la
représentation nationale dans l'esprit
de votre question devant leur porte et
je vous remercie
la fin on est un autre collègue yves
daudigny
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
d'âme la ministre portent sur le déficit
de la sécurité sociale
il ya tout juste un an le gouvernement
annonce et je cite après 18 ans de
déficit la sécurité sociale dégagera un
excédent de 700 millions d'euros en 2019
nous y sommes le déficit régime général
fonds de solidarité vieillesse pour 2019
sera de 5 4 milliards d'euros et la
prévision pour 2020 est un déficit à
peine réduit à 5,1 milliards
y at il eu dérapage des dépenses depuis
janvier non le projet 2020 et intègre
utile de crédit exceptionnelles pour
résoudre la crise de l'hôpital avec
l'ondam à plus de 23%
couplé à 4 milliards d'économies ce
n'est pas le cas il y a un an encore le
gouvernement se préparait à transférer
les excédents attendu de la sécurité
sociale vers le budget de l'état fait
pillage diront certains sans précédent
aujourd'hui de nouveau vous déroger à la
loi veil de 1994
en refusant de compenser par le budget
de l'état
les conséquences de vos propres choix
fiscaux votre ma question madame la
ministre
quelle est la conception quelle est la
philosophie des gouvernements en matière
de sécurité sociale pour le 21e siècle
vous répondre la parole est à madame la
secrétaire d'état blague du golfe
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur le projet
de loi de finance de financement de la
sécu social pour 2020 poursuit comme je
viens de le dire la transformation de
notre système de protection sociale pour
un système social plus juste et prolonge
notre politique qui consiste à augmenter
le pouvoir d'achat des français ce plfss
renforce également la prise en compte
des nouveaux risques sociaux qui pèsent
sur les français dans la couverture est
l'essence même de la sécurité sociale
permettez moi de vous donner quelques
exemples de ces belles mesures qu'il ya
dans ce projet de loi de financement de
la sculpture sociale un accompagnement
des familles monoparentales en offrant
aux parents séparés un dispositif de
sécurisation du versement des pensions
alimentaires c'est plus 40 millions dès
2020 la création d'un parcours
d'accompagnement après la maladie pour
les patients atteints d'un cancer
la création d'un fonds d'indemnisation
pour les victimes de maladies
professionnelles liées aux pesticides
cher à votre groupe parlementaire
l'ouverture dès 2020 d'un congé
indemniser indemnisés pour les proches
aidants mesure initialement porté au
sénat par jos dings inez et olivier
henno
nous entendons la demande d'un système
social plus juste sans remettre en cause
les objectifs du gouvernement en matière
de redressement des comptes sociaux
lors des débats parlementaires vous
verrez monsieur le sénateur que le
projet de loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale pour 2020 poursuit l'effort
important engagé depuis 2018 de maîtrise
des dépenses sociales comme l'ensemble
des dépenses publiques comme juin de
dire à l'instant tout en veillant à
préserver et soutenir les citoyens les
plus fragiles merci monsieur dowd signé
maintenant la ministre je vous ai écouté
avec attention
nous devons actes et notre profond
désaccord de fond parce que nous sommes
arc bouté sur la défense non pas d'un
monde ancien nous ne sommes plus en 1945
mais sur la défense de valeurs la
solidarité la justice dont découlent
l'autonomie de la sécurité sociale
comment ne pas percevoir madame la
ministre dans l'orchestration de ce
déficit politique
les justifications demain à de nouveaux
coups portés à notre protection sociale
la civilité sociale est une assurance
solidaire de toute la société
elle ne saurait en aucun cas se réduire
à une chambre de compensation des
politiques de l'état
je vous remercie merci sa parole et à
notre collègue jean françois husson pour
le groupe l'est républicain
quatre questions au gouvernement
démontre la gravité la situation à la
suite de l' incendie de plus de 5000
tonnes de produits chimiques dans
l'usiné brizola rouen il convient de
prendre la pleine mesure des
conséquences sanitaires et des deals
inquiétudes écologiques et économiques
qui expriment les populations les
professionnels intervenus sur le site
des réponses claires elles sans
ambiguïté et qui relève de l'état se
sont par trop fait attendre
une communication brouillonne
inappropriée et inadaptée à donner le
sentiment d'une crise très mal gérée par
les pouvoirs publics
sonic ce qui n'a fait qu'accroître le
malaise trop de questions restent sans
réponse aussi je vous demande madame la
ministre de faire la lumière sur
plusieurs zones d'ombré les leçons de
l'incident survenu en 2013 on et elles
ont elles été tirées et si oui selon
quel plan d'action les réglementation
seveso ont elles été intégralement
respectés et si oui
sont-elles à la hauteur des défis
sanitaires pourquoi avoir attendu cinq
longues journées pour publier la liste
des produits chimiques présents sur le
site de lubrizol
cette liste est elle d'ailleurs complète
enfin au delà des premiers résultats de
l'ineris d'autres analyses sont en cours
vous engagez vous allez rendre tout est
intégralement publics
pour vous répondre monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur les sénateurs us ont je
voudrais vous redire l'extrême
mobilisation des services de secours et
des services de l'état pour faire face à
cette catastrophe industrielle
je voudrais à nouveau rendre hommage aux
pompiers et aux services qui ont été
mobilisés dès le début de l' incendie
qui ont permis de maîtriser cet incendie
d'éviter tout sur accident dans un
contexte qui était pourtant très
compliqué je peux vous assurer que les
services de l'état sur le terrain ont
également été mobilisés pour réaliser ou
faire réaliser par l'exploitant comme
lui impose la loi
de nombreux prélèvements dans l'air dans
l'eau dans les sols sur les végétaux
dès que les résultats de ces analyses
sont connus ils sont rendus publics ils
ont été successivement vendredi samedi
ils continueront à l'être sur le site de
la préfecture sur les leçons de 2013 je
peux vous confirmer qu'en effet c'est le
son bien été tiré et notamment sur le
fait que à l'époque les services de
secours les services de l'état ne
disposait pas d'une capacité à faire
réaliser des prélèvements et des
analyses avec autant de réactivité et je
pense que si nous avons pu disposer de
ces informations
aussi rapidement c'est bien parce que
nous en avons tiré les conséquences de
l'incident 2013 alors forcément comme
dans tout accident dans une catastrophe
telle que celle que nous avons connue à
rouen nous aurons encore à progresser
nous auront à examiner notamment
pourquoi cet incendie s'est déclaré dans
un site qui est pourtant très surveillé
trente neuf inspections ont été
réalisées depuis 2000 13 10 au cours des
deux dernières années
mais forcément cet incendie n'aurait pas
dû se produire et donc nous aurons est
certainement votre commission denquête
nous éclairera également à en tirer les
conséquences je remercie merci
madame la ministre la parole publique
qu'elles proviennent en l'occurrence de
l'état ou de l'exploitant a été
défaillante dans ce cas depuis le départ
entretenir le flou par la cacophonie les
déclarations officielles contradictoires
n'est pas acceptable et symbolise une
crise ingérable face au discrédit de la
parole publique
notez-bien en effet madame la ministre
quand cinq jours pas moins de cinq
ministres dont vous-même et le premier
ministre sont venus sur place pour y
tenir cinq discours différent accentuant
le trouble dans l'opinion
enfin je veux le dire ici les
préoccupations écologiques et
environnementales parce qu'elles sont
aujourd'hui dans la conscience des
français méritent comme en partage les
défis et les enjeux en toute
transparence
nous avons l état au premier chef un
devoir de vérité chacun le constatera il
reste beaucoup à faire à part le cas de
notre collègue olivier cigolotti pour le
groupe de l'union centriste de la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur en
charge de la sécurité civile monsieur le
ministre monsieur le premier ministre a
rendu un hommage bien légitime aux
qualités à la détermination de nos
sapeurs pompiers mais nos sapeurs
pompiers volontaires et professionnels
sont à bout de souffle
ces hommes et ces femmes dont
l'engagement au service de nos
concitoyens force le respect sont sur
tous les fronts et doivent faire face à
une sur sollicitation en intervenant
parfois est de plus en plus souvent pour
des missions non urgentes
ces soldats du feu sont devenus dans nos
territoires des soldats de la santé à
force de pallier aux lacunes de notre
système de santé
monsieur le ministre à l'occasion du
congrès de la fédération nationale à
vannes il ya quelques jours vous le
rappeliez vous même il y entre les
français et les sapeurs-pompiers une
relation spéciale mais ces derniers n'en
peuvent plus et notre modèle de sécurité
civile est en danger ils n'en peuvent
plus de pallier à toutes les
sollicitations et de répondre à tous les
défis désertification médicale
réchauffement climatique réorganisation
et disparition des services publics dans
les territoires ruraux
toutes ces évolutions concours à une
situation malheureusement similaire à
celle des urgences beaucoup de questions
sont posées mais peu de réponses sont
apportées
je ne citerai que quelques points la
directive européenne sur le temps de
travail pas d'échéance pas d'information
nos volontaires demeure dans
l'expectative et s'inquiète la
déclinaison des propositions de nature
législative du rapport de la mission
volontariat ainsi que de nouvelles
mesures de lutte contre les agressions
pour lesquels le sénat fera
prochainement des propositions pas de
suite à ce jour rationalisation du
transport sanitaire héliporté toujours
rien enfin monsieur le ministre le
président de la république appelait de
ses voeux en octobre 2010 est la mise en
oeuvre d'un seul numéro d'appel
d'urgence le 112 mise en oeuvre sans une
régulation médicale devenue inopérante
deux ans après la france est encore à la
traîne alors que tous les autres pays
européens ont depuis longtemps intégré
cette nécessité
monsieur le ministre ma question est
claire j'espère que votre réponse ce
sera tout autant votre gouvernement
entente il véritablement mettre en
oeuvre une politique de sécurité civile
ambitieuse est capable de faire face aux
défis sociétaux et environnementaux à
venir pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur le
questionnaire merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs c'est un
terme monsieur le sénateur vous avez
raison il ya un malaise palpable réel
chez nos sapeurs pompiers compte tenu
d'un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements cumulée et notamment
celui que vous évoquez qui est la
sur-sollicitation liées aux
interventions dans le cadre du service
du jour aux soa personnes 84% 84 % de
leur activité qui est mobilisé dans ce
cadre là avec trop souvent pas pour
l'essentiel des cas mais trop souvent le
sentiment qu'ils sont appelés pour des
missions qui ne relèvent pas de leur
savoir faire et de leur formation ils
ont raison en cela sa raison pour
laquelle avec la ministre de la santé
nous travaillons d'ici la fin de l'année
à faire des propositions concrètes pour
aller vers ces plateformes communes de
gestion des appels et je ne prononce pas
volontairement de numéro de téléphone
pour ne fâcher personne
mais des plates formes communes qui nous
permettent d'avancer dans certains
départements on nous a montré l'exemple
je pense à l'autre
je pense à la loire qui a fusionné leurs
plateformes pour avancer dans le même
sens et pour avoir une cohérence
d'ensemble dans la gestion des appels ou
matériaux j'ai aussi sur des mesures
prises à court terme et elles sont
nécessaires et lors du congrès de vannes
j'ai pu en évoquer quelques unes sur
lequel nous sommes convenus avec la
ministre de la santé d'avancé la
création par exemple de coordinateur
ambulanciers pour limiter les carence
d'ambulance qui sont assurées
aujourd'hui par les sapeurs pompiers
l'amélioration de la coordination entre
les ars et les dix avec des emplois
dédiés pour ce sujet là et des missions
confiées en particulier aux directeurs
des ars pour fluidifier ce système là le
fait de limiter le temps d'attenté dans
les urgences
autant de sujets qui sont
particulièrement importants mais
interrogé sur nombreux sujets je
voudrais vous dire que sur l'art et
marssac et les conséquences qui
d'ailleurs oppose sapeurs pompiers
professionnels et sapeurs pompiers
volontaires
il ne faut pas négliger cette
dimension-là sur les marsac j'ai pris un
double engagement mais j'ai pris surtout
l'engagement de faire en sorte qu' il
n'y ait pas de conséquences négatives
sur notre modèle du volontariat français
et il n'y aura pas de conséquences
négatives
enfin une revendication importante est
porté sur la grille salariale et sur la
prime aux feux mais vous comprenez que
je réunirai le comité des financeurs le
10 octobre et je ne souhaite pas décidé
d'engager des dépenses qui relève des
départements et des mairies sans
l'accord des départements et des mérites
jour merci merci la parole est
maintenant à jean paul emorine pour le
groupe l'est républicain le sénateur
judd président monsieur le premier
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation monsieur le ministre il y
avait après midi le débat en séance a
porté sur la place déclinante de notre
agriculture dans les marchés
internationaux
aujourd'hui après une forte des prises
qui n'est pas d'aujourd'hui
notre agriculture n'occupe plus que 50%
de la superficie de notre territoire
depuis plus de trois ans une majorité de
nos agriculteurs désespère leurs revenus
et de plus en plus bas voire quelquefois
inexistant avec des moyennes de revenus
de 500 euros par mois ce qui sont la
règle
la loi galim présenter hâtivement comme
une solution n'est qu'une déception
supplémentaire pour le monde agricole
le sénat l'avait prédit et toutes ces
propositions avaient été rejetées la
sécheresse qui sévit dans certaines
régions ne fait qu'aggraver la situation
les jeunes sont toujours plus endettés
les moins jeunes sont gagnés par le
désespoir
malgré un engagement de passion et
personnels de tous les jours certains
d'entre eux confrontés une immense
détresse médecins leur existence et
plongent leurs familles dans le deuil
quel drame humain que dirait ton d'une
catastrophe qui chaque année ferait plus
de 300 victimes
monsieur le ministre quelles
dispositions comptez vous prendre pour
enrayer cette terrible hémorragie
quelles mesures structurelles quelles
mesures conjoncturelles l'agriculture
at-elle encore pour le gouvernement un
avenir dans notre pays
pour vous rendre la parole est aux
militants sortent des relations avec le
parlement marqué tôt le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur emorine
je vais d'abord excusé le ministre de
l'agriculture qui est retenue en ce
moment au sommet de l'élevage à cournon
en auvergne vous l'avez rappelé la
profession agricole est malheureusement
très touché par le drame du suicide
elle met en avant et mettant en exergue
la crise de toute une profession je vois
d'abord m pour commencer ma répond pour
répondre à particulier sur le sujet de
l'élevage est un département
vous êtes un élu d'un département pour
lequel élevage compte beaucoup en
particulier sur deux filières la filière
lait et viande sur la filière lait la
conjoncture malgré tout s'améliore même
si on ne peut pas s'en satisfaire le
prix du lait payé elle est en hausse de
plus de 5% depuis le début de l'année ce
n'est pas suffisant c'est une première
étape mais à la fois la conjoncture
mondiale et aux perspectives d'export et
c'est les premiers effets que l'on peut
percevoir de la loi et galim sur cette
filière les outils sont maintenant
totalement en place depuis le 1er avril
et c'est à la profession de s'en saisir
et de les faire vivre pour que là aussi
on améliore le revenu des agriculteurs
nous sommes par ailleurs vigilant sur
deux nouveaux points d'inquiétude la
perspective du breakbeat dur ou le
rétablissement des droits doit par les
états unis sur la filière viande bovine
la conjoncture actuelle est très
difficile et vous avez réservé raison
accentuée par la crise de la sécheresse
jeu rappelait la semaine dernière les
mesures qui avaient été prises soit au
niveau européen sur l'avancement des
primes pac soit les dégrèvements ceux
prévus dans ces cas-là au titre
de la msa ou de la taxe sur le foncier
non bâti mais dans ce contexte la mise
en oeuvre des orientations des plantes
filière est plus que jamais nécessaire
et je veux dire un mode voudrais vous
dire un mot de l'expert l'export pardon
et pour ne citer qu'un exemple nous
pouvons faire mieux aujourd'hui que les
200 tonnes actuellement exporté vers la
chine tant ce marché est important et
pauvres des perspectives d'avenir est là
aussi il faudra que nous accompagnons la
fille à jour enfin salué le travail qui
est réalisé par l'interprofession pour
trouver des solutions et trouver un coût
de production qui permettent de mieux
tenir compte de la rémunération des
éleveurs au fond gouvernement est
conscient de tout cela il agit mais au
delà du volet économique on voit bien
que ce n'est pas la même la seule
réponse au moins six sites tous les deux
jours c'est toujours un drame intime
vous l'avez rappelé un drame familial un
drame locales et au fond c'est la dram
de toute une nation par aof car au delà
des difficultés économiques et
conjoncturelles c'est une crise du sens
et nous devons les accompagner
nous devons les défendre nous devons les
protéger nous voulons devons leur dire
ce que l'on nous leur devons et nous
devons faire attention aux mots et je
sais que nous partageons monsieur le
sénateur et mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs la nécessité de trouver les
mots aux agriculteurs pour arrêter de
faire ce qu'on voit trop souvent parfois
dans les médias de les vilipender et de
les critiquer merci monsieur sénateur
emorine
merci monsieur le ministre je pense que
votre réponse ne va pas satisfaire
l'ensemble du monde agricole simplement
prendre à témoin mes collègues nous
sommes pour une la grande majorité des
représentants des territoires et des
terroirs
c'est ce que nous avons à défendre ses
50% de l'espace de notre pays
ce sont des productions de qualité ce
sont des hommes et des femmes qui
travaillent 7 jours sur 7
presque nous vous demandons surtout
c'est de prendre des décisions
nécessaires rapidement pour pouvoir les
maintenir sur le territoire
merci merci la parole notre collègue
bernard but pour le groupe de la
république en marche
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues la question s'adresse à la
secrétaire d'état auprès de la ministre
des solidarités de la santé madame dans
cette assemblée
au mois de juin dernier dans le cadre de
l'examen de la loi relative à
l'organisation et à la transformation du
système de santé
nous débattions discussion et adoption
l'obligation pour les étudiants de
troisième cycle de médecine générale et
d'autres spécialités d'effectuer leurs
dernières années en pratique ambulatoire
en autonomie dans les zones
caractérisées comme sous dotées la
plupart d'entre nous savons combien les
élus de territoires ruraux mais aussi
dans certaines villes souffrent de la
carence de médecins pour répandre
problématiques de santé de leurs
administrés je suis sûr par exemple que
dans cette assemblée
nous avons les uns et les autres étaient
interrogés par nos concitoyens sur leurs
difficultés à trouver un médecin
traitant
cette mesure madame la ministre est donc
une bonne mesure très concrète
elle a été saluée par les associations
d'élus car c'est une proposition
réaliste et pragmatique
non seulement parce qu'elle instaure
avec ce stage la présence d'un terne
enfin une formation dans des secteurs
présentant une offre de soins
insuffisante mais aussi pour faciliter
et installer l'installation de ces
jeunes praticiens dans nos territoires
c'est aussi une mesure d'urgence madame
la ministre
et je sais que le mesurer pleinement
dans le plan quand jean dard ural
présentée par monsieur le premier
ministre le 23 septembre dernier
l'engagement est pris de recruter 600
médecins salariés ou à exercice mixte
ville hôpital dans les déserts médicaux
c'est pourquoi ma question est simple
comment comptez-vous emploi vous
employez pour appliquer très rapidement
ces mesures et de quelle façon
pensez vous envisagez d'y associer les
maires pour de la parole est à mme anne
krystel du boss de même la ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur à bernières lui permettra en
effet de préciser que le gouvernement
entend les attentes des élus des
citoyens soient nombreux territoires
concernant l'inquiétude est légitime qui
accompagnent les questions de l'accès
aux soins
la ministre des solidarités de la santé
s'était attaqué à ces préoccupations dès
son arrivée au ministère et c'est pour
ça que depuis 2017
nous avons apporté un certain nombre de
réponses avec notamment le développement
des maisons de santé dont le nombre a
augmenté de 37 % en deux ans et qui sont
situées essentiellement dans un milieu
rural près de 80% en milieu rural
nous avons également augmenté les aides
aux médecins qui s'installent dans les
zones sous denses pour libérer du temps
médical nous développons tous les outils
et la coopération entre les
professionnels les délégations des
tâches le développement et le
déploiement du numérique
d'autres solutions sont en cours de mise
en oeuvre je pense aussi aux hôpitaux de
proximité qui compléteront l'offre de
soins mais aussi aux assistants médicaux
qui seront près de 4000 d'ici 2022 nous
accélérons également le déploiement de
400 médecins généralistes partagé entre
la médecine de ville et l'hôpital et 200
dans les zones les plus modestes
concernant le développement des stages
la mesure adoptée à l'initiative du
sénat dans la loi santé c'est une
première réponse efficace et pragmatique
à l'urgence territoriale nous inscrivons
dans le calendrier que vous avez adopté
nous souhaitons système à systématiser
le stage ambulatoire en soins en
autonomie supervisée pour les étudiants
en dernière année d'internât à compter
de 2021 les contours sur définies par un
décret qui pourra notamment ouvrir la
possible et d'une supervision à distance
afin de laisser davantage de souplesse
dans l'organisation des terrains de
stage permettez moi également de vous
indiquer qu'un groupe de travail sera
mis en place dans les prochaines
semaines pour accélérer la dynamique
pour faire découvrir l'exercice en zones
sous denses et je retiens votre
proposition ne pouvoir y faire
participer les élus des collectivités
locales je vous remercie
chez lui merci vadam la musique pour ces
précisions
merci la parole est à notre collègue
jacky d'euromédis pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le ministre ce gouvernement
aime-t-il les français de l'étranger
vous me permettrez d'en douter en
matière fiscale entre autres des
centaines de compatriotes relayés par
leurs élus m'interpelle sur leurs
inquiétudes quant à l'augmentation
faramineuse de leurs impôts vous êtes à
l'origine de ce qu'ils décrivent comme
une catastrophe fiscale j'ai deux
questions premièrement les français de
l'étranger sont soumis aux prélèvements
sociaux csg crds et prélèvements de
solidarité soit 17,1 pour cent alors
qu'il ne bénéficie d'aucune prestation
sociale en france
à ceci s'ajoute une discrimination entre
les français résidant dans lieux et ceux
résidant hors heu
ceux qui résident dans lieu en raison de
votre refus de supprimer ces
prélèvements ont saisi la cour de
justice de l'ue eux et ils ont gagné
ils sont donc exemptés vous avez refusé
d'appliquer la même règle à ceux qui
résident hors heu
il continue donc à être soumis à ce
prélèvement de 17,20 % pourquoi cette
double injustice
deuxièmement compte tenu compte
concernant la retenue à la source
vous avez augmenté le taux minimum de 20
à 30 % auxquels il faut ajouter pour les
résidents auront eu le prénom le
prélèvements csg crds et le prélèvement
de solidarité soit 17,1 pour cent pour
les revenus inférieurs à 27 8 519 euros
la retenue à la source et de 27 5% pour
les résidents d'ems lieux et de 37,5 %
pour ceux résidant hors yeux pour ceux
dont les revenus sont supérieurs à 27
milles 519 euros soit 2300 euros par
mois la retenue à la source sera de 37,5
pour cent pour les résidents d'ems lieux
et de 47,20 % pour ceux résidant hors
ue27
or application d'un taux moyen s'il
accepte de déclarer leurs revenus
mondiaux
pourquoi cet autre discrimination pour
répondre monsieur olivier du club
secrétaire d'état produisent de l'action
des comptes publics je ministre merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice vous avez utilisé madame la
sénatrice des mots que je trouve un peu
dur pour qualifier la fiscalité des
français non résidents
il faut rappeler que dans le cadre de la
loi de finances pour 2010 9
nous avons procédé à une réforme de la
fiscalité des non résidents sur la base
des préconisations du rapport la députée
de madame j'ai noté nous avons ainsi
remplacer la retenue à la source
dérogatoires qui était appliqué à
certains des revenus de source française
comme les traitements salaires et
pensions par une retenue à la source de
droit commun déjà applicables aux mêmes
appliqua pardon même revenu au delà d'un
certain seuil de 43000 euros est déjà
applicable aussi au premier euro
d'autres catégories de revenus ce qui
était source de complexité et
d'incompréhension et la seule
formulation vient illustrer par ailleurs
nous avons et vous l'avez rappelé fait
le choix d'un taux minimum d'imposition
pour mettre en oeuvre ce prélèvement à
la source pour les français de
l'étranger
est ce que cette réforme a eu des
conclusions des conséquences extrêmement
importante et dans quel sens les soldes
les choses sont à relativiser par
rapport à votre propos à des certains
des craintes que vous relayez
premièrement l'application du droit
commun en lieu et place de la route du
libératoire peut selon les cas sur rv
est révélée par don plus ou moins
avantageuses en fonction notamment de la
composition du foyer
la part des revenus de source française
ou la nature des revenus
ensuite les contribuables non résidents
ont toujours la possibilité comme
auparavant d'opter pour l'heure un peu
pour l'imposition de leurs revenus au
taux moyen plutôt que la retenue à la
source et cette imposition au taux moyen
consiste à appliquer aux revenus de
source française
le taux qui relèverait du barème de
lierre progressif donc applique à
l'ensemble des revenus mondiaux
il faut aussi ajouter que la réforme
s'est accompagnée de nouveaux avantages
pour les non résidents avec notamment la
déduction des pensions alimentaires pour
le calcul du taux moyen ou encore
l'allongement de cinq à dix ans du délai
d'exonération des plus-values
immobilières et enfin j'ajoute madame la
sénatrice que ce que vous avez évoqué la
jurisprudence dite de rites hertz en
matière de csg a effectivement été
inscrite dans le droit français par loi
de finances pour 2010 9
elle concerne les non résidents dans
l'espace communautaire et pas les autres
ce gouvernement a fait le choix de
rendre effective alors quelle date et
depuis 2015 il y as certainement si
monsieur le président me permets
quelques améliorations aux modifications
à apporter le gouvernement y travaille
pour que dans le cadre du projet de loi
finances de 2020 nous puissions apporter
les améliorations nécessaires
merci dernière question jours cette
journée est un peu particulière dans le
temps je le dis à mes collègues je vous
remercie d'être là
notre collègue michel meunier pour le
groupe socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adressait à
madame la ministre du travail
unedic vient d'analyser les deux décret
réformant l'assurance chômage pris par
votre gouvernement et le verdict est
sans appel
les perdants seront nombreux un million
trois cent mille personnes à la
recherche d'un emploi verront leurs
allocations chômage baisser quatre
chômeurs sur dix plus de 200000
travailleuses et travailleurs sans
emploi seront privés d'indemnités 10%
des personnes concernées en moyenne
l'unedic estime que cette baisse des
allocations sera de 10 9%
c'est à un mouvement de précarisation
massif madame la présidente qu'il faut
s'attendre si vous persistez à appliquer
dès le 1er novembre
les nouvelles règles les associations de
personnes précaires et les centrales
syndicales présentes déjà que les
premiers touchés seront les plus jeunes
qui enchaîne les contrats courts et des
faibles salaires les plus fragiles cette
perspective est dramatique
madame la ministre mais le pire est que
votre vision est très conservatrice
parce que vous prétendez que la réforme
aura pour conséquence d'inciter les
chômeurs à reprendre une activité votre
logique dissimule mal l'ambition
d'économie budgétaire au détriment de
celles et ceux qui ont pourtant cotisé
ma question est simple qu'avez vous
prévu pour accompagner ces personnes qui
risquent de se retourner vers pôle
emploi les agents en effet
une montées d'agressivité de colère et
la parlementaire que je suis de
loire-atlantique sait jusqu'où ces actes
peuvent mener quelle mesure donc de
prévention pôle emploi va-t-il proposer
à ses agents pour vous répondre la
parole est à madame la secrétaire d'état
auprès du royaume uni portant parole
d'abc bundle merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice je vous prie d'abord
d'excuser l'absence de muriel pénicaud
la ministre du travail qui ne pouvaient
être des nôtres aujourd'hui ce que je
crois qu'il est utile de se poser comme
question au fond c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons souhaité mener cette
réforme de l'assurance chômage
je veux vous rappeler trois chiffres
trois chiffres qui pour moi sont
extrêmement importants le premier c'est
que la france est un pays où 87 % des
embauches sont réalisés en cdi parmi ces
embauches en cdd pardon parmi ces
embauches en cdd 70 % correspondent à
des contrats de moins d'un mois
et parmi ces contrats de moins d'un mois
85 % correspondent à des ré embauche
cette réalité madame la sénatrice c'est
la réalité de la précarité des
travailleurs et des travailleuses
française cette réalité
ce gouvernement ne peut pas l'accepter
dans le même temps que voyons nous on
voit que un chômeur sur cinq peut
percevoir plus au chômage qu'en
travaillant dans le même moment
c'est une réalité dans le même moment
que voyons nous nous voyons que certains
secteurs économiques use et abuse des
contrats courts ce qui contribue à
précariser toujours davantage les
travailleurs
quel est donc au fond pour refuser cette
précarité la réforme que nous avons
proposé d'abord nous avons voulu en
terminer avec le recours abusif aux
contrats courts c'est la mise en place
du bonus malus qui permet de modifier la
cotisation chômage de l'employeur en
fonction de son comportement
nous avons également souhaité inciter
davantage à la reprise du travail en ne
changeant pas le capital d'indemnités
auxquelles les chômeurs ont droit nous
leurrer parties sont simplement de
manière différente dans le temps de
manière à ce que de plus rapidement
possible la personne qui est en
recherche d'emploi soient incités à
revenir à l'emploi est la dernière chose
madame la sénatrice c'est que nous
renforçons
considérablement je dis bien
considérablement l'accompagnement des
personnes en situation de chômage c'est
la raison pour laquelle la ministre en
charge du travail à annoncer des
embauches en nombre important auprès de
pôle emploi et je crois que nous avons
là une réforme qui nous permettra très
largement de lutter contre la précarité
au travail tue vous remercie madame
meunier vous avez huit secondes
allez-y sur le président 8 secondes
c'est trop devant tant de caricatures il
d'idées reçues je suis sans voix je
voudrais mes chers collègues à bord
avant de lever notre séance
temporairement salué l'arrivée de parmi
nous de pascal martin sénateur de
seine-maritime
qu'ils soient ici le bienvenu il vient
remplacer parce qu'il en a décidé ainsi
notre doyen charles revêt qui a beaucoup
plus vrai ici dans cette assemblée qui
apportait aussi beaucoup de valeurs
auxquelles il était attaché et auxquels
je tiens à exprimer au nom de cela tout
entier à la fois notre gratitude et à
vous souhaitez chers collègues le
meilleur mandats possibles au sénat
c'est aussi à l'or lors de ces questions
au gouvernement il a notamment été
question de l' incendie de lusine
lubrizol de rouen à droite comme à
gauche les sénateurs sont inquiets et ne
trouve pas la réponse du gouvernement à
la hauteur des enjeux sanitaires et
environnementaux alors le sénateur
socialiste didier marie a réclamé que
l'état de catastrophe technologique soit
déclarée comme ce fut le cas à l' usine
azf ce cas écarté le gouvernement donc
hier à l'assemblée
catherine morin desailly sénatrice
centriste a quant à elle bien insisté
sur la nécessité de d'un suivi
épidémiologique strict alors que doivent
edouard philippe
le premier ministre a dit oui ainsi qu'à
un suivi médical à court et long termes
alors il faut rappeler que les habitants
à proximité de l'usiné et même au delà
se plaignent de maux de tête de nausées
de vomissements et ce depuis le début de
l'incident depuis la colle incendie a eu
lieu alors enfin le sénateur et l'ère
jean françois husson déplore une
communication brouillonne voire même une
cacophonie avec pas moins de cinq
ministres qui se sont succédé sur les
lieux donc de l' incendie et qui ont
obtenu 1,5 discours différent
alors ce qu'on peut dire c'est que cet
après midi donc lors de ces questions au
gouvernement la communication du
gouvernement était bien rodé c'est à
dire qu'une fois encore
le edouard philippe et elisabeth bornes
on dit que la transparence serait totale
que les informations seront données au
fur et à mesure que les analyses seront
rendus et ils ont renvoyé la balle en
quelque sorte à l'industriel qui sera
mis face à ses responsabilités
et voilà ce que je peux vous dire donc
pour ces questions au gouvernement pour
l'instant merci merci beaucoup à l'iss
pour toutes ces explications et on va
continuer à débriefer cette séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement en
plateau avec mes invités et sophie calle
polion bonjour vous êtes sénatrice
génération ici au groupe socialiste du
val-de-marne membre de la commission des
finances également ici en plateau didier
rambaud bonjour je sénateurs la
république en marge de l'isère également
avec nous grégoire milo bonjour vous
êtes président de l' agence de conseil
en communication publique état d'esprit
stratis et enfin nous avons également le
plaisir d'avoir un plateau jean françois
husson bonjour sénateurs l air de
meurthe-et-moselle vous avez tout à
l'heure interpellé vous même le
gouvernement sur sa gestion de
l'incendié de lusine libre izod arrow
vous n'étiez pas le seul 1 il ya eu pas
moins de quatre questions sur ce sujet
on écoute d'abord et dans les
explications qu'à donner tout à l'heure
edouard philippe le premier ministre
vous avez reconnu la nécessité d'un
suivi médical de long terme il faut
aussi un suivi épidémiologique strictes
qui doit s'appliquer à ceux qui sont
intervenus sur le sinistre ainsi qu'à
toute la population touchée d'une
manière ou d'une autre
si comme vous le dites l'état de
catastrophe technologique n'est pas
envisagée quel est alors votre solution
pour indemniser les victimes
dans le cas présent le dispositif tel
qu'il a été conçu les critères qui ont
été posées par la loi même ne semble pas
en première analyse adapté à ce que nous
vivons pas complètement adaptée
dans tous les cas je veillerai à ce que
les mesures prises pour l'indemnisation
immédiate des agriculteurs qui voient
leur production en vertu du principe de
précaution
non commercialisé
les riverains l'ensemble de ceux qui
subissent un préjudice ou un dommage je
veillerai à ce que rien ne vienne
exonérer la responsabilité de
l'industriel que comme pour la
transparence le gouvernement et l'état
mettra tout en oeuvre pour dire pour
mesurer et pour faire connaître
l'ensemble des causes et des
conséquences de cet incendie de cette
catastrophe industrielle
jean françois husson comment est ce que
vous avez jugé la réponse
j'allais dire la réponse ne sont les
réponses d'edouard philippe et du
gouvernement dans son ensemble à ce que
vous ont rassuré non pas complètement
d'abord alors il ya une longue réponse
j'espère qu'elle n'a pas été alors elles
étaient étayé ça c'est plutôt
intéressant
j'espère qu'elle n'a pas été une forme
d' écran de fumée pour masquer les
insuffisances les carences des cinq
premiers jours je redis simplement que
pendant cinq jours cinq ministres sont
succédé pour tenir des discours et des
positions différentes c'est un vrai
sujet
quelle est la vraie question aujourd'hui
c'est comment à la survenance de l'
incendie
quelles sont les méthodes pour assurer
la transparence la communication à la
fois proactive et pour rassurer les
populations et aujourd'hui heureusement
parce qu'il faut savoir que ce site avec
les associations agréées de surveillance
de la qualité de l'air ont mis en place
une force d'intervention rapide il
n'empêche vous allez voir dans quelques
jours vous allez voir la métropole de
roue en délibéré au côté de l'état pour
se payer enfin les moyens qui étaient
demandés par les territoires c'était
plus de 400000 euros
vous allez voir que ça arrive c'est
quand même dommage de devoir attendre un
signe d'une pareille ampleur sergent
pour laquelle le sujet de l'écologie le
sujet des catastrophes industrielles est
un sujet majeur qu'il faut prendre à
bras le corps alors sophie calle paulhan
comment est ce que vous même vous juger
la gestion de cette crise par le
gouvernement a noté le mea culpa
d'edouard philippe sur la qualité de
l'information qui n'a pas toujours été
au rendez vous il est même avoué dans sa
longue réponse notamment début de séance
ans
je crois que effectivement peut que
reconnaître le fait que la communication
du gouvernement a été plus que plein de
cafouillis c'est grave c'est grave parce
que les habitantes et les habitants de
rouen attendait de l'état qu'il les
protège et qui les informent moi ce qui
m'interpelle aussi c'est vis-à-vis de ce
goût c'est le rapport cas ce
gouvernement avec les problèmes
environnementaux notamment les problèmes
je dirais de gestion des risques et de
et de prévention des risques
quand on voit les décisions qui ont été
prises et notamment de remises en
question de d'un certain nombre d'études
environnementales qui était préalable à
certaines décisions auparavant et ça
dans la loi et être confiance a été
remis en cause
et d'ailleurs il est visiblement
question du fait que ces dispositions
étaient mises en oeuvre par le préfet et
donc ça alléger les à alléger les
contrôles va alléger les études d'impact
ça allait j'ai donc les mesures de
prévention qui aurait dû mettre être
être mis en place précisément dans ce
cas quand je vois qu'à paris où on
entend parler d'un rapport sur la
question du plan qui a été mis sous le
coude par le gouvernement moi je je je
m'interroge très fortement sur la façon
dont ce gouvernement
un de préserver la santé des français en
cas de risque et de pollution
environnementale
didier rambaud votre mage it bag
majorité attaqué à vous entendez sophie
calle polian vous n'êtes pas sensible
aux questions environnementales qu'est
ce que vous lui répondez à votre avis
que vous pensez que je ne suis pas
sensible donc j'éviterai à travers ce ce
problème cette catastrophe qui arrive de
voir polimiquer war même de caricaturer
dois dire qu'on est insensible aux
questions environnementales et 8 je
préfère la proche qui a eu mon collègue
jean françois husson cesser de regarder
à partir de cet événement comment on
peut s'améliorer
visiblement c'est clair en matière de
communication de transparence je pense
qu'il ya besoin de trouver à un nouveau
protocole et en plus on est dans une
société de plus en plus exigeante
les réseaux sociaux etc je suis sûr que
cette catastrophe l'az se serait déroulé
y avait un tendre il n'y aurait pas eu
les mêmes réactions bon c'est comme ça
bon il ya deux commissions d enquête
parlementaire qui vont s'installer
ils vont faire ces informations du côté
de l'assemblée
donc c'est clair que tous beaucoup
d'auditions tout doit se faire dans la
transparence sûrement derrière des
propositions et puis aussi
j'attire l'attention derrière ça va
sûrement entraîner de nouvelles normes
ça va générer de nouvelles normes
voilà une société où on se plaint un qui
a trop d'ordre est hélas pas des cas un
tel événement et bien ça va générer de
la production législative
supplémentaires et il va falloir voilà
on tirait en tirer des conséquences ça
pose une question pour tous les
territoires c est ce que nous sommes
suffisamment armée pour gérer les sites
seveso quelques quel que soit le
problème en tout cas dans tous les
départements on a effectivement des
sites dits seveso c'est le cas dans mon
département en isère notamment des
installations chimiques
ça va être l'occasion effectivement de
regarder si si demain matin on est
capable de faire face à un tel événement
grégoire milo on l'a entendu en séance
certain nombre de parlementaires
demandent à ce que l'état aujourd'hui
ils protègent 1 face à ce genre de
situation vous comment est-ce que vous
jugez cette gestion de la crise par le
gouvernement en terme d'opinion c'est
intéressant je suis roi n'est donc je
connais bien le territoire et la
situation j'étais en contact avec des
certaines de roanne et la manif d'hier
c'était on pleure pas pour chirac on
pleure pour l'ammoniac bon ce qui est
vrai c'est que il ya un certain nombre
de défauts qui sont pas nouveaux c'est à
dire que ayant l'expérience du travail
avec les services de l'état depuis 30
ans j'ai travaillé en particulier sur
l'épée périt les plans de prévention des
risques industriels
vous savez les uns et les autres à quel
point quand il faut parler il faut
demander au dessus qui demande au dessus
qui demande au dessus et en règle
générale on ne parle pas comme vous
l'évoquiez aujourd'hui la société de
l'information va à une vitesse qu'il
faut qu'il faut intégrer et gérer
donc c'est vrai qu'en deux occasions ça
pose la question d'une part delà de la
transparence a été dit par le premier
ministre et répétait exactement
plusieurs reprises que toute la
transparence soit faite sur l'ensemble
du circuit de décision à une information
aussi compliqué soit il est ce qu a dit
premier ministre s'y est assez
intéressant en matière de discours
publics
c'est on n'a pas les réponses
aujourd'hui à toutes les questions qui
se posent
parce que c'est vrai aussi et je le
comprends très bien des gens que j'avais
des rouennais que j'avais au téléphone
c'est qu'ils me disaient pas nous on a
besoin de savoir
savoir si c'est mauvais pour la santé si
ceci cela ce qui est complètement
légitime après ce qui est vrai c'est que
l'on peut pas toujours tout savoir
voilà dans dans la minute donc en tout
cas en terme de communication publique
c'est évident que cette nécessité de
transparence et d'ouverture ressort mais
aussi le fait d'intégrer qu'on ne sait
pas tout tout de suite forcément vous
qui avait présidé une commission
d'enquêté parlementaire sur la pollution
de l'air qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre
de cette commission d' enquête qui va
être créée par le sénat jean françois
husson
alors d'abord je pense que les auditions
vont remettre beaucoup de raisons et
d'objectivité
deuxièmement ça va permettre également
de décortiquer les mécanismes et moi je
pressens assez facilement que ce qui a
été dit par mon collègue est ce que vous
avez également évoqué je pense qu'on va
on va devoir bien encadré c'est à dire
c'est plutôt que des normes je pense
qu'il va y avoir de la réglementation
mais ce qui m'avait frappé dans cette
commission denquête on composait de
shawn que deux questions à la fin c'est
pour agir contre la pollution de l'air
vous privilégiez quoi yam différentes
solutions s'est refait bouger la
réglementation ou la fiscalité
90 % c'était la réglementation même si
effectivement on n'aime pas plus que ça
les normes en disant si on travaille sur
l'alimentation il faut travailler à
livre ouvert pour permettre à tous les
acteurs les populations les industriels
de se projeter et là c'est la même chose
moi je jette pas j'ai posé la question
sur ses désolation et ce qu'elle adapte
et que j'ai pas eu de réponse
je pense que c'est bien de répondre sur
la qualité des pompiers c'est mieux de
répondre aux questions sur le fond est
en tous les cas de tracé de dresser les
perspectives
allez on continue le débrief de cette
question d'actualité au gouvernement il
ya un autre sujet sur laquelle il ya eu
plusieurs questions ce sujet bien c'est
le budget de la sécurité sociale on
écoute un extrait des questions d'actu
et on revient juste après sécurité
sociale madame le ministre est malade et
vous ne prescrivent est pas le bon
remède pire vous aggravé le mal
vous remettez en cause plusieurs
principes fondamentaux qui constitue à
nos yeux le coeur de notre système de
protection sociale
mettez fin à l'autonomie d'insécurité
sociale on ne respectant pas la loi veil
de 1994 et en la privant de près de 3
milliards d'euros
avec la mise en oeuvre des mesures
d'urgence économique et social en
réponse à la crise des jets et jaune du
gouvernement entente il uniquement agir
sur le levier de la baisse des pensions
d'aujourd'hui et de demain
le projet de loi de finances propose de
mieux prendre en compte les parcours de
vie de soutenir la petite enfance et
l'accompagnement des familles
monoparentales qui sont les plus
vulnérables
mais aussi de prendre en compte des
nouveaux risques sociaux de simplifier
l'accès au droit et de poursuivre la
lutte contre les déserts médicaux
vous avez là les axes de ce futur budget
que vous aurez à débattre dans les
prochaines semaines et notamment au sein
de votre commission monsieur le
président je voudrais que nous ayons
tous en tête
cette déclaration de simone veil la
sécurité sociale c'est d'abord un
immense progrès social et le plus
puissant facteur de cohésion sociale qui
existe en france que nous avons le
devoir de préserver pour les générations
futures
sophie calle polian alors qu'est ce que
vous pensez de cette séquence autour du
budget de la sécurité sociale
olivier faur le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste a dit il ya un
véritable tour de passe passe qui a été
fait par le gouvernement
finalement et bien il ne va pas
équilibrer les comptes de la sécu comme
il devrait le faire il va utiliser les
comptes de la sécu pour financer et bien
les mesures d'hygiène ce qui ont été
liés aux mouvements de gilet jaune
c'est exact qu'en fait on fait peser sur
la protection sociale un certain nombre
un certain nombre de décisions
gouvernementales alors en faveur de la
population pour les gilet jaune mais en
fait les décisions en faveur de la
population elles sont aussi liées à la
justice fiscale donc en fait on a un jeu
de benneteau je le confirme
qui finalement met en danger la sécurité
sociale et donc les prestations sociales
et on le voit très bien aussi sur la
question de l'assurance chômage et des
baisses massives d'indemnisation qui
vont toucher les plus précaires donc
pour financer un certain nombre de
choses notamment des baisses d'impôts
de ceux qui payent des impôts sur les
revenus je précise que ce ne sont pas
forcément les plus pauvres c'est aussi
des catégories sociales modestes mais ce
ne sont pas forcément les plus hauts
on tape sur les prestations sociales et
notamment sur l'indemnité chômage qui la
touche notamment les plus précaires un
didier rambaud christian eckert l'ex
secrétaire d'état au budget a dit si le
gouvernement supprime des recettes de la
sécurité sociale dès qu'elle revient à
l'équilibré et la met ainsi dans le
rouge ce n'est pas la peine d'avoir fait
polytechnique poursuit pour comprendre
qu'ils veulent changer de système
est ce que c'est un trait à la halle un
changement de système pour la sécurité
sinon attendez que ce soit budget de
l'état au budget de la sécurité sociale
à la sortie c'est le budget des français
donc soyons clair donc là on est quand
même sur des jeux et d'écriture moi ça
me choque mesure ne mélangeons pas tout
mental ne mélangeons pas tout vous ai
parlé d'assurance chômage c'est autre
chose
alors là c'est une autre c'est une autre
merci anbar dont on sait tous ce
respecté jusqu'à présent c'est une autre
c'est un autre dispositif l'assurance
chômage ne sont pas toujours les mesures
sociales vous dire que ce soit la prime
d'activité que ce soit les heures
supplémentaires la fiscalisation des des
heures supplémentaires c'est bien des
mesures sociales je veux dire ça bien
des conséquences sur les recettes de ce
les recettes de la sécurité sociale donc
ça me surprend pas qui effectivement bas
le budget soit hélas un peu plus
aggravée pour pauvres pour financer
justement c'est ces mesures l'assurance
mais chômage c'est pas c'est pas ça qui
ne remet pas en cause l'assurance
chômage à cause de cela c'est parce que
selon lui de remettre à plat nos
cotisations
voyez c'est l'histoire de la sécurité
sociale ce sont les cotisations des gens
qui payent les prestations et la bleue
jour je vais de cela george clooney
jours sont plus montés aux réductions
d'impôts antérieures vous savez c'est et
vous savez aussi les baisses d'impôts
des entreprises voulant juste une wii
parce que le gouvenement mélange tout
parce que justement jusqu'à présent on
avait un budget de la sécurité sociale
qui rien à part du budget de l'état et
c'est ça que vous brouillez et c'est là
que vous engagez au fond une réforme
fondamentale par rapport à ce qu'est la
sécurité sociale indien commun avant
tout de ceux qui cotisent en coin en
bref quoi la baisse des impôts est
financé par le budget national et parce
que vous aviez vous
alors quand l'état décide que les
cotisations sont allégées eh bien l'état
ne rembourse pas la plus factuelle peser
sur la série quotidienne sociale des
heures supplémentaires ça relève bien du
budget de la sécurité sociale donc bien
filant seul ou non vous ne compensait
pas les allégements de cotisations donc
vous décidez nous ont fait nous savons
il ya un petit souci mais bien sûr ce
soit un gros mot de l'audio d'accord
j'en prends fait que vous aurez un petit
mot sur ce sujet sur la sécurité sociale
je pense qu'il ya d'abord il ya des
dérapages des dérapages financiers
je pense qu'il ya un dérapage beaucoup
plus philosophique la sécurité sociale
c'est un pacte social de la nation
au sortir de la deuxième guerre mondiale
et aujourd'hui ce pacte il et
réinterrogé manger ah ben il ya je pense
un danger et donc il faut mettre le
débat sur la place publique parce que il
reste pardon juste un mot il ya un
dossier dont on parle trop peu celles
liées au vieillissement c'est le dossier
de la dépendance ça c'est un vrai sujet
et il mérite d harry
m sauf que les lois ça fait dix ans
qu'on leur porte
mais c'est le grand âge il est là
aujourd'hui il faut trouver la mire du
rocher il ya un vrai enjeu mais un enjeu
social et sociétal
je pense que en interrogeant le pacte
social au regarde qu'est ce qui doit
relever de la solidarité nationale
et qu'est-ce qui peut être portée par le
secteur assurantiel
alors avant de se quitter on va parler
du dernier thème de cette émission
ce son est bien allé marche de la colère
les manifestations de policiers qui ont
lieu en ce moment aujourd'hui sachez que
depuis le début de l'année 50 policiers
se sont donné la mort écoutez bien
justement un syndicaliste que nous avons
interrogés dans les manifestations
l'état dispose aujourd'hui sud la colère
la colère policière est réel
c'est une colère froide mais une colère
certaine aujourd'hui 51 suscite ont été
déplorés dans nos rangs depuis le début
de l'année une année noire exponentielle
on est là aussi pour manifester contre
le ras-le-bol des policiers par rapport
à leurs conditions de travail des
conditions de travail qui se détériorent
de plus en plus un management qui laisse
aussi à désirer
on est là également pour parler notre
régime de retraites régimes de retraite
qui n'est pas sécurisé alors qu'il est
il est inconcevable que les gendarmes
qui font partie du mime même ministère
que nous et leur régime de retraite
sécurisé camp nou policiers on ne l'a
pas encore est ce que vous pensez
légitime qu'un policier à 65 ans 67 ans
puisse encore courir le voyou tel qu'il
est aujourd'hui sur la voie publique
impossible et christophe castaner a été
interpellé dans l'hémicycle tout à
l'heure sur ce même sujet on écoute les
ministres de l'intérieur on peut pas
aujourd'hui évoquer les heures
supplémentaires en en négligeant la
cause la cause c'est effectivement une
baisse massive des emplois au sein de la
police et de la gendarmerie
c'est effectivement une sur mobilisation
après les attentats de 2015
et c'est aujourd'hui la nécessité de
remettre tout cela à niveau madame la
sénatrice
aux termes du budget que je présenterai
donc quelques jours devant votre
assemblée le budget de la police
nationale aura augmenté en trois
exercices de plus de 1 milliard d'euros
dans le budget je vous présenterai dans
quelques jours le budget de la police
augmentera de 5 3%
voilà madame la sénatrice des réponses
concrètes lisez rambo est ce que et bien
la réponse de christophe castaner est à
la hauteur et de l'urgence qu'on a pu
entendre tout à l'heure et bien dans la
voie de ce policier on voit
qu'effectivement ok mais il faut aussi
au delà de transformer ce pays il faut
le réparer
jeudi à réparer ce qui n'a pas été fait
les années précédentes il ya eu des
suppressions de postes en en matière de
gendarmerie et de police
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que les
fonctions régaliennes de notre pays
c'est une priorité
elles seront affirmé tendre dans ce
budget que ce soit en matière de justice
en matière de défense et en matière de
sécurité donc il faut d'abord dans une
réponse budgétaire le ministre vient de
vient de le confirmer
on aura l'occasion de l'examiner
lors de leurs du projet de loi de
finances pour 2020 grégoire milo on le
voit cette crise qui lie à elle dépasse
même les policiers allaient policier
dans l'emmental a reparlé des mères on
parlait des pompiers c'est beaucoup plus
large sentiment d'abandon que ressentent
et bien c'est un certain des
représentants de notre pays est un
paradoxe d'image sur la police c'est à
dire que les études montrent bien
l'adhésion peuvent avoir les français à
l'égard de de la police la police est là
pour les protéger pour les aider et
c'est vrai aussi que voilà il ya un
certain nombre de discours qui attaquent
frontalement la police d'ailleurs j'ai
écouté les questions tout à l'heure au
gouvernement il y en avait une qui était
sous entendu mais qui n'a pas été
explicité cetc sur les déclarations de
jean luc mélenchon justement il à faire
les barbares l épaule on est évidemment
sur ce sur ce fait je regardais hier une
autre chaîne avec frédéric péchenard qui
qui présentait un son livre et son
engagement pour la police mais on a
présenté un certain nombre d'image qui
ont pu choquer un certain nombre
d'habitants sur le voile sur des sur des
pratiques
donc on a eu sur ce paradoxe
jean-françois ils sont effectivement
aller police et il dénonce à la fois
leurs conditions de travail
mais il dénonce aussi bien la
stigmatisation systématique dont ils
font l'objet
et cela est aussi liée bien au mois de
crise des îles et jaune c'est à la fois
ya un côté surréaliste dans l'opinion
qui veut être protégés pour parfois
mieux mettre en cause pour remettre en
cause l'autorité
moi j'ai vu que j'ai vécu ce week-end à
nancy ou pour un peu plus de mille
manifestants
par crainte des black blocks on avait
plus de 500 personnels des forces de
l'ordre plus en hélicoptère c'est
glacial et glaçant et c'est inacceptable
dans une démocratie de la liberté de
manifester la contrepartie on fait ça
visage ouvert et je vais vous dire il
faut qu'on s'interroge joue moins sur
une chose les difficultés sont les mêmes
entre la gendarmerie et la police moi je
rentre pas dans la question d
organisation
la gendarmerie a fait sa mutation avec
succès avec succès dans beaucoup de
territoires de france ruraux là où la
police à plusieurs difficultés donc un
chantier voila ça n'est pas ma
spécialité mais un chantier il faut
regarder les choses en face se fait
tailler polian et à
un chantier dit jean françois husson
comment y à répondre au malaise des
policiers 50 suicides quand même depuis
le début de l'année je crois qu'il ya un
véritable chantier qui est de deux
ordres d'abord effectivement il faut
améliorer très sensiblement les
conditions de travail des policiers qui
ont des difficultés majeures notamment
dans les équipements
bon alors je n'ai pas en tête les
chiffres de dépenses en tête les
chiffres du nombre de postes mais il me
semble quand même que parmi les corps de
fonctionnaires ce ne sont pas ceux qui
ont été le plus touchés par les
diminutions de postes
j'ai même souvenir qu'il ya eu pas mal
de postes supplémentaires par contre en
terme d'équipement de voitures de
commissariat près de chez moi le
commissariat dans un état indigne on ça
c'est un véritable chantier très
important
puis la façon dont fonctionne la police
et dans ce qu'on veut de vous est ce
qu'on lui demande de faire
je crois effectivement que le
gouvernement a eu un recours abusif aux
forces de police
alors il ya eu des situations très
difficiles ça c'est sûr et les policiers
étaient là mais il y a aujourd'hui y
compris dans certaines manifestations
des dispositifs policiers gigantesques
donc faut pas s'étonner que les heures
supplémentaires explose j'ajouterai
qu'il y avait aussi et il faut qu'à un
moment donné dans notre pays nous
puissions l'admettre un certain nombre
de choses qui ont été réalisés par
certains policiers de violences
policières qui ont été avérés on l'a vu
quand même dans de multiples dans de
multiples vidéos à plusieurs reprises à
de nombreuses reprises et ça aussi si on
veut que la communication reprennent de
façon apaisée de façon sereine entre la
population et les policiers entrent
toutes les populations et tous les
policiers
il faut que les enquêtes soient menées à
terme il faut que c est que ces
agissements qui je pense sont très
nettement individuelle et bien soit
finie quand on voit un certain nombre de
problèmes avec dans les quartiers
sensibles mais aussi dans l'est autour
des manifestations de gilet jaune ou un
certain nombre de personnels même de la
presse ou mais des manifestants qui
faisait rien on voit des passants se
sont retrouvés dans des situations qui
ont mis en cause leur intégrité physique
je pense qu'il faut qu'on sorte de cette
situation et pour cela le ministre de
l'intérieur qui ne reconnaît absolument
pas ces faits portent une grande
responsabilité
didier rambaud oui il ya effectivement
la violence qui est subie par la police
et puis il ya aussi les doigts oui à se
requinquer voilà donc d'équilibrer un
peu la réaction parce que nous parler
que des violences policières y en a eu
je ne vais pas parler que des violences
policières beaucoup insister là dessus
c'est ce que vous souhaitez c'est ce que
vous souhaitez entendre j'ai parlé au
travail des policiers
et j'ai parlé aussi de faits individuels
je ne pense pas que la police dans son
ensemble soit évidemment vers elle fait
un travail très important non mais parce
que c'est important
merci mika ne jamais en parler et niais
qu'il y ait des violences policières ce
que le gouvernement fait justement
équilibrons un petit peu les choses
merci merci beaucoup à tous les cadres
d'avoir participé à ce débat c'est la
fin de ce premier débrief des séances de
questions d'actualité du mercredi au
sénat l'actualité parlementaire elle
continue sur public sénat tout de suite
voyez l'audition de jean-pierre farandou
le successeur désigné pour succéder à
guillaume pepy à la tête de la sncf a
passé ce matin son grand oral au sénat
regardez les dames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs
je suis heureux et honoré d'être
présents devant vous pour soumettre ma
candidature à votre vote
je vais vous faire part de ma vision au
moment où le président de la république
a proposé mon nom pour prendre la
responsabilité de la nouvelle sncf
puisque on va se projeter très vite sur
le début 2020 et mettre en perspective
cette nouvelle sncf qui ce qui s'annonce
au delà de l'actualité législative je
sais que la question des mobilités au
global et le sujet du ferroviaire en
particulier sont pour vous comme pour
chaque élue une question politique
centrale est sensible au quotidien c'est
sensibilité forte et touche tous les
territoires
j'en ai conscience aussi bien en tant
que citoyen comme en tant que chef
d'entreprise lorsque j'observe ce qui se
passe en france et partout dans le monde
je sait l'attachement et les attentes
que vous avez vis-à-vis de la sncf
je sais aussi que vous êtes attentifs
aux services rendus
je mettrai toute mon énergie au service
de la qualité et de l'efficacité
et ce chaque jour de mon mandat avant de
vous présenter ma feuille de route
quelques éléments mon parcours
en complément de ce qu'a bien voulu
présenter le président que je souhaite
partager avec vous je suis né le 4
juillet 1957 à talence en gironde à la
sortie d'école et mines de paris et
après avoir fait mon service militaire
dans l'armée de l'air je rentre à la
sncf donc en 1981 j'ai fait tous les
métiers du transport aiguilleurs
conducteurs de trains régulateurs et
bien d'autres je suis passé par toutes
les étapes du management opérationnel
management des hommes et des femmes
chefs d'equipe chef d'établissement
directeur régional directeur général des
transports en commun lyonnais
j'ai lancé trois tgv le tgv nord en 1993
thalys en 1996 et le tgv méditerranée en
2001 j'ai été drh adjoint pendant la
grande négociation des 35 heures 20 99
début 2000 au comex de la sncf où je
suis rentré en 2006 j'ai créé la
division sncf proximités qui est en fait
de la branche des trains de la vie
quotidienne et je suis effectivement
depuis sept ans pdg de keolis ou
président du directoire du groupe keolis
spécialiste du transport urbain qu'ils
ont passé un tiers de ma carrière à
l'extérieur de l'epic dont cinq ans à
l'étranger
pas très loin à bruxelles mais quand
même à l'étranger j'ai été deux fois
président de l'union des transports
publics
par ailleurs aussi président de l'
orchestre national de l'île de france et
président de l'union des pin's qui sont
les points d'information et de médiation
multi services
j'ai le service public la mobilité et
les territoires chevillée au corps
fait développer maintenant devant vous
trois points la mise en perspective de
la nouvelle sncf les engagements
vis-à-vis de l'état des français et des
cheminots et mes convictions sur la
direction que doit prendre l'entreprise
à ce moment si particulier de l'histoire
ferroviaire et de sa propre histoire
je souhaiterais commencer par mettre en
perspective la mission du futur
président de la sncf
au regard des décisions politiques qui
ont été ou qui vont être prises mais
aussi des urgences qui traversent notre
époque et que nous devons prendre en
compte la détermination politique de
l'état et du parlement lors de cette
réforme qui va donner naissance à la
nouvelle sncf marque le premier jour
d'une entreprise consciente de la
transformation à opérer et des
engagements à tenir
je voudrais saluer le rôle et
l'impulsion donnée par l'état et le
parlement qui ont pris acte de la
nécessité de moderniser le système
ferroviaire français
le parlement a fait sa part
dès 2014 en créant sncf réseau et tout
récemment en 2018
à travers le nouveau pacte ferroviaire
la reprise de dettes qui vous sera
proposé dans le cadre du projet de loi
de finances 2010 sera la prochaine étape
importante
marter réalisant cet engagement des
pouvoirs publics l'état et le parlement
ont voulu naissains cf unifiée car
l'efficacité du système ferroviaire
français est durablement liés à la
synergie entre le gestionnaire des
infrastructures est le principal
opérateur la sncf
cela portera notamment sur des choix
techniques majeures comme le système
d'exploitation et d'espacement des
trains la planification et d'exécution
des travaux ou encore l'information en
temps réel des voyageurs je veillerai à
l'unité de cette nouvelle sncf et je
m'en porterais garant mais je serai
aussi bien sur le président du strict
respect des règles françaises et
européennes en matière d'égalité entre
les opérateurs pour l'accès au réseau et
plus largement aux facilités
essentielles
à nous dirigeants de l'entreprise de
fait notre part du travail avec lucidité
pragmatisme et ambition ouverture à la
concurrence
changement de statut juridique avec le
passage des pics à société anonyme
reprise de la dette
évolution du statut social du personnel
avec l'arrêt des recrutements statutaire
au 1er janvier
nous le savons toutes ces mesures ne
sont pas de simples évolutions
technocratique elles marqueront à jamais
l'histoire du ferroviaire et de la sncf
c'est une étape déterminante pour nous
et pour les mobilités en france le
président de la république a fixé
l'ambition la sncf doit devenir le
champion mondial des mobilités du 21e
siècle
nous devons désormais conduire cette
transformation
sans oublier notre responsabilité être
digne de la confiance des élus et de la
société dans son ensemble et nous devons
répondre à cet enjeu politique et
économique pour l'avenir
nous avançons avec lucidité et
pragmatisme déjà par le passé
la sncf a accompagné des grandes
transformations de la société
le passage d'une économie industrielle à
une économie de services où
l'urbanisation et la métropolisation nos
territoires
les transports de la vie quotidienne ont
été ma priorité
aussi bien la sncf en créant par exemple
la direction sncf proximités que chez
keolis en lançant d'ambitieux projets de
mobilité en france et à l'international
quand on pense sncf
on pense souvent trains voyageurs ou en
france en réalité la sncf est un groupe
mondial 1 florent nationale que l'on
exporte dans 120 pays tant sur les
marchés du transport de voyageurs que de
la logistique
c'est une entreprise de 33 milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires dont un
tiers est réalisé à l'international
avec ses 270 mille collaborateurs et ses
100 métiers forts de ce que je vis chez
keolis je maintiendrai et renforcerait
cette ambition le ferroviaire représente
environ 50% du chiffre d'affaires
l'autre moitié du chiffre d'affaires du
groupe c'est par exemple le transport
urbain avec keolis premier exploitant
mondial de métro
c'est aussi le transport routier de
marchandises avec geodis quatrième
logisticiens européens mais aussi le
numérique avec houllier cncf premiers
sites dits commerce en france dans les
grandes réussites de sncf soulignons
aussi le succès du ter remarquable
exercice de décentralisation celui du
transilien
malgré la complexité de son exploitation
et les investissements massifs réalisés
ces dernières années pour remettre en
état
notre réseau ferré national
je tiens d'ailleurs associé à ces
réussites les présidents précédents qui
m'ont particulièrement marqué louis
gallois
anne marie idrac est naturellement
guillaume pepy que je salue et remercie
pour avoir remis le client au coeur de
notre action
mais nous sommes aussi dans un contexte
d'urgence la naissance de la sncf de la
nouvelle sncf intervient dans un monde
très spécifique un moment d'urgence
premièrement une urgence
environnementale c'est un moment
politique sociale et de prise de
conscience il y ait dit cela nous
dépasse et nous oblige envers la planète
je souhaite que la nouvelle sncf
participent en déclinant pour
elles-mêmes les objectifs de
développement durable que la france est
fixé nous sommes d'ailleurs en mouvement
sncf réseau est la seule compagnie
ferroviaire au monde à avoir levé plus
de 5 milliards d'euros d'obligations
vertes ce qu'on appelle les greens bones
deuxième urgence l'urgence territoriale
parler des territoires c'est affirmer
que l'on doit sortir de l' opposition
classique entre les grandes lignes et
les petites lignes entre le mass transit
et les lignes de desserte fine
s'il ya des différences entre chacune
d'entre elles cela doit être sur leurs
méthodes d'exploitation et non sur leur
priorisation
les territoires en droit à la différence
qui ne doit jamais exclure l'un d'entre
eux d'un service ferroviaire ou de
mobilité efficace
la troisième urgence elle est économique
et sociale d'abord l'ouverture à la
concurrence et la reprise de la dette
par l'état nous impose un effort très
important et rapide d'efficacité pour
retrouver la compétitivité et équilibrer
le système eco ferroviaire français
cette exigence économique on prend
nécessairement volet social il ne faut
pas opposer l'une et l'autre mais au
contraire marché simultanément sur les
deux jambes de l'efficacité économique
et du nouveau pacte social entre la sncf
et ses salariés
c'est pourquoi il y a urgence à
transformer la sncf en la nouvelle sncf
alors le temps de la transformation est
venu à travers ma candidature à sa
présidence je souhaite incarner et
accompagner l'entreprise dans la
construction de regard neuf sur
elle-même sans tabou les sept ans que je
viens de passer chez keolis me permets
d'apporter un regard lucide et
bienveillant sur ce qu'il convient de
faire évoluer ce que nous devons faire
c'est ouvrir collectivement une ère
nouvelle
la sncf appartient à notre patrimoine la
sncf doit porter tous nos tous nos
ambitions en matière de mobilité
la sncf doit rendre aux français ce que
chacun d'eux lui a donné voilà la
nouvelle essentielle que je souhaite au
service des français au service des
territoires
en fait je veux une sncf utile et notre
valeur cardinale a toujours été
l'utilité utilité sociale et
environnementale
c'est concourir aux engagements de la
france en matière de réduction des
émissions de co2 pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone en 2035
c'est aussi une utilité servicielle
s'est proposé un français au niveau de
qualité pour le service ferroviaire qui
sont en droit d'attendre
cette nouvelle sncf doit être non
seulement utile mais encore plus
connectés plus proche et plus efficiente
ce que je souhaite c'est une nouvelle
sncf qui concilie le client quels qu'ils
soient
voyageur collectivités territoriales
charger et le sens du service public
les valeurs du service public et
l'intérêt général sont plus que jamais
présente et pour moi l'intérêt général
doit servir l'intérêt économique et
l'intérêt économique servir l'intérêt
général
améliorer notre compétitivité économique
c'est indispensable pour soutenir mieux
et davantage le service public
voilà après cette mise en perspective
j'en viens on continue les engagements
que je prends avant toute chose le
premier nommé engagement pour la
nouvelle sncf et de répondre aux
fondamentaux qui constituent nos racines
la sécurité des circulations et du
personnel
la performance du réseau la ponctualité
et la qualité et la précision de
l'information donnée aux voyageurs
au-delà de ces fondamentaux que je viens
de rappeler je souhaiterais prendre
devant vous quatre engagements
le premier ça sera vis-à-vis des clients
je m'engage à un service personnalisé et
une attention portée à tous nos clients
nos clients voyageurs attendent de la
nouvelle sncf une expérience de services
mieux adaptés à chacun d'entre eux une
sncf plus ouverte plus accessible
notamment en matière de prix qui joue
pleinement son rôle moteur pour les
mobilités enfance chez keolis nous avons
proposé ainsi plusieurs innovations de
service qui simplifie la vie des clients
notre mission est aujourd'hui de créer
au delà de la continuité des services
une continuité de mobilité en utilisant
toutes les solutions disponibles sur le
marché
celle de la sncf bien sûr mais aussi
celle des autres acteurs
la question n'est pas de savoir ce que
la sncf a pu proposer mais c'est ce que
la nouvelle sncf sera en mesure de
construire comme of penser aux clients
ses pensées à tous les clients pour les
charger du fret
l'enjeu n'est pas seulement commercial
il est aussi de contribuer à une
économie décarbonée le deuxième
engagement que je prends c'est la
réponse c'est la réponse au défi
climatique et à la proximité avec les
territoires
l'équation est simple donné l'envi de
train
c'est choisir la façon la plus directe
de lutter pour le climat et permettre un
développement durable en conjuguant
mobilité et protection de la planète
pour le climat la sncf est
intrinsèquement une partie de la réponse
et nous devons continuer à faire mieux
faire mieux c'est faire plus écologique
plus local dans des contraintes
économiques maîtrisé et en visant la
neutralité carbone
concrètement cela se traduira par la
construction de programmes innovants
pour par exemple entretenir les voies
sans abîmer les sols l'arrêt du cliff
hosatte se fera avant la fin 2021
pour toujours plus de proximité
m'inscrivant dans la direction tracée
par le premier ministre je m'engage à
dialoguer avec tous les territoires
le troisième engagement sera pour les
salariés c'est un nouveau pacte social
qui s'agit de construire avec eux et
pour eux après avoir négocié en 2016
en tant que président de l'utp des
points importants de la convention
collective nationale du secteur
ferroviaire comme l'organisation du
travail
la branche doit maintenant finaliser les
chapitres classification et rémunération
pour l'ensemble des salariés relevant de
ce secteur
a la sncf il faut établir le nouveau
pacte social entre l'entreprise et ses
salariés
comme tout groupe industriel nous sommes
confrontés à des évolutions métiers
majeurs sous l'effet notamment de la
révolution numérique un métier sur deux
sera à nouveau métier ce nouveau pacte
social doit garantir une place et des
perspectives à chacun sur le long terme
il doit aussi donner envie de rejoindre
la nouvelle sncf
le quatrième engagement je le prendrais
vis-à-vis des contribuables c'est
l'efficacité économique et financière à
keolis géant c'est en fait progresser le
chiffre d'affaires de 70 % la marge a
doublé et la dette est maintenant
totalement maîtrisé la nouvelle sncf
devra tenir ses engagements avec l'état
et respecter la trajectoire de retour à
l'équilibré financier du système
ferroviaire
prévue pour 2022 cet engagement
c'est la contrepartie du désendettement
massif décidé par l'état 35 milliards
d'euros de reprise de dette
et c'est la condition nécessaire à la
compétitivité de l'entreprise
alors comment ferons nous il faudra
développer les recettes réduire les
coûts d'exploitation et optimiser
l'investissement en donnant la priorité
aux investissements productifs et à ceux
qui améliorent le service et donc les
recettes
plusieurs leviers d'action rendront
cette transformation possible la culture
de la performance individuelle et
collective
l'efficacité industrielle mais aussi
l'innovation et le digital mis au
service de tous
cette révolution numérique est partout
présente à nous de la maîtriser pour
dépasser la fracture numérique qui est
souvent même temps la fracture
territoriale avec au coeur de cette
transformation la mobilité durable
pour terminer je voudrais partager avec
vous mes convictions pour cette nouvelle
sncf pour atteindre l'excellence que je
vise
il n'y a pas de temps à perdre car les
cycles économiques n'ont jamais été
aussi courts et les concurrents sont
agressifs nous ferons de l'adaptation de
notre service aux changements des modes
de vie une obsession permanente voyons
clair et soyons lucides
si demain les voyageurs sont satisfaits
et trouve les services dont ils ont
besoin
même ceux dont les yeux sont aujourd'hui
rivés sur l'ouverture à la concurrence
ils choisiront la nouvelle sncf si
demain la sncf est capable de porter de
manière compétitive
les enjeux climatiques des transports de
marchandise et de la logistique
les chargeurs choisiront la nouvelle
sncf
si demain la sncf n'oppose pas les
grandes lignes les petites lignes mais
offre une réponse globale aux besoins de
mobilité dans toute leur variété et à un
prix raisonnable
les collectivités territoriales
choisiront la sncf
enfin si demain la sncf est reconnu pour
sa haute capacité d'innovation
partenaires industriels pme start up
choisiront la nouvelle sncf
je suis devant vous en ayant pleinement
conscience de la responsabilité qui me
reviendrait pour mener cette
transformation le courage politique dont
a fait preuve le parlement en gage la
nouvelle sncf dans la concrétisation
rapide de son projet au service des
français et des territoires pour mener
cette transformation je ne serai pas
seul dans l'exercice de ma présidence
car la sncf se dirige avec avec les
cheminots l'ensemble des salariés
d'aujourd'hui de demain et leurs
représentants syndicaux avec les clients
qui vivent la sncf au quotidien et leur
association avec tous les élus nationaux
régionaux et locaux avec les territoires
dans leur diversité et enfin avec nos
partenaires et nos fournisseurs
si vous m'invitez je souhaiterais chaque
année devant vous rendre compte de
l'avancement de la transformation et de
ce qu'est la nouvelle sncf mener à bien
cette transformation nous le pouvons et
nous le devons à chaque français je vous
remercie pour votre attention il sut
maintenant prêt à répondre à vos
questions
merci beaucoup ce soit en 12 je vais
donner la parole tout d'abord à ce
moment délicat était le rapporteur de la
l'homme qui suit les questions
ferroviaires au sein de notre commission
merci se présente ce président je
voudrais d'abord vous féliciter pour
votre parcours personnel
qui a été réalisée en interne dans la
même entreprise depuis ou prise de
fonction initiale
c'est assez exemplaire pour être
souligné je voudrais également vous dire
que j'ai été sensible au fait que vous
ayez déclaré à la presse après
l'annnonce de votre désignation
nomination par le président de la
république que vous ayez pris la
précaution de préciser aux médias qui
vous a doublé déjà comme président de
dire que vous deviez passer devant le
parlement pour être définitivement
intégré à ce poste bas donc jeu c'est
assez rare pour être souligné je
voudrais partir de l'international pour
ma première question vous avez évoqué le
fait que la sncf était devait devenir un
champion mondial est déjà présente dans
un grand nombre de pays plus de 120
quelle est la stratégie que vous comptez
mettre en oeuvre pour y parvenir en
termes de croissance externe
éventuellement voilà ce que vous est
d'ores et déjà des pistes sur le sujet
ma deuxième question elle est
consécutive à l'adoption de la loi
l'homme même si encore une étape à
franchir
ici au sénat dans le cadre de la loi
nome nous avons sanctuariser les
ressources de lafitte nous avons
entériné la sécurisé en tout cas le
conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures dans le cadre de ces
deux instances
évidemment tout ce qui concerne le
ferroviaire est temps au premier chef
concernée est-ce que d'ores et déjà vous
avez pu reprendre les éléments des
différents scénarios 1 2 et 3 du cwh y
voir un avis d'ores et déjà sur le
financement de la fit au financement des
projets et puis dans là l'homme nous
avions également intégré vous l'avez
évoqué aussi la question des petites
lignes avec la possibilité la faculté
pour les régions de leur prend donc je
vais avoir votre avis sur ce point
précis également des rires dans la
l'homme et plus vite dans le cas de
l'album nous avons intégré des
obligations avec un sérum d'amendement
des collègues on essaie de trouver un
équilibre pour la question de
l'intermodalité notamment l'obligation
pour sncf mais aussi d'autres acteurs
dans les gares de favoriser
l'implantation des vélos tout simplement
est ce que mon ami une obligation en
2024 est-ce que d'ores et déjà cncef
anticiper sur cette question quel est le
plan stratégique défini et puis un
dernier point qui concerne un sujet
d'actualité où nous l'avons vécue à
travers de nombreux articles de presse
plus ou moins polémique concernant la
gestion et la rénovation des gares et je
pense en particulier à l'égard du nord à
la fois sur le fait qu' on donne
évidemment priorité 1 priorités en terme
d' équilibre sur le plan commercial et
financier
ce sont des pôles importants qui voit
transiter de nombreuses des centaines de
milliers de personnes
et à l'instar de ce qui se passe dans
les aéroports devraient constituer à
terme une ressource importante pour sncf
est-ce que sur ce cas précis gare du
nord est ce que quelqu'un quel est votre
jugement votre regard porté dans la
mesure où voilà on a la foi la ville de
paris mais également collectif
d'architectes qui dénonce un peu le fait
qu'on privilégie l'aspect commercial au
flux des voyageurs
même si moi j'ai regardé le projet dans
le détail en termes de séparation de
flux les arrivées des départs là mais je
voulais avoir votre avis précisément sur
cette question et puis je m'arrêterai là
pour laisser aux collègues compléter la
série de questions
surtout que j'ai déjà une douzaine de
demandes de prise de parole donc on fera
assez bref sur les questions et sur les
réponses avec des merci merci président
j'ai le sens de la synthèse
bon donc sur les investissements et pour
l'international oui alors je pense que
le le groupe sncf comme je l'expliqué
est aussi un groupe international c'est
moins connu mais c'est une réalité il ya
déjà presque un tiers de son chiffre
d'affaires qui se fait à l'international
il faut continuer on peut faire en repli
sur sur l'hexagone
donc il faut absolument que les métiers
que nous avons développée en france plus
en plus continuer à les exporter dans
tous nos savoir faire
on a des bases solides avec deux grandes
filiales qui sont à l'avant-garde geodis
pour la logistique
et puis keolis pour le transport urbain
et ferroviaire d'ailleurs aussi bien on
fait aussi du train à l'international
non oui il faut se développer
peut-être que l'élément l'élément de
conditionnalité que je rajouterais
pour l'avoir vécu le développement
international comporte des risques
vous connaissez pas les pays vous
connaissez - les pays dont vous avez
forcément une part de risque
supplémentaire quand vous rentrez dans
un pays lointain et c'est encore plus
vrai comme vous éloigner des logiques
ocde voilà les logiques et c'est dur on
se ressemble dès que vous arrivez sur
des pays sud américains africains ou
asiatiques
forcément la part de risque augmente
donc l'élément nouveau fondamental de la
nouvelle sncf celle à l'extrême rigueur
sur la maîtrise du cash et de la dette
voilà il ya vraiment une trajectoire
économique qui nous oblige je le prends
comme tel et je mettrai toute mon
énergie est la respecter et donc ça veut
dire que le développement à
l'international se fera mais en en étant
très attentif à ce qu'on ne fasse pas de
faux pas et qu'on ne remarque pas dans
des aventures qui occasionnerait des
pertes financières qui abîmeraient la
trajectoire financière et de la même
manière et vous l'avez un peu évoquée en
matière de financement du développement
pour faire très attention à ce que les
allocations de substances de cash comme
on dit dans le jargon soient bien
ciblées
donc je pense que la priorité on va dire
c'est plutôt la france donc à l'étranger
il faudra être très attentif à ce que
les besoins de financement soit n'obère
pas notre capacité de maîtrise de la
dette est peut-être d'ailleurs qu'on
soit imaginatif en trouvant des
partenaires qui nous aideront à financer
la croissance de nos filiales à
l'international sur la nomme alors le
volet infrastructures
moi j'aime bien revenir à des
fondamentaux il n'y a pas de bons
services ferroviaires ça pas de bonnes
infrastructures
voilà on l'a d'ailleurs trop négligé
dans ce pays on sait bien que c'est le
problème que nous avons
voilà c'est une responsabilité
collective pendant une trentaine
d'années
nous n'avons pas mis assez d'argent sur
le réseau structurant sur le réseau
principal
non non à grande vitesse et donc depuis
quelques années nous avons entrepris un
formidable effort de rattrapage et de
remise en état de ce réseau de ce réseau
structurant
le financement bien sûr et clé s'il n'a
pas les ressources financières pour
réaliser les opérations de régénération
et de renouvellement on n'y arrivera pas
c'est la symbolique c'est l'âge du
réseau notre réseau structurant à 30 ans
de moyenne d'âge
le réseau allemand n'a 17 bon sinon on
des comptes l'effort qu'il faut faire
pour rajeunir à nouveau le réseau qui
avait tendance à vieillir année après
année on est juste au début quand tu
n'es travaux qu'on fait on a stoppé son
vieillissement
on est en train de petit à petit
commencé à la rajeunir mais c'est un
effort long on va très bien que la
collectivité devra consentir un effort
très long dans la durée pour réussir à
ramener notre réseau ferroviaire partie
du patrimoine de notre pays à un niveau
de 2 finalement de qualité satisfaisant
et de fiabilité satisfaisant ça c'est
pour la régénération qui est clé là
dessus d'ailleurs la trajectoire
financière telle peut être qu'elle ait
négocié avec le gouvernement qui qui est
autour de 6 milliards d'euros par an
sont pas faire des choses on a 6
milliards d'euros par an entre l'art le
renouvellement et les projets dans trois
milliards pour le renouvellement par an
pour commencer à travailler je rappelle
qu'à une dizaine d'années on n'avait
qu'un on est passé d'un milliard à 3
milliards milliards était alors
absolument insuffisant avec 3 milliards
qui correspond au rythme actuellement
constatés avec une perspective
d'ailleurs à l'euro monte même jusqu'à
trois et demi je considère que la l'état
fait les efforts nécessaires pour nous
permettre de régénérer le réseau
ferroviaire structurant sur le
développement alors là c'est très clair
ça c'est vraiment une
c'est une décision de l'état et du
parlement puisque ce n'est pas un réseau
qui financera le développement c'est
vraiment l'argent de l'état et du budget
qui financera le le développement ce
choix c'est un choix à prendre il ya des
critères socio économique qu'il faut
prendre en compte sur l'intérêt des
projets il peut y avoir aussi des
critères d'aménagement du territoire de
décision de notre pays de relier telle
ou telle ville ou tel ou tel territoire
au réseau à grande vitesse par exemple
ou d'améliorer en profondeur telle ou
telle ligne importantes d'intérêt
national dont là ça renvoie au volet
c'est oui au volet financement
enfin capacité à décider un programme
pluriannuel de développement de nos
infrastructures
c'est très attendu car ce qui veut dire
ce qui est important c'est qu'on ait une
décision
le pire c'est la certitude
alors cette décision on souhaite qu'elle
soit le la plus importante possible je
prendrai pas je n'en ai pas d'avis sur
les scénarios 1 2 3 je pense que c'est
pas ma responsabilité de le faire par
contre voilà il faut cugnaux soient
prises et tenue est tenue en pour que
tout le monde puisse organiser y compris
la filière industrielle autour de de ce
schéma directeur qui qui ressortirait de
2,7 de la partie infrastructure ii de la
loi l'homme sur sur les petites lignes
là encore on a bien entendu que les
petites lignes sont un élément très
important de notre de l'aménagement du
territoire a même du ressenti des
français il ya un attachement très très
fort des français aux lignes
ferroviaires
ce qui fait que chaque fois d'ailleurs
qu'on veuille touché on voit ce qui se
passe là il ya des réactions très fortes
donc c'est vraiment très emblématique du
développement d'un territoire
l'existence de ces lignes qu'on a
d'ailleurs appelé plus joliment desserte
de fines les lignes de desserte fine du
territoire
elles sont importantes elles ont elles
ont leur rôle
là encore les règles du jeu en matière
de financement commence à être posée
avec une participation de l'état étaient
des régions des collectivités à la
régénération de céline elles ont besoin
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui ces lignes
sont pas toutes mais certaines sont en
mauvais état donc effectivement leur
pérennité se pose donc il faut engager
des ressources pour les régénérer il ya
eu un effort de fait on est passé en
gros 250 millions par an à 300 il faut
peut-être aller encore un peu au delà et
d'ailleurs on attend la sortie du
rapport philizot qui peut-être nous
éclairera sur les politiques à conduire
et des moyens à y consacrer avec la part
de l'état et la part des régions
ce n'est pas qu'un sujet des
infrastructures même si l'infrastructure
est vital c'est aussi un sujet de
service sur ses lignes
et d'ailleurs les deux sont liés quand
vous discutez avec les gens des cinq
réseaux ils nous disent nous on fera le
réseau qui correspondra au projet de
service que vous voulez préfère circuler
sur le réseau par exemple si vous avez
une double voie et que vous avez
finalement peu de traits à faire
circuler
peut-être qu'un passage à voie unique
performant avec télécommande peut
suffire
voyez bien qu'en termes de coûts c'est
pas du tout pareil ça devrait générer 2
voies ou une les budgets sont pas les
mêmes par exemple vous avez aussi un
exemple qui réussit sur la sur la côte
bleue là c'est entre marseille et fos
sur mer ou en ajustant le projet
d'infrastructure au projet de service
régional
on a pu baisser les coûts de 20% voilà
on voit bien que la clé c'est aussi
cette capacité à s'adapter à des projets
locaux a des ambitions locales à des
conditions locales y compris d'ailleurs
sur les normes techniques il faut pas
appliquer des grands référentiels
nationaux
il faut être capable de les ajuster à
des réalités locales sur sur les vélos
un inconnu philosophie que le vélo est
l'ami du transport collectif et du
transport ferroviaire vélo doit prendre
toute sa place dans une politique de
mobilité urbaine plutôt urbaine
périurbaine petite distance dans les
milieux ruraux
le vélo électrique permettant de
rallonger un peu les distances et de
faire accéder au vélo aussi peut-être
plus de gens qui auraient du mal sinon à
tête à pédaler sur un vélo sans
assistance électrique venant de l'urbain
je crois beaucoup au vélo et je pense
que dans notre pays d'avoir c'est en
train de pousser on est ensemble pour
l'instant de passer un cap
autour du vélo notamment notamment dans
les villes et oui le train devra
s'articuler avec le vélo ou le vélo avec
le train il ya deux manières de
s'articuler la première des politiques
qui est celle que nous encourageons à la
sncf c'est des parkings à vélo faire en
sorte que les gens puissent venir en
vélo et laissé en toute sécurité leur
vélo dans les abris sécurisés spacieux
pratique d'accès pas loin des voies
avant de prendre le train et une fois
arrivé à destination bénéficier de vélos
en libre service dans les villes par
exemple
donc c'est vraiment la voie que nous
privilégions pour autant nous n'écartons
pas la montée des vélos à bord des
trains on sait bien que là il ya un
équilibre à trouver avec les passagers
eux mêmes c'est à dire la place
consacrée au vélo elle peut venir
parfois s'opposer à la place comme on a
laissé au passager notamment les
périodes de pointe
voilà pour y faire un peu attention
région parisienne en particulier mais je
pense qu'on peut tout à fait faire
cohabiter à bord des trains des vélos et
des passagers si les vélos sont démontés
c'est plus facile là c'est comme un gros
bagage si le vélo n'est pas démonté il
ya les emplacements il faut prévoir leur
nombre et les logiques et les procédures
d'accès voilà en tout cas je serai
quelqu'un qui encouragera le vélo parce
que je crois que fondamentalement on
peut pas parler de mobilité durable sur
n'inclut pas le vélo sous toutes ses
formes dans les politiques de mobilité
sur la gare du nord bon j'aurai un petit
devoir de réserve eux n'étant pas encore
au coeur au coeur du dossier
je suis étonné finalement je le don je
le regarde avec encore un peu
d'externalités je pensais qu'il y avait
un accord franchement de ce qu'on
m'avait expliqué je pensais qu entre les
principaux donneurs d'ordre
en gros la sncf et la ville de paris
pour faire court je pensais qu'il y
avait un accord depuis 2018 c'est ce
qu'on m'avait dit et il semblerait que
ce ne soit pas le cas
voilà donc il faut essayer de comprendre
quels sont les éléments nouveaux qui ont
qui explique ce désalignement il ya
certainement des réseaux donc je
souhaiterais lorsque je si vous si vous
confirmez mama mama candidature bien sûr
je m'empare aurait très vite de ce
dossier parce qu'il est il est dans
l'actualité dont faudra rapidement
regarder quels sont les éléments de ces
divergents de nouvelles est ce qu'on
peut se remettre en convergence parce qu
il est bien évident que l'objectif c'est
d'arriver à mettre tout le monde
d'accord et avoir une convergence sur la
nature du projet qui satisfasse
l'ensemble des parties prenantes je
rappelle qu'un petit sujet de planning
puisque l'ambition initiale c'était que
cette gare du nord qui en a besoin je
crois que tout le monde est d'accord qui
a bien besoin d'être rénovée puisse être
prête pour les jeux olympiques 2024 il y
avait une petite ambition de fierté
nationale à ce que voilà les les
nombreux étrangers qui viendront voir
paris certains venant par la gare du
nord d'ailleurs puissent vivre une garde
une gare du nord rénové voilà donc il ya
aussi ce petit aiguillon qui doit nous
encourager à se mettre autour d'une
table et à trouver les voies d'une
convergence en tout cas c'est d'état
d'esprit dans lequel je suis à cette
occasion après les grandes
problématiques vous avez expliqué les
équilibres entre la priorité doit donner
aux flux de voyageurs bien évidemment
une gare c'est d'abord pour monter dans
les trains pour descendre des phrases
c'est très clair après il ne faut pas
s'interdire de dans les espaces du gard
autour d'une gare d'avoir aussi des
services à la fois parce que ses
services sont utiles à aux voyageurs et
aux riverains puis deuxièmement au
procès ce cachet qui sont une source de
revenus et on peut pas
dégager nos revers de la main une source
de revenus au moment où l'argent public
est rare
voilà donc il faut trouver les
équilibres je suis convaincu qu'on y
arrivera mais je vais vous interroger
sur le social vous l'avez dit vous avez
géré les 35 heures dans les années 2000
reste à voir comment vous alliez conduit
négociations et quelle leçon vous tiré
de cette expérience en tant que drh et
quels sont les points sur lesquels vous
serez particulièrement vigilants pour
conduire la réforme sociale de la sncf
nouvelle quels sont aujourd'hui vos
relations avec les syndicats et comment
vous comptez travailler avec eux alors
le social jour dès qu'on en prenne un
peu la mesure parce que je en préparant
bien sûr ces auditions je me suis rendu
compte qu'il y avait énormément de
choses dont l'actualité est chargée
voilà c'est un moment un peu particulier
où il ya beaucoup de choses alors il ya
déjà tout ce qui est à l'intérieur de la
sncf qui était le social que nous
maîtrisons c'est la direction ces
syndicats et son corps social il ya ce
fameux pacte social dont on a parlé
c'est une vraie petite révolution ça
parce que c'est la conséquence de
l'arrêt du recrutement statut à partir
du 1er janvier 2020 très bientôt un an
dans trois mois
regardez nouveaux salariés qui vont
arriver qui seront pas au statut
aujourd'hui les règles sociales
applicables sont pas complètes donc il
faut dans un laps de temps très court
définir les règles sociales de
rémunération de classification de
déroulement de carrière de formation les
droits et devoirs les droits et devoirs
entre ses salariés et l'entreprise dans
un laps de temps très court
généralement c'est mieux de le faire
avec une signature d'un accord c'est
quand même mieux qu'on arrive à se
mettre d'accord sur six règles du jeu
social qui s'appliqueront à ses salariés
et donc c'est un peu une course contre
le contre le temps avec des enjeux et
chaque enjeu là encore en parler d'eux
les gens qui sont paradoxales en tout
cas les enjeux chacun est légitime leur
cohabitation est pas simple et là encore
faudra faire preuve à faire preuve de
mesure et de responsabilité pour trouver
les équilibres
d'un côté il faut que ces conditions
soient satisfaisantes pour les salariés
dont qu'ils aient envie de rentrer la
sncf s'ils ont pas envie de rater sncf
on aura un problème pour qu'il sente
bien une fois qu'ils disent aux folie's
envie d'y rester
il faut qu'ils soient épanouis par les
conditions qu'on leur propose les
formations les déroulements de carrière
les laits l'intérêt des emplois qu'on
leur propose et c'est donc ça il faut
que ce soit attractif il faut un cadre
social attractif de notre côté attention
aux coups au coût de la masse salariale
parce que dans nos coûts
la masa est un coût important donc dans
un moment de compétitivité dans un
moment de trajectoire financière
rigoureuse
il faut aussi faire attention à ce que
les le coude et des règles du jeu social
soit supportable par la société ou en
tout cas faut des contreparties de ti
polyvalence par exemple voilà on voit
bien apparaître des éléments de
négociation autour de l'attractivité du
cadre social et puis des éléments
d'engager sur nouvelles du travail qui
permettront d'obtenir les gains de
productivité dont nous sommes dont nous
avons besoin
deuxième élément est ce qu'il est la
difficulté c'est la nouveauté puisqu'il
faut se sortir des règles statutaires
c'est pas pour refaire le statut
or le statut est présent dans toutes les
têtes des cheminots et des syndicats
donc faut inventer quelque chose de
nouveau alors que la référence installé
c'est quelque chose dont on veut un peu
s'éloigner
voilà donc voyez un peu qu'elle est là
qu'est la difficulté qu'on connaît qu'on
doit gérer
deuxièmement on l'a dit il ya on a
devant nous un plan de productivité à un
niveau peut-être jamais fait c'est à
dire que pour tenir cette trajectoire
pour obtenir ces compétitivité il va
falloir être très attentifs auront
regagné sens du travail à l'efficience
c'est quelque chose qui est difficile
parce que ça va se traduire par des
baisses d'emploi
et les baisses d'emploi le corps social
n'est pas satisfait par les baisses
d'emploi ne même qu'à l'horizon
syndicale donc comment on va conduire
7.7 politique comment on va la faire
accepter comme moi aussi on va
accompagner les sujets humains qui vont
avec
parce que quand quelqu'un perd son
emploi c'est un sujet humain qu'il
s'agit d'anticiper qu'il s'agit
d'accompagner avait des sujets de
reconversion avait des sujets de comment
on trouve un emploi dans le bassin
d'emploi considéré voilà donc là on a
des vrais sujets de méthode et de mise
en oeuvre qui ont à l'évidence un enjeu
social important
troisièmement vous avez un sujet
identitaire c'est parfois les plus
difficiles mettez vous à la place des
cheminots innoncent avait quelques
années qui l'ont réforme sur réforme la
la la la réforme initial est un peu loin
c'est rff en 1996 salaire est un peu
avaler mais depuis 2014 ça n'arrête pas
depuis cinq ans vous avez réformes
structurelles sur réformes structurelles
qui secoue les organisations qui secoue
au fond même la vision la vision des
cheminots dans l'avenir de leur
entreprise et dans la relation avec
l'état a finalement l'état qu'est ce
qu'elle veut faire de la sncf ils
finissent par être un peu perdu
donc il est plus que temps de leur
donner une perspective de leur donner du
sens et ça sera un boulot important pour
moi de leur donner ce cap de les
rassurer quelque part sans les mots sans
leur mentir sur les éléments de
difficultés de notre environnement mais
mais qu'ils aient le sentiment quand
même qu'il ya un capitaine dans le
bateau et que le bateau il sait à peu
près ce qu'il veut accoster voilà il
faut juste se mettre à leur place c'est
absolument nécessaire
tout ça c'est l'intérêt de l'entreprise
et vous rajoutez à ça un dossier qui est
extérieur c'est pas le dossier de la
sncf c'est le dossier du pays
c'est le gouvernement qui veut installer
une un régime universel de retraite qui
bien sûr s'appliquera à tout le monde
puisqu'il est universel et donc qui
s'appliquera aux cheminots et donc qui
re va rediscuter remettre en question le
régime spécial des cheminots qui est à
la fois aujourd'hui considérée comme une
condition du contrat social passé par
l'esprit nous avaient leur entreprise
donc toujours connu ça et deuxièmement
en termes d'identitaires on en revient
là aussi qui est un marqueur très forts
de leurs spécificités cheminote voilà
donc là vous l'avez un élément de
difficulté supplémentaire ces deux
causes externes qui forcément va se
rajouter à l'agenda social
quand vous rajouter tout ça forcément on
dit ouais c'est pas mal
il ya quand même pas des sujets
sensibles qui va falloir discuter et
faire avancer dans l'entreprise la
méthode y en a pas trente-six la méthode
c'est le dialogue et le dialogue
respectueux et clair et lucide
c'est un préalable au moins 1 on verra
bien ce que ça produit mais c'est le
préalable il faut dialoguer avec qui
faut dialoguer mais les syndicats et
tous les syndicats même ceux qui sont
pas d'accord avec vous et il y en a
quelques-uns mais faut parler avec eux
pour les entendre parce que dans ce
qu'ils vous disent faut écouter ils vous
disent d'abord ils vous disent des
choses que pense une partie importante
des cheminots ils sont si représentative
d'une partie des cheminots dont si vous
nous écoutez pas vous écoutez pas les
cheminots qui pensent comme eux c'est
embêtant faut les écouter et au fond
regarder avec eux quel est le chemin on
peut partir de positions très
différentes et peut-être construire un
chemin qui est le moins mauvais des
chemins qui est le chemin accessible à
court terme
voilà et moi je suis un optimiste
fondamental je pense qu'il ya toujours
un chemin
même quand les situations sont
compliquées il ya toujours un chemin il
faut faire appel au sens des
responsabilités des uns et des autres
aux syndicats pour leur demander bien
sûr que les syndicats la sncf bloquer la
sncf on le sait c'est pas nouveau
c'était vrai hier c'est aujourd'hui et
ça le sera encore quelques temps mais
bloquer la sncf
est-ce que c'est lui rendre service
est-ce que c'est rendre service à
l'entreprise de l'empêcher de
fonctionner de l'empêcher de rendre ses
missions de service public de l'empêcher
de transporter les marchandises que les
chargeurs veut lui confier est-ce que
c'est comme ça qu'on prépare le futur de
la sncf est con là et qu on la renforce
voilà chacun est placé devant ses
responsabilités et chacun devra se
déterminer et rendre compte des
orientations des décisions et des des
impulsions qui donnera sur le corps
social
le dialogue social c'est pas que les
syndicats mais le syndicat cet important
et une boîte comme le cncm ne peut se
gérer qu'avec des syndicats quand vous
avez 100 5 145 1000 salariés pouvaient
pas avoir un happening avec 145 mille
personnes il vous faut des représentants
du personnel avec qui dialoguer c'est
essentiel à côté ça vous avez ce corps
social et moi mon ambition
même s'ils sont nombreux c'est d'aller
les voir je pense que je vais faire mes
meilleurs efforts pour dans ma tête j'ai
une fois par semaine je sais pas si
j'arriverai en tout cas souvent très
souvent aller sur le terrain parce qu'il
faut dialoguer avec les gens la honte
quand on écoute et dialogue
il faut expliquer faire de la pédagogie
finalement si on est d'accord pour dire
que ce projet d'acf d'un projet voulu
par les princes par les français au
travers de son gouvernement
c'est un projet qui bon pour le pays qui
est bon pour les français il est
difficile
il a une partie d'efforts mais au fond
ce projet qui vise à faire de la sncf un
champion mondial de la mobilité au
service des français et des territoires
ça s'explique ça se sache ce sas eux ont
fait de la pédagogie autour de ça on le
concrétise dans mon intention est
d'aller très régulièrement en contact
des cheminots pour parler avec eux
discuter avec eux et peut-être co
construire avec eux aussi ce chemin on
sait d'où on part on sait à peu près où
on veut aller il ya des marges de
manoeuvre sur le chemin des barres joël
temporel à quel rythme quand comment par
contre comment ce parc on se met
d'accord tout de suite qu est ce qui est
compliqué qu'on peut peut-être pousser
un peu plus loin qu'il faudra bien
reprendre quand ça sera murs etc etc
voilà et ce mouvement je n'aime plus ray
dès le premier jour de ma présidence et
je le poursuivrai autant que de besoin
voilà pour cette audition de jean pierre
farandou
le candidat désigné par l'elysée pour
succéder à guillaume pepy à la tête de
la sncf il a été auditionné ce matin par
les sénateurs de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire présidée par
le sénateur uc hervé maurey je vous
rappelle quelques mots du cv de jean
pierre farandou
c'est un ancien chef de gare actuelle
présidente du groupe keolis lors de son
audition il est notamment revenu sur le
fait qu'il a insisté sur le fait qu'il
fallait concilier service public et
efficacité économique
l'utilité sociale et environnementale et
pour lui au coeur de son projet pour la
sncf il devrait donc succéder à
guillaume pépy au 1er janvier 2020
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les auditions à toutes les
séances sur notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne fin de journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]